Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wie hast du deinen Mehrverdienst jetzt auf den Kopf? Du arme, arme Kirchenmaus.
Ja.
Nicht nur kein Geld, sondern oder mehr Geld, sondern auch kein Mechanismus, Gott gegeben, der es einfach über dich ergießt.
Das heißt, es gibt eine Inflation, es gibt einen allgemeinen Lohnanstieg.
Aber weniger Geld, willst dich beschweren jetzt.
Und dann würde ich einfach auch davon profitieren, würde mehr bekommen. Dann müsste ich vielleicht Bundestagsabgeordneter werden.
Zum Beispiel, Nico Simsrott dreht gerade große Runde, steht auf der Bühne und geht dann so die Privilegien der Parlamentarier, vor allem in der EU, durch und schließt da mit der Pointe, sieht es nicht aus wie Sozialismus. Und das Publikum so, ja stimmt, irgendwie sieht es aus nach Sozialismus. Jedenfalls, wir hatten es ja im kurzen Teaser für das Buch, das wird im nächsten Lesen schon angesprochen, es gab eine Diätenerhöhung. Und zwar automatisiert. 6% mehr Lohnniveau heißt 6% mehr Geld. In dem Falle Spiegel titelt Rekorderhöhung der Diäten, denn 11.227 Euro, mehr als 600 Euro mehr bedeutet das größte Plus seit fast 30 Jahren. Also im Grunde eine Wiedervereinigungs-Erfolgsgeschichte, mehr Geld, während ich sagen würde, wir laufen gerade alle durch diese Landschaft und stellen fest, ich brauche nicht nur Essen für mich, sondern vielleicht auch für das ein oder andere Kind. Ich gehe in einen Einkaufsladen, wo mir nichts zubereitet wird. Ich muss es alleine nach Hause tragen und es ist trotzdem gefühlt teurer, als wenn ich vor fünf Jahren ins Restaurant einfach gegangen wäre. Also ich weiß nicht genau, die Leute verdienen ja wirklich nicht viel in Deutschland. Und trotzdem kostet ein Einkauf mittlerweile so immer einfach standardmäßig erstmal 65 Euro. So ein halber Rucksack voll Essen irgendwie 65 Euro. Also es ist alles schräg, gut, der Automatismus nach oben. Also wenn man als Bundestagsabgeordneter einkaufen geht und sagt, oh, das ist aber teuer geworden, dann gibt es einen Automatismus, dann brauche ich auch mehr Geld. Und dann kommt das einfach. So, es ist so geregelt, es gab 2014 eine Kommission, die hat gesagt, Bundestagsabgeordnete sollen auf der Besoldungshöhe der Richter an den obersten Gerichtshöfen verdienen und dann jährlich nach Nominallohnindex eine Steigerung erhalten, die das Statistische Bundesamt ausweist und dann wird ohne Streik, ohne Streit, ohne Konflikt, ohne Aussprache im Bundestag einfach gesagt 6% mehr. So, und ich habe jetzt Claude, meine neue Lieblings-KI, weil GPT, wir distanzieren uns ein bisschen, wir reden heute gar nicht, gar nicht darüber eigentlich, vielleicht sehr wenig. Machen wir dann noch im Laufe des Monats, wir sind ja noch auf der Bühne dann nächsten Monat. Ich habe dann mal Claude, meine neue Lieblings-KI, von Anthropic gefragt. Gibt es eine Regelung zur Höhe der Mindestlöhne, die sich beispielsweise an Medien- oder Durchschnittslöhnen orientiert, so wie also die Diätenerhöhung am Nominallohnindex orientiert ist? Und die Antwort ist ja.
Und zwar auf eurer europäischer Ebene.
Auf allen Ebenen. Also das Mindestlohngesetz sieht vor, dass nach § 9 Absatz 2 Milo G, also Mindestlohngesetz, eine Mindestlohnkommission prüft und dann eine Gesamtabwägung macht im volkswirtschaftlichen Rahmen, den man so vorfindet. Aber das wird im Verlauf des Textes auch für alle verständlich zusammengebunden auf die Formulierung nachlaufend an der Tariflohnentwicklung. Also genau wie bei den Bundestagsabgeordneten. Man hat also grundsätzlich, sagt Claude, eine Orientierung an der allgemeinen Lohnentwicklung. Da hab ich Claude gefragt, gibt es das auch in der EU als Regelung? Ja, durchaus. EU-Richtlinie 2022, schrägstrich. Also die ist von 2022 und dann 2041. Schriftsatz also relativ spät im Jahr, 19. Oktober. Solche Sachen haben wir immer so ne zwei Jahre. Wir gewöhnen uns alle mal dran. Also die laufen jetzt auch ab Oktober 24. Da steht wortwörtlich drin, die Mitgliedsstaaten mit gesetzlichen Mindestlöhnen, also Deutschland zum Beispiel, ergreifen die erforderlichen Maßnahmen, um sicherzustellen, das und so weiter. Und dann wird aufgedröselt, a. Kaufkraft ist hier relevant, b. Das allgemeine Niveau der Bruttolöhne und ihre Verteilung, c. Die Wachstumsrate der Bruttolöhne, d. Arbeitsproduktivität. Also da kommt ganz schön viel rein. Da läuft ganz schön viel Wissen rein. Ich hab dann auch Claude direkt gefragt, wie sähe denn so eine Rechnung aus, wenn man das jetzt einfach mal durchgeht und stellt sich raus, ja, also man kann das selbst von Claude, wo es ja immer heißt, so ein LL kann nicht gut rechnet oder so, doch da ist so ein Taschenrechner angebunden und man kann, also man könnte den ganzen politischen Diskurs einfach mal kurz mit einem Einzeilerprompt bei Claude durchrechnen lassen, um eine Gesprächsgrundlage zu haben für eine Talkshow. Also bedeutet hier zum Beispiel Claude auf die 60% Bruttomedianeinkommen 43.750 Euro im Monat, 12 Monate, 3.645,83 Euro Medianeinkommen, davon 60%, 2.187, runtergebrochen auf 4,33 Wochen, 40 Stunden, bedeutet 12,62 Euro. Ist jetzt eine rein mathematische Rechnung. Wenn man das dann anpasst an diese ganzen politischen Überlegungen, die man da so hat, ist man relativ zügig bei diesen 14 oder 15 Euro. Die ja gerade im Raume stehen. Warum stehen sie im Raume? Scholz hat einen Mindestlohn-Vorschlag gemacht. Er hat dem Stern gesagt, ich bin klar dafür, den Mindestlohn erst auf 14 Euro, dann im nächsten Schritt auf 15 Euro anzuheben. Und mein Anlauf bis zu diesem Punkt ist, ja, der Kanzler hat es gesagt, der Kanzler ist ein Politiker. Wenn der Politiker spricht, ist es politische Kommunikation. Aber da gibt es eine Kalkulation dahinter. Sein Gehalt, das Gehalt aller, es gibt Gesetze, EU, national. Eigentlich ist das ein Argument, das zwangsläufig ist.
Und Kevin Kühnert ist aber gleich vor die Kameras getreten, hat gesagt, nein, so geht das nicht. Das müssen wir der Mindestlohn-Kommission überlassen. Also der vermeintliche sozialistische Kevin Kühnert ist also der, der jetzt den Kanzler zurückfällt. Das bitte nicht, die Forderungen zu links sind. Also wenn man mal beobachten will, wie sehr man sich anpassen kann in kürzester Zeit, dann bei Kühnert.
Wir kommen heute noch ein bisschen auf Kühnert. Irgendwer muss ja verteidigen, dass Guy Witt sagt, wir sind noch kein Denny-Staat, wenn die Leute die Biete nicht bezahlen können, kann der nicht der Staat jetzt plötzlich eingreifen. Also überall taucht dieser Kevin Kühnert auf. Ich will mal ein Beispiel, wo es härter formuliert ist, spielen. Gitta Kondermann, wir kennen sie von der CDU. Sie steht gerne mal als Beiberg rum oder als, falls der nächste Kanzler kommt und der ist von Blackrock entsandt, dann ist das die neue Sozialministerin oder wie auch immer. Gitta Kondermann von der CDU redet jetzt über diesen Umstand, dass der Politiker Olaf Scholz als Bundeskanzler publizistisch auftritt und sagt 15 Euro, weil Hintergrundrauschen der Gesetze und so. Und wieder sagen, nee, das muss erst von der Kommission zerredet werden wieder. Wir können nicht einfach die Mathematik gewähren gelassen. Bei Gitta Kondermann klingt das so.
Der 15-Prozent-Kanzler fordert 15 Euro Mindestlohn, aber im Grunde nach ist es natürlich das zweite Mal, dass er sein Wort bricht. Er hatte 2022 gesagt, wir werden als Politik einmal in den Mindestlohn eingreifen. Danach aber nicht wieder. Und jetzt tut er es wieder. Und damit löst er auch einen politischen Überbietungswettbewerb aus. Das ist absolut schädlich.
Ja, das ist absolut schädlich. Was man nicht hört, aber sieht, ist, Gitta Kondermann ist natürlich Vorsitzender der Mittelstandsunion. Das heißt, sie spricht hier nicht für den Wähler, der vielleicht demnächst BlackRock zum Bundeskanzler wählen soll, sondern sie spricht hier für ihre Klientel. Also diejenigen, die den Mindestlohn bezahlen sollen, hat sie natürlich was dagegen. Würde ich sagen, okay, im politischen Gefecht, wenn man das ordentlich markiert, sollte man das darstellen, dass es da auch Arbeitgeber gibt im Gefüge. Aber was ich dann nicht verstehe, ist zum Beispiel beim Deutschlandfunk die Pressesschau zu hören, wo es dann folgende kleine Snippets gibt.
Der Kölner Stadtanzeiger kritisiert, inzwischen ist klar, die Sozialdemokraten wollen den Mindestlohn grundsätzlich politisch und nicht nach volkswirtschaftlichen Kriterien bestimmen. Ein riskantes Manöver.
Nee, die 14, 15 Euro sind ja die volkswirtschaftliche.
Ich muss auch gerade so lachen, weil ich auch jemanden kenne, der mal beim Kölner Stadtanzeiger gearbeitet hat. Also beim Kölner Stadtanzeiger die Löhne. Die sind jetzt, sagen wir mal so, da gehört man jetzt nicht zu den reichen Leuten, in Deutschland. Und das finde ich dann immer so lustig, wenn diese Leute, die selber wahrscheinlich äußerste Mühe haben, in Köln noch bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu finden, die wahrscheinlich schon in Königswinter wohnen und dann beim Kölner Stadtanzeiger arbeiten und hoffen, dass sie häufig Homeoffice machen können, dass diese Leute dann noch mal aufschreiben, also jetzt bloß nicht die Löhne erhöhen.
Ja, das passt nicht zusammen. Ich finde, dass allein der Kölner Stadtanzeiger glaubt, da noch mal einen Kommentar machen zu müssen. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie vorher eine Berichterstattung aus eigenem Hause zu dem Thema haben, sondern wahrscheinlich nur diesen Kommentar. In der Hinsicht ist das schon, und vor allem in dieser Eckenbrüller, dass es dann auch beim Deutschlandfunk anlandet, als dass es Deutschland denkt so am nächsten Morgen. Wir müssen die Hörer darüber informieren. Das ist ja wirklich schräg. Aber richtig bestürzend finde ich auch, wie verlogen die Diskussion, sagen wir mal so im politischen Vorfeld ist. Micky Beisenherz hat einen Podcast, der Apokalypse und Filter-Café heißt, sich also um Nachrichten kümmert, aber doch mit so einem lustigen Anflug, Humor und so weiter. Er selber hat ja jetzt eine jahrzehntelange Karriere im Privatfernsehen gemacht, wo quasi Drehbücher für soziale Konflikte, die als Reality-TV laufen, also Dschungelcamp und so weiter, ausgetragen werden. Und dass jemand mit so viel diebischer Freude an dieser persönlichen Kontroversen und dem Wissen, wie man sie orchestriert, dann Lars Klingweil als SPD-Chef im Podcast hat und ihm die Frage zum Mindestlohn und Olaf Scholz Beitrag so stellt, finde ich wirklich, es kommt so sanft daher, aber man müsste es wirklich mal an Grund und Boden diskutieren, was da so als latente Sinnstruktur eigentlich mitkommt.
Finanzminister Lindner fordert alle Koalitionspartner und die einzelnen Ministerien auf zu sparen. Und in dem Moment kommt plötzlich der Bundeskanzler und sagt, so ein Mindestlohn auf 15 Euro, das wäre doch eine feine Sache. Während wiederum die FDP sagt, naja, die Rente mit 63, also das können wir uns auch langsam mal sparen. Also ist das jetzt einfach nur Payback-Time? Ist es Wahlkampf im Hinblick auf die Europawahl und die Landtagswahlen im Osten? Ist es die pure Menschenliebe? Also was soll das jetzt? Es ist doch eh schon alles andere als ruhig in der Koalition. Wieso denn jetzt auch noch der Mindestlohn von 15 Euro?
Du, ich hab da mit dem Kanzler schon oft drüber geredet. Insofern weiß ich, dass das seine Position ist. Er war hoch unzufrieden damit, dass die Arbeitgeberseite sich in dieser Mindestlohn-Kommission so einseitig durchgesetzt hat. Bisher war das immer total etabliert, dass man gemeinsam etwas festlegt. Und dann haben die gesagt, nö, obwohl das Leben teurer geworden ist, sollen die Menschen jetzt nicht den Mindestlohn bekommen, der eigentlich angemessen wäre, sondern eben 12,42 Euro. Oder jetzt irgendwie 12,82 Euro. Und da sind wir uns einig, Kanzler, ich und andere, das ist zu wenig.
Ja, es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, dass man nur noch in diesem Modus denken kann, wie bauen wir das Dschungelcamp in diesem Jahr zusammen? Also so redet und denkt ja Micky Beisenherz, der ja selbst einen Stundenlohn von wahrscheinlich zweieinhalbtausend bis fünftausend Euro verlangt, wenn der irgendwo eingeladen wird. Nehm ich mal an. So, das ist so etwa, also so ein Monatsmindestlohn. Genau, der bekommt den Monatsmindestlohn in einer Stunde. So das wird der Betrag sein, wird ja von allen hofiert und so weiter. Und dass er jetzt nur in diesem Modus darüber nachdenken kann und nicht darüber nachdenken kann, dass das vielleicht das Leben von etwa 20 Prozent der in Deutschland Arbeitenden verbessern würde. Und zwar substanziell.
Es ist ja dieser Modus im Hintergrund, ich bin schon da für die Leute und bin auch im besten Ansinn für sie unterwegs. Nur, und dann expliziert er quasi, mir ist wichtiger, dass sich die Ampel nicht streitet und nicht jetzt auch noch der mit dem komischen Vorschlag um die Ecke kommt. Wir hungern doch extra dafür, dass sich die Ampel nicht streitet. Wieso streiten die sich trotzdem? So ungefähr. Also da liegt so der fast religiöse Überbande-Spielen, wer hier Opfer, wer sich opfert für irgendwen, damit es allen gut geht. Also der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt ist, wenn Christian Lindner nicht gereizt wird jetzt mit dem nächsten irren Vorschlag und so. Dafür hungern wir auch gerne.
Also die anderen hungern dafür gerne, eher natürlich nicht.
Meine Zuhörer im Grunde genommen. Er spricht so stellvertretend für die Zuhörer. Interessanterweise ist Lars Klinkenball dann auch nicht in der Lage, einfach zu sagen, naja, man kann es einfach durchrechnen. Fragen Sie Claude, der Prompt ist eine Zeile, Sie kriegen eine Antwort, die wird Sie zufriedenstellen. Da ist quasi alles erklärt. Sondern er hebt es direkt auf diese von Micky Beisenherz abgezielte persönliche, nein, der Kanzler ist dieser Meinung und ich bin es auch und wir haben halt eine gute Meinung. Da kann man auch anderer Meinung sein, aber unsere Meinung ist irgendwie besser oder sowas. Also auf der Ebene. Während der dafür zuständige Hubertus Heil ja im Bundestag steht und einfach, wenn auch dann immer nur kurz, aber Klartext redet.
Finden Sie sich mal einmal vor, wir hätten den Mindestlohn nicht erhöht auf 12 Euro. Da haben wir als Koalition das ja gemeinsam gemacht. Es war eine Lohnerhöhung von 22 Prozent. CDU hat sich heldenhaft enthalten. Und jetzt ist auch klar, der Mindestlohn muss weiter steigen. Und da ist die Mindestlohnkommission dran. Es gibt übrigens auch im Gesetz ein Kriterium. Und das sagt sehr deutlich, dass 60 Prozent des mittleren Einkommens bei der Beurteilung, ob es ein angemessener Mindestlohn ist, wie das in die EU-Richtlinie auch vorsieht, jetzt schon im Gesetz ein Kriterium ist. Und ich erwarte, dass in der Mindestlohnkommission die Sozialpartner einheitlich und gemeinsam entscheiden, weil das das Vertrauen auch in die Fortentwicklung des Mindestlohns stärkt. Aber sie haben recht, das kann nicht das Einzige bleiben. Besser als eine Lohnuntergrenze an Mindestlohn sind immer Tariflöhne in Deutschland. Und deshalb werden wir in diesem Jahr noch auf den Weg bringen, ein Tarifstärkungsgesetz, was dazu führt, dass öffentliche Aufträge des Bundes zum Beispiel nur an tarifgebundene Unternehmen gehen, die nach Tarif bezahlen. Das stärkt die Tarifbindung, auch die Löhne, damit Arbeit sich mehr lohnt in Deutschland.
Man ist ja sowieso verblüfft darüber, dass das noch nicht so ist, dass man also öffentlich Aufträge vergibt an Unternehmen, die sich nicht an die Tarifbindung halten.
Naja, der Staat gibt ja da vor allem auch viele Bauaufträge. Da kannst du gar nicht groß, weil du es einfach gar nicht durchschaust. Also wenn du da anfängst, so ein Ding aufzuziehen, da fehlen noch viel mehr Gesetze. Aber ich finde, man könnte jetzt nicht nur beim Thema Krieg in der Ukraine, Krieg in Gaza oder so immer mal wieder auf eine, nee, wir haben eine regelbasierte Ordnung. Wir wissen, Protagonisten, Konflikte und so weiter, aber wir haben auch regelbasierte Ordnungen. In dem Falle eben so wie Heil und das dann auch wieder bezeichnet. Du hast auf der einen Seite so ewig lange Podcasts, Gelabergespräche und im Bundestag eine Anfrage der, also wie nennt man diese Frage? Stunden der Bundesregierung, tausend Fragen. Und dann immer nur 30 Sekunden Antwort, 30 Sekunden Frage. So und da wünscht man sich doch, dass dann wenigstens Lars Kling bei sich in einem Podcast mal 30 Sekunden nimmt, um auf die regelbasierte Ordnung des Mindestlohns hinzuweisen. Ein Clip noch von Heil im Bundestag, denn all das muss man ja auch noch mal einbetten in diese fortlaufenden, bescheuerten Diskussionen der CDU zum Thema Bürgergeld. So Bürgergeld ist ja angeblich immer zu hoch. Warum? Lohnabstandsgebot und dann schweigen sie ja zum Mindestlohn. So wie jetzt Heil hier auch schon den Bogen gespannt hat. Na ja, der Mindestlohn muss so und so. Und eigentlich brauchen wir doch ordentliche Tariflöhne, weil der Mindestlohn ist ja dann gesetzlich da. Nachlaufen, also kümmern wir uns erstmal zumindest da, wo wir wirtschaftlich eingreifen als Auftraggeber, um eine ordentliche Linie. Und die CDU blendet ja sowas komplett aus. Also für die gibt es ja nur Bürgergeld. Das ist doch alles Betrüger und so. Deswegen von Heil noch mal kurz. Und wir wissen jetzt, wie viel die CDU in allen Kanälen übers Bürgergeld geredet hat. So und Heil macht jetzt noch mal einen Aufruf an die CDU zum Thema Mindestlohn.
Sie müssen ihr Thema Mindestlohn mal als CDU für sich klären. Wir sind dafür, dass sich der Mindestlohn weiterentwickelt und dass wir unsere und mittlere Einkommen in Deutschland entlasten, damit Arbeit sich noch stärker lohnt. Das ist der Unterschied. Sie schweigen zum Thema Löhne.
Ja, die CDU redet so gerne übers Bürgergeld und über die anderen Themen gar nicht. Und zwar nirgendwo zu reden. Auch nicht im parlamentarischen Betrieb. Das muss man sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen. Es sind Verlegenheitssachen, die da kommen. Bürgergeld einfach nur, um so ein Stimmungsding zu setzen, wo man auch weiß, der Wähler, auf den wir abzielen, der identifiziert sich niemals mit Bürgergeldempfängern.
Genau.
So, und dann hält man sich einfach die Mindestlohn-Diskussion so vom Hals.
Und der würde auch nie auf die Idee kommen, dass möglicherweise er mehr Lohn verdient hätte. Dann ist das so, wie es ist. Und wenn ich zu wenig bekomme, dann sind die Bürgergeldempfänger und oder die Ausländer daran schuld.
Genau. Man macht dann diese Auswege. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Thema zu tun, bei dem wir immer auf die regelbasierte Ordnung abstellen können. Und wenn irgendwer kommt und sagt, das sollte volkswirtschaftlich entschieden werden, dann sagen wir, naja, das ist die volkswirtschaftliche Entscheidung. Der Staat als Player, der Märkte erschafft, absichert, garantiert mit juristischen und ökonomischen Haltelinien, Grenzziehung, Untergrenzen, Obergrenzen, wie man es auch immer definiert. Einfach diese Selbstrautlogik übernehmen, macht es wie bei den Bundestagsabgeordneten. Automatismus, wir haben ihn, wir können ihn anwenden, fertig. Keine Diskussion.
Ja, du hast sicherlich auch das Grundgesetz gefeiert in diesem Monat.
Natürlich.
Die Bildzeitung hat ja große Umfragen gemacht. Was ist Deutschland für dich? Und ich will die schönste Antwort mitbringen. Was ist Deutschland für dich? Ja, was liebst du an Deutschland? Und 75 Jahre Grundgesetz, da fragt man also die Prominenz, was denn das Tolle an Deutschland ist, an 75 Jahren Grundgesetz, Bundesrepublik etc. Und die schönste Antwort kam natürlich von Carmen Geis. Die Frau von Robert. Genau. Sie sagt, ich liebe Deutschland, weil es wirklich ein wunderschönes Land ist. Es gibt unglaublich viele schöne Seen und Berge. Die Landschaft in Deutschland beeindruckt mich einfach. Und wir wissen, die Seen und die Berge sind dank des Grundgesetzes entstanden. Ein Hoch auf die Gründerväter und Mütter und auf die Bundesregierung.
Vor allem ist es so interessant, dass sie als diejenige, die ganz Deutschland in so ein, wie soll man sagen, du kannst ja alles kaufen und so weiter, dann genau die Sachen nennen, die man sich nun mal nicht für Geld kaufen kann, sondern die wirklich allgemein gut sind.
Und die auch nichts mit politischer Macht zu tun haben. Also wenn hier jemand anders regieren würde, wären die Seen und Berge vermutlich immer noch da.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich ist es gar nicht so der große CSU-Erfolg, dass die 3000 Meter Berge die paar, die wir haben, in Bayern stehen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Man müsste es Söder schonend beibringen. Ja, jetzt machen wir hier ja manchmal preaching to the choir, in dem wir sagen, dass die FDP wenig Einfluss hat und so weiter. Aber ich will jetzt nicht so weit gehen und sagen, ich habe in den letzten Wochen Christian Lindner liebgewonnen. Aber in gewisser Weise sage ich jetzt...
Auf freundschaftlicher Basis bist du schon mit ihm.
Ich sage es jetzt nur halb ironisch, dass ich zum Anhänger der Schuldenbremse geworden bin. Und ich will das ein bisschen ausführen, wenn du gestattet bist.
Die Hörer ballen die Fäuste. Ich auch.
Alle sind wütend. Vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen Selbstbefragung. Hat man sich nicht vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr verliebt in diesen Gedanken, die Schuldenbremse muss abgeschafft werden, egal wofür? Man kann ja mal darüber nachdenken, wofür wird die Schuldenbremse abgeschafft oder wofür sollte man die Schuldenbremse abschaffen? Ich glaube, ich muss hier nicht noch mal erwähnen, und wir sprechen ja heute noch über das Bauen. Wir haben jetzt schon Soziales angesprochen, dass der Staat mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen müsste und dass die Schuldenbremse uns da bremst. Und dass ich natürlich, was das alles anbelangt, sehr gegen die Schuldenbremse bin. Und daran wird sich ja auch nichts ändern. Aber wir haben jetzt alle diesen tollen Streit noch mal miterlebt. Marie-Agnes Strack Zimmermann wirft dem Kanzler autistische Züge vor in Fragen der Aufrüstung und der Behandlung der Ukraine.
Aber hast du ihre Entschuldigung gehört?
Und sie entschuldigt sich jetzt bei den Menschen, die im autistischen Bereich tätig sind. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das meint, aber es ist bestimmt gut gemeint von ihr. Jedenfalls fand ich das so kurios, dass sie sich noch mal den Kanzler ausgesucht hat, um sich an ihm abzuarbeiten. Denn wenn ich jetzt mal ganz kurz mich in die Position von Straks Zimmermann hineinversetze und die einmal teilen würde, dann würde ich ja überlegen, wer steht meinem Anliegen am allermeisten im Wege? Und dann wäre das natürlich nicht der Kanzler, sondern es wäre Christian Lindner. Ich möchte sogar so weit gehen und sagen, Christian Lindner ist gerade ein großer Pazifist aus Versehen. Christian Lindner wird aufgefordert von Pistorius, mehr Milliarden zu liefern. Lindner sagt, wir müssen hier ganz sparsam sein. Roderich Kiesewetter, der Hardliner der CDU, sagt, der Krieg lässt sich nur mit Schulden gewinnen. Und dann sagt Pistorius, man muss mal darüber nachdenken, es gibt da so eine verfassungsrechtliche Konkordanz. Also was er damit meint, momentan ist das so, dass die Aufrüstung und die Schuldenbremse gleichwertig behandelt werden und sich damit ausbremsen. Was er eigentlich möchte, ist, dass die Aufrüstung über der Schuldenbremse steht. Dies ist ziemlich exakt das, was die CDU auf europäischer Ebene in ihrem Programm fordert. Nämlich, dass man sagt, ja, wir sind für die Austeritätspolitik, aber bei der Verschuldung für Rüstung müssen wir das so regeln, dass diese Art der Verschuldung nicht in die allgemeine Rechnung der Maastricht-Kriterien mit einfließt. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, aber wenn die Schuldenbremse gelockert wird, dann ist weniger Druck auf den anderen Haushalten da. Das ist ja eine Argumentation, die beispielsweise auch Adam Toos schon häufig vorgetragen hat. Ich glaube das tatsächlich nicht. Wenn man sich die Programme ansieht von SPD, CDU, Grüne und FDP, FDP will sowieso Austrieteilspolitik weiter betreiben. Aufrüstung ja, aber sagt gar nicht, wie das dann leistbar ist. Aber bei den anderen drei genannten Parteien wird es so sein, dass man die Schuldenbremse wahrscheinlich bei der nächsten Wahl, nach der nächsten Wahl abschaffen wird. Sehr wahrscheinlich. Aber man wird nicht dann damit, und deswegen sage ich, es haben sich viele Leute sehr verliebt in die Abschaffung der Schuldenbremse, man wird nicht damit den sozialen Wohnungsbau finanzieren, man wird damit nicht mehr Bürgergeld gestatten, man wird damit nicht Schwimmbäder bauen, die Kommunen entlasten etc. Das wäre dann auch alles möglich. Dazu fehlt aber dann der politische Wille. Sondern man wird sagen, wir haben die Schuldenbremse aufgegeben und sorgen nun dafür, dass wir in einem ganz, ganz großen Stil aufrüsten. Denn de facto ist es ja so, diese ganze CDU-Rede vom zu hohen Bürgergeld, wenn man sich einfach mal ansieht, wie der Haushalt verteilt ist, dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, beim Bürgergeld zu kürzen. Und selbst wenn man es halbieren würde, dann könnte man da ein paar Panzer kaufen, aber das wäre nicht so relevant. Man müsste die Rente, die ja über 100 Milliarden im Jahr bezuschusst wird, müsste man also halbieren. Dann könnte man sagen, wir haben jetzt richtig viel Geld. Da kann man ja mal in die Talkshow gehen und sagen, ja, also wir haben uns jetzt mal überlegt, wir halbieren die Rente. Was dann los ist. Also ist überhaupt nicht möglich. Das heißt, man kann mit dieser Aufrüstungsdiskussion natürlich dafür sorgen, dass man noch Lisa Paus zwei Milliarden abknöpft oder so, die sie dann nicht ausgeben darf. Aber das alles ist nicht relevant. Das heißt, wir werden eine Hegemonie wahrscheinlich bekommen, die dahin läuft, dass die Schuldenbremse abgeschafft wird. Und dann werden viele MMTler und so mal kurz jubeln. Aber ich sage es hier deutlich, es wird nicht ein einziges progressives Projekt dann verwirklicht werden, sondern man wird nur noch mehr aufrüsten. Und das hat noch eine oder hat zwei Problematiken, vielleicht sogar drei. Einmal wird sehr viel Arbeitskraft dadurch wieder gebunden werden, die man woanders benötigen braucht, die man woanders benötigt. Zweitens, wenn wir mehr Waffen produzieren, werden wir noch mehr exportieren Waffen, wir werden noch mehr in Konflikte involviert sein. Du hast das ja mal sehr gut gezeigt mit Adam Toos im Salon, was Staatsräson eigentlich meint. Das meint Waffenlieferung nach Israel und inwieweit man da verquickt ist. Und drittens ist das natürlich ökologisch ein ziemliches Desaster.
Gegenrede, die ist natürlich jetzt zwingend.
Zwingend.
Und ich versuche eine Einflugschneise zu finden, indem ich hier mit Christian Lindner selbst versuche, ein nicht Gegenargument, aber ein Gegengedankenraum aufzumachen. Christian Lindner stand nämlich jetzt auf der Bühne des Finanzministeriums. Ich hab's mit Mick im Fernsehpodcast geschaut. Also es gibt einen O-Ton davon, wie er sagt, darauf, dass Boris Pistorius jetzt losgeschickt wurde, um zu sagen, ganz explizit, Schuldenbremse geht so nicht, denn Verteidigung. So, damit hat ja die SPD für sich zwei Entscheidungen getroffen. Wir schicken den Kanzler der Herzen vor, um das Thema zu besetzen. Und wir verknüpfen die Schuldenbremse jetzt mit dem, den Deutschen gerade am wichtigsten Thema. Weil Verteidigung ist ja auch so ein, wie soll man sagen, ein Thema, bei dem jeder betroffen ist. Also auch Carmen Geiss kann sich nicht davon freikaufen, dass wenn ein Verteidigungsfall, dann brennt der Wald. Und sie weder den Wald noch die Gegenwehr kann sie selber organisieren aus ihrem Privatvermögen. Sie könnte sich höchstens ein Zaun bauen für ihr kleines Grundstück. Und in dieser Gemengelage, in der Christian Lindner in die Enge getrieben wurde, sagte er den Satz, fiskalische Resilienz ist auch ein Teil der Verteidigungspolitik. So, und wenn jetzt fiskalische Resilienz, also darben, sparen, hungern, mit zur Verteidigungspolitik gehört, würde ich sagen, dann lass uns doch die Schuldenbremse so weit abräumen, dass wir wieder in so ein vor 2009er-Ding kommen. Da gab es ja auch eine Schuldenbremse. Nur ebenso als goldene Regel. So viel, wie wir investieren, dürfen wir auch uns verschulden. Also es war halt nicht so streng. Und dann lass uns doch in so einen Zustand zurückgehen und einfach alles als Verteidigungspolitik deklarieren. So wie wir ja auch schon gesagt haben, die Landesverteidigung mit der Waffe an der Hand zur Grenze laufen, ist überhaupt nur erklärbar und logisch vernünftig, wenn es an der Heimatfront stimmt. Wenn man sich darauf verlassen kann, dass das restliche Leben gut funktioniert. Und damit, finde ich, fällt alles unter. Und dann kann man den Grundbegriff austauschen. Resilienz. Die pädagogische Resilienz ist auch ein Teil der Verteidigungspolitik.
Man könnte das so machen und ich stimme dir zu. Ich will in keiner Weise widersprechen, nur ich schaue mir an, wo sind die politischen Mehrheiten? Welcher politische Wille hat sich gebildet? Und der hat offenbar nicht dein Konzept verfolgt, dieser politische Wille, der sich da gebildet hat, sondern es ist ein anderer Wille. Ich glaube, wir sind eher in einer Situation, die den 80er Jahren gleicht. Und zwar der Reagan-Jahre in den USA. Reagan hat den Sozialstaat beschnitten, wo er konnte. Das ging auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt. Das sieht man ja gerade beim Bürgergeld. Auch da ist jetzt Verfassungsgericht sowieso schon dazwischen. Aber ja, man kann Leute arm machen und man kann sie noch ein bisschen ärmer machen, aber das hat doch Grenzen. Man kann ihnen nichts geben. Dafür sind die Summen einfach zu niedrig, um da entsprechend dann noch mehr Geld zu bekommen, indem man kürzt. Und was hat Dragon gemacht? Der hat den Sozialstaat ein bisschen sehr hart angefasst und hat aber zugleich wahnsinnig viele Schulden gemacht für die Aufrüstung, weil er die Möglichkeit hatte. Also in den USA gibt es ja bis heute diese Art der Schuldenbremse nicht. Und was ich glaube, ist, dass wir generell auf der europäischen Ebene sehen. Von der Line ist, und wir haben das hier im Podcast sehr häufig dokumentiert, vier, fünf Jahre lang damit hausieren gegangen, jetzt haben wir hier unseren Mann auf dem Mond, das wird unsere neue grüne Transformation. Keiner wollte das hören. Das wurde ja oft in den Medien noch nicht mehr reportiert. Du hast es irgendwo rausgefischt und dann hier vorgespielt. Und das funktioniert nicht. Wenn jetzt aber von der Line mit Meloni, mit anderen zusammen, und damit kommen wir gleich schon zum nächsten Themenkomplex, sagt Aufrüstung, wir müssen die NATO stärken, dann funktioniert das, aber dann ist diese grüne Transformation, die kann vielleicht noch irgendwo mitlaufen, aber das wird nicht der Kern sein. Deswegen noch einmal, natürlich bin ich nach wie vor jemand, der sagt, die MMT hat da einen sehr guten Ansatz. Und ich halte nach wie vor die Schuldenbremse für falsch in Bezug auf die eigentlichen Investitionen, die getätigt werden müssten. Aber wenn ich mir die politischen Mehrheiten gerade ansehe und wenn ich mir den allgemeinen öffentlichen Diskurs ansehe, inklusive Anne Will denkt darüber nach, wir könnten doch ganz viele Bunker bauen, dann bin ich mir sicher, dass die Schuldenbremse fallen wird. Und zwar wahrscheinlich spätestens dann, wenn die CDU regiert und dann wahrscheinlich am ersten Tag. Aber dies wird nicht dazu führen, dass eine Sozialwohnung mehr entsteht, dass ein Kulturzentrum mehr errichtet wird oder irgendein Schwimmbad. Deshalb warne ich davor und sage das auch ganz direkt an diese MMTler, ich warne davor, sich einfach nur in die Idee der Abschaffung der Schuldenbremse zu verlieben. Es muss immer um politische Mehrheiten gehen. Und deswegen habe ich einen Clip mitgebracht. Und das war ganz zufällig. Ich hatte also diese Provokation mir heute schon zurechtgelegt im Kopf und fand dann gestern noch zufällig einen Clip, der aber relativ neu ist, zwei Wochen alt, von Yuval Noah Harari. Und der guckt sich mal an, was eigentlich so ausgegeben wurde für Rüstung. Es ist ein längerer Clip, aber wir sollten uns ihn mal ganz zu Gemüte führen.
Für die meisten der menschliche Geschichte war der Nummer eins, das auf dem Budget jedes Königs, jedes König, jedes Republik, jedes Stadtstaat der Militär war. Mehr als 50% des Budgets des Roman Empires, zum Beispiel, wurden auf Soldaten gespart, auf die Fortifikationen, auf die Waffen und so weiter. Das war das gleiche bei fast jedem alten, medizinischen und frühmöden König. Wenn man sich in den ersten 20. Jahrhunderten anschaut, dann während der Weltkrieg hat die Briten etwa 50% des Budgets des Militärs. Das war die normale Situation. Jahrhunderten schaut, ist das vielleicht eine der optimistischsten Unterrichtsmaterialien der Welt.
Um sich das zu vergegenwerfen, 50%, 70% des gesamten Staatshaushaltes für das Militär. Das ist so unglaublich. Also wir reden jetzt da über Ideen, dass man vielleicht auf 10% kommt oder so etwas. Oder noch ein bisschen höher. Aber wir sind weit davon eigentlich entfernt. Aber nun.
Weil du findest, dass weltweit, die ganzen Länder in Bezug aufs Militär die gesamte Ergänzung aufs Militär von 7% des Regierungsbudgets waren. Im Vergleich, die Ergänzung aufs Gesundheitswesen hat sich auf 10% des Budgets erhöht. Und das war unvorstellbar für die meisten der Geschichte. Und das wurde tatsächlich erreicht. Es ist kein Pessimistisches Fantasie für die Zukunft. Es wurde tatsächlich erreicht. In den letzten Jahren sehen wir die Wiesnachkommission in vielen Teilen der Welt, auch in meiner Region des Mittelästers. Denn die Wiesnachkommission war nicht ein Ergebnis eines gewissen Mirakuls, ein Ergebnis eines Veränderings in der Natur. Es war ein Ergebnis von Menschen, die ihr eigenes Behaviour verändern. Und sie können es wieder verändern. Aber einfach realisieren, dass der Niveau der Gewalt nicht konstant ist.
Die Zeiten, in denen wir 70, 80 Prozent, ich würde jetzt weniger so im staatlichen Budget, sondern mehr so im staatlichen Engagement begriffen bleiben. Das kommt aus einer Zeit, in der Nachwuchs kein Problem war, also zahlenmäßig. Oder anders ausgedrückt, Nachwuchs war ein Problem, man wusste nicht wohin. Junge Männer, die sich ganze Zeit prügeln wollen, was machen wir eigentlich mit denen? Naja, wir stecken sie mal in der Kaserne, wo sie den ganzen Tag über eine sinnvolle Aufgabe, eine Handlungsorientierung und dann eine Zielgerichtetheit bekommen. Das heißt, man hat in einer Organisation, die gerade so zu suchte nach einer Aufgabe und es war am einfachsten, ihnen einfach eine militärische zu geben. Das kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen, aber bis zum Anfang des letzten Jahrhunderts, Hitlerjugend und so weiter, da ging es einfach darum, die größte Gruppe der Bevölkerung, die man nicht im Zaum erhalten kann, weil deren Elterngeneration zu 30 Prozent in Arbeitslosigkeit und so weiter, also riesige Konflikte, mit sich selbst austragen muss. Die muss man irgendwie organisieren. Also steckt man sie in solche Jugendorganisationen, bindet sie relativ nah an die Politik an und hat dann halt Massenparteiorganisationen, die irgendwie eine Zielrichtung brauchen. Also es gibt da auch so einen, ich will nicht sagen Automatismus, aber eine funktionale Erklärung dafür, warum das so ist. Jetzt hat sich ja alles verdreht. Nicht mal China ist in der Lage, Taiwan zu überfallen, weil sie einfach die Kalkulation vorher nicht hinkriegen. Also die wissen einfach nicht, was bedeutet das jetzt so weltweit? Sind da jetzt Kill-Switches in diesen Anlagen? Könnten wir da eh nichts mit diesen Chips machen? Zerstören wir damit alles? Also auch unsere eigene Produktion? Wie sieht dann die Antwort der Welt aus? Und der ganze Kram. Also man kriegt es einfach ökonomisch. Damals war es folgerichtig, Ökonomie, also den Staat einfach über seine Verteidigungsfähigkeit aufzubauen. Heute geht genau das Umgekehrte, weil sich eben die demografische Lage einfach groß umgekehrt hat. Und wir haben heute...
Aber wohin erklärst du dir dann, dass wir trotzdem in einer solchen Aufrüstungsspirale uns jetzt gerade befinden?
Also diese Aufrüstungsspirale gerade, also jetzt gerade, die wir in Deutschland zum Beispiel haben...
Nee, weltweit haben wir die ja.
Ich nehme die Deutsche, die wir so kennen. Ja. Zwei Prozent Ziel, Rheinmetalle sponsert jetzt Borussia Dortmund und lauter solche Sachen. Dortmund sagt dann auch noch als Verein, wir wollen damit ein Thema setzen. So ein Diskussionspunkt. Für mich ist das so eine Hysterie. Und zwar wirklich vergleichbar mit, wir brauchen jetzt eine Impfpflicht. Das ist ganz wichtig. Und alle sind sich so einig, dass selbst der Bundeskanzler, der jedes Thema scheut, einfach auf der Bühne sitzt und sagt, ja, das ist total vernünftig, eine Impfpflicht zu machen. Drei Monate später wollte davon niemand etwas wissen. Was haben wir für einen Stress gehabt, irgendwelche Güterwagen mit militärischen Mitteln, wenn auch in Hand der Polizei, in der Schweiz aufzuhalten, um zu sagen, das wird jetzt hier nicht exportiert. Worum ging es? Masken. So, jetzt vier Jahre später, wir können es uns gar nicht mehr richtig vorstellen, China überflutet den Weltmarkt mit Masken. Keiner kommt gerade in Deutschland auf die Idee, hier eine eigene Maskenproduktion aufzuziehen, obwohl das damals so zwingend war. So, meine Vermutung ist, Donald Trump wurde jetzt verurteilt. Es wird diesen Wahlkampf noch mal zuspitzen. Es wird keine Wählerstimme verändern. Also er wird weiterhin gewählt werden. Er wird sich noch mehr in der Defensive sehen. Er wird noch mehr den Ratschlägen folgen, jetzt einfach weltweit ein großes Zeichen zu setzen. Er wird sich mit Putin verständigen. Der Krieg wird aufhören. Wir werden alle irgendwie so ein bisschen aufatmen, weil wir denken, ja, die sind zwar irre, aber die haben es jetzt in der Hand und es steht in Frieden im Raum. Wer ist hat denn ernsthaft was gegen den Frieden und sagt dann, ne, wir Europäer sollen jetzt ohne Amerika diesen Krieg weiterführen? Also dieser Krieg wird ein Ende finden.
Aber die Amerikaner könnten ja auch sagen, ne, der Krieg ist schon wichtig, aber wichtig ist, dass ihr den bezahlt und führt.
Ja, irgend sowas. Und dann wird man feststellen, ne, wir Europäer schaffen es nicht.
Aber man möchte es ja schaffen. Ja, das ist ja diese Hysterie. Ja, aber da würde ich ja schon sagen, dass der Unterschied zwischen der Geopolitik und Corona ist. Corona war ja dann aufgrund von Omikron, aufgrund davon, dass sich auch einfach viele Leute haben impfen lassen, ohne eine Pflicht, vorbei. Und hier würde ich sagen, ja, der Ukraine-Krieg mag enden. Und möglicherweise hast du recht, dass dieses Szenario da eintritt mit Trump. Möglicherweise ist aber auch so, dass tatsächlich Europa sagt, wir kümmern uns drum und dann wird es richtig teuer und auch richtig gefährlich. Aber wie dem auch sei, dieser eine Krieg, wenn er dann vorbei ist, beendet ja nicht alle Kriege, sondern wir haben ja zugleich den Krieg hinaus. Und wo es überhaupt keine Unterscheidungen in der Position gibt zwischen Trump und Biden, ist ja die Perspektive auf China. Und du sagst natürlich zu Recht, dass es ein demografisches Problem gibt. Und wir werden nachher mal so eine Zahl hören. Also die Chinesen rechnen, dass sie, um Taiwan besetzen zu können, also nicht mal da so gerade rein, sondern wirklich besetzen zu können, damit dass sie 500.000 Soldaten brauchen. Für einen doch recht kleinen Fleck. Und jetzt kann man natürlich denken, also wie viel ist dann da überhaupt möglich? Allerdings kann man auch wieder sagen, Länder mit sehr viel Budget und so könnten natürlich viel stärker umstellen auf Söldner. Putin, der nicht so ein großes Budget hat, wie jetzt westliche Staaten, hat ja auch mit der Gruppe Wagner doch ein ganz, ganz großes Söldner-Heer sich schon geschaffen. Ich denke auch, dass die Kriege andere werden. Nur ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass wir hier nur so einer Hysterie anheimfallen, die dann in zwei Jahren wieder verpufft, sondern was hier jetzt so manifestiert wird, da sind ja auch Investitionen, die gemacht werden. Also da werden ja Zusagen bereits gemacht, Rheinmetall und Co., dass die überhaupt jetzt gerade auch noch 20 Millionen übrig haben, um den BVB zu sponsern. Das hat man ja bei den Maskenfabriken alles nie gemacht. Das waren ja immer so Lippenbekenntnisse, ja, man müsste, man sollte. Und hat aber dann doch gesagt, na ja, ach so, die Chinesen liefern das und daher kommen die Handschuhe, dann brauchen wir die auch nicht selbst machen. Das läuft ja hier anders. Und wenn man sich das ansieht, wie wir jetzt Koalitionsbildung vielleicht dann mit der Europawahl haben werden, dann gibt es da so eine Eintracht wirklich von Grüne, SPD, CDU und die europäische Rechte. Ich klammer hier bewusst die AfD aus, weil das ein anderer Fall ist. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist das jetzt ein großes Konzept, dass hier das BIP nach oben treiben kann, das auch vor allem etwas ermöglicht. Und das ist mir sehr aufgefallen in den Kommentaren, so Tagesschau, Instagram-Kanal und so was. Wenn da irgend so eine Kachel kommt, Pistorius will 80 Milliarden mehr, ja, und zwar jede Woche, dann schreiben die Leute reiweweise in die Kommentare, toller Mann, so muss es sein, wir müssen wieder Stärke zeigen. Und ich glaube, das sind ja nicht alles Leute, die reich sind, die da schreiben, sondern ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die soziale Situation für viele als so naturalisiert wahrgenommen werden, dass sie sagen, ich werde ökonomisch nicht stärker, aber, und das ist jetzt pure Ideologie, ich fühle mich stärker, wenn mein Land aufgerüstet ist.
Also ich will noch mal dafür werben, einfach nehmen wir uns ein bisschen aus diesem Alltag, wie wir ihn jetzt gerade vor allem fühlen, raus. Wir können uns noch dran erinnern, also wir können uns eigentlich nur noch rational dran erinnern, aber es nicht mehr wirklich nachfühlen, wie es war, als wirklich alle sagten, nee, also da sollte die Polizei raus und jedem die Spritze in den Arm. Maskenpflicht, überall, auch draußen und so weiter. Also es gab ja wirklich staatliche Befehle, heute sieht man dann noch auf YouTube diese lustigen Clips, wie irgendwie auf eine Skipiste jemand fährt, einsam den Hang runter oder wird er angehalten, 70 Euro, sie haben keine Maske auf gehabt. Also wirklich der totale Wahnsinn. Polizeiautos, die auf eine Wiese in einem Park Jugendlichen hinterherfahren, weil die irgendwie und so weiter. Jetzt hören wir mal den ehemaligen Bundeswehrbeauftragten aus dem Bundestag, der sich zum Thema diese neue Wehrpflicht äußert und versuchen mal, abseits dessen, was wir gerade irgendwie so vor uns hinfühlen, was uns auch als Gefühle so vom Fernsehen, wenn Agnes Strack Zimmermann da irgendwie und so, mit ihrem gewissen Wehem mensa. Wir hören uns das mal an und ich denke das dann mal sachlich.
Der ehemalige Wehrbeauftragte des Bundestages, Hans-Peter Bartels, SPD, jetzt Präsident der Gesellschaft für Sicherheitspolitik, denkt in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Mir steht vor, dass wir die Wehrpflicht, die alte Wehrpflicht, nicht in der alten Form wiederbeleben, sondern als Auswahl-Wehrpflicht. Und dann dazu kommen, dass statt 20.000 Soldaten, neue Soldaten, Rekruten im Jahr auf dem freiwilligen Arbeitsmarkt, auf dem Arbeitsmarkt freiwillig zu gewinnen, wäre dann vielleicht 40.000 im Jahr Gewinn über diese Auswahl-Wehrpflicht. Also einfach die Zahl des Nachwuchses verdoppeln, das würde der Bundeswehr jetzt schon sehr helfen.
Jetzt überlegen wir uns mal. Angenommen, dieser Krieg geht jetzt noch ein Jahr. Selbst wenn er dann noch läuft, auch in dieser Härte, auch in diesem jeden Tag 300 Tote, 3.000 Mordversuche, die auf diesem Kriegsgebiet stattfinden, es wird eine Ermüdung geben. Und die Leute werden irgendwann wirklich fragen, das ist irgendwie sinnlos. Ich sehe da etwas, ich verstehe es nicht. So, jetzt mein Szenario noch ein bisschen extremer. Trump gewinnt, macht mit Putin so einen Hauruck, die ganze Welt muss und wenn Europa will, ja können sie halt. Aber wenn man in Amerika anruft, geht niemand mehr ins Telefon. Schaffen das die Europäer? So, und dann, und ich würde mal sagen, so lange dauert es, wenn jetzt der CDU-Parteitag hat jetzt auf Ansinnen der jungen Leute so diese Auswahlwerbpflicht angeregt, die steht jetzt da irgendwie so in diesen Beschlüssen drin. Dann regiert die CDU ab wann, mal gucken, vielleicht dauert es auch noch wirklich anderthalb Jahre, dann kommt das irgendwann. Dann haben wir so ein Szenario 2027. So, dieser Pflegestress wird auch zunehmen, Rentendiskussionen werden zunehmen. Wir werden nicht mehr diese krasse Inflation haben, aber alle Schocks wirken ja weiterhin nach. Es wird ja nicht zurück abgewickelt. So, und dann bekommen Familien Briefe, wo es heißt, sehr gut, dass ihr euer Einzelkind gut durchs Abi gebracht habt, toll, dass ihr nicht den Staat angefragt habt nach den 7500 Euro für die Nachhilfe, die das gekostet hat und so weiter. Den wollen wir jetzt haben. So, wenn ich mir überlege, wie in Deutschland das, mein Kind soll auf diese Schule gehen und nicht auf die, das ist so unfair. Ich mache einen Aufstand, ich gründe eine Bürgerinitiative, ich rufe den Bürgermeister an, ich mache alles, alles auf dieser Welt, damit mein Kind nicht auf diese Schule geht, sondern ich möchte, dass es auf diese Schule geht. So, und dann glaubt der Staat, er könnte manchen Brief schreiben und anderen nicht. Und wir bekommen dann keine Diskussion zum Thema, das ist aber unfair, wir haben es hier mit Korruption zu tun, da wurden Leute bestochen, damit manche diesen Brief nicht bekommen und so weiter und so fort. Das ist Teufels Küche in dieser demografischen Lage, in der wir sind. Und das haben wir bei ganz vielen dieser Themen. Also wir denken jetzt immer gerade, ja, ja, diese mega Aufrüstung und irgendwann wird die ganze Bundesliga von Rheinmetall bezahlt und so weiter. Aber man kann diese Hysterie nicht allzu lange. Wir müssen mit dem Virus Putin leben lernen. Naja, da können nicht zero Putin jetzt noch und dann sagen, ja, in wer pflegt und hier die Panzer und da und noch mal 100 Milliarden oder 300 Milliarden und so. Diese Hysterie wird ihr Ende finden. Einfach ein natürliches Ende. Auf welchem Wege? Sehen wir dann. Aber das wird so keinen großen Bestand haben. Und es ist auch jetzt schon lächerlich, finde ich. Man muss sie sich wirklich mal anschauen und sagen, Leute, ihr könnt hier nicht, also ich habe hier Clips, die sind so haarstrugend.
Nur haben wir eine große, wenn wir jetzt, also für Deutschland stimme ich dir da absolut zu und das ist die Gewalt des Faktischen und die können wir nicht aufheben. Aber auf der europäischen Ebene können wir ja schon sehen, dass Jugendarbeitslosigkeit ein großes Problem ist. Und wenn man da beispielsweise sagt, warum denn nicht zum Militär und das ist ja im Prinzip schon ein bisschen das, was man jetzt auch tut, dass man Anreize schaffen will, warum man zur Bundeswehr geht. Nun Anreize gibt es auch bei anderen Arbeitgebern, aber dass man jetzt sagt, kostenloser Führerschein, dass man, wie Pistorius das vorgeschlagen hat, dann auch noch sagt, einen besseren Zugang zu Fächern, die man studieren will, wo ein NC drauf ist. Also lauter solche Dinge. Da kann man natürlich auch noch mal überlegen, wer wird eigentlich angesprochen. Also den Krieg kämpfen müssen ja sowieso nicht die oberen 20 Prozent, sondern die anderen kämpfen den ja. Also nicht die Söhne von Journalisten kämpfen den Krieg, sondern höchstens die, die sich die Bildzeitung kaufen.
Aber ich will nur erinnern, wir hatten Eva Högl, die in der Bundespressekonferenz sitzt und hat davon erzählt, die Eltern sehen die Stuben ihrer Söhne und Töchter und sagen, das geht so nicht. Und klar, auf freiwilliger Basis Anwerbetechniken und die armen Leute da anwerben, das versucht die Bundeswehr seit zehn Jahren. Wir sehen diese YouTube-Kampagnen, wir sehen den ganzen Kram. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Warum? Es sind wirklich zu wenige da.
Ja, und ich denke auch, dass sich oder ich hoffe, dass sich zivilisatorisch etwas gewandelt hat, dass man einfach das nicht mehr als eine Perspektive für sich sehen will, wie man zum Beispiel auch nicht mehr als junger Mann, das war nämlich übrigens die Alternative, wenn man nicht die Kinder in den Krieg schicken könnte, Priesterseminar. Und da wird also nichts gegen Leute, die sich dafür entscheiden. Aber ich sage mal so, das ist jetzt auch für viele nicht mehr so naheliegend, zu sagen nur, dann lebe ich halt zölibatär, ich werde katholischer Priester.
Na gut, man hat ja den Freiwilligen Sozialen Dienst oder so, dann mal alternativ für die Werftätigkeiten.
Nein, ich meine nur, wenn es ja darum geht, also es geht ja nicht nur um die Leute einen Zaun zu halten, sondern es ging ja wirklich auch darum, was macht man mit denen beruflich? Und dann sagt man, ja geh doch zum Militär, da kannst du Karriere machen. Oder geh in die Kirche, dann bist du für immer versorgt, denn zu Hause haben wir nicht so viel. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr eine Alternative des Männern, sagen, na ja, ich lebe halt zölibatär, aber dafür bin ich gut versorgt in der Kirche. Also da können wir vielleicht hoffen, dass sich das nicht mehr einsetzt. Und deswegen würde ich ja auch sagen, ist das eigentlich so verrückt, dass das nicht vielmehr als Stimmung auch offen vorgetragen wird. Also ich meine, die ganzen Influencer, die Risos und so, die äußern sich ja gar nicht zu diesem Thema. Die könnten ja richtig schön mal ihren jungen Leuten sagen, wir spielen hier Counter-Strike und so, aber wir gehen nicht aufs Schlachtfeld. Also da könnte man ja eine große pazifistische Bewegung los treten. Und die eine oder andere Partei könnte es, wenn sie denn Interesse daran hätte, auch in ganz anderer Weise adressieren.
Also in diesem Fall, glaube ich, wird sich vieles von selbst regeln, weil sich vieles von selbst versteht.
Ja, aber die Aufrüstung kann es ja trotzdem geben. Also die Aufrüstung, ja, die muss schon bedient werden, das Gerät. Aber es ist ja auch Viehgerät, was nicht mehr vielleicht so mannstark ist, beziehungsweise vielleicht wird man noch mit Söldner-Konzepten arbeiten. Und da denke ich, wird es schon so sein, dass man also jetzt gerade das als Möglichkeit nimmt, um die Schuldenbremse abzuschaffen. Aber das führt aufgrund der politischen Mehrheiten, wie sie nun einmal sind, nicht zu einer in irgendeiner Weise besseren Politik.
Also Kuppersbursch hat letztens im Aufwarn-Podcast ganz pointiert darauf hingewiesen, die deutsche Erfahrung der Nachkriegszeit ist, solange die Bundeswehr mit Krieg nichts zu tun hat, nimmt man den Führerschein, den man da kostenlos bekommt, gerne mit. Ja. Aber als es dann anfing, auch zu heißen, ne, also wenn du in die Bundeswehr gehst und eine Familie gründen willst, also du hast jetzt die Pastorenfamilie eingebracht, das ist ja interessant eigentlich, dass man sich halt entscheiden soll dazwischen Liebe zum Vaterland oder Liebe zu Gott. Dann kam irgendwann die Liebe zur Frau dazwischen und die Liebe zur Frau überwiegt immer auch die Liebe zum Vaterland, weil wenn es wirklich heißt, du kannst das Familie gründen, weil endlich ökonomische Sicherheit, weil Arbeitgeber starten, ist aber die Bundeswehr und es droht wirklich, dass du dann entsandt wirst. Dann entscheiden sich sehr viele Menschen, die vorher anders entschieden hätten, wirklich dagegen. Und ich glaube, die allergrößte Gefahr hier ist auch die Automatisierung. Also wenn wir Angst vor militärischen Auseinandersetzungen haben, dann vor diesen Automatisierten, die demnächst kommen. Larry Fink, also der BlackRock-Chef, saß letztens auf der Bühne und es war wahnsinnig interessant, weil er meinte, und er hat so quasi diesen Hype, diesen KI-Hype aufgegriffen. Und er meinte, ja, man kann sich schon lustig machen über diesen KI-Hype. Und klar, das sind bislang nur Chatbots. Und vielleicht auch mehr so in dieser kreativen Ecke. Die können halt tolle Bilder und mittlerweile auch Musik. Was brauchen wir das in der Wirtschaft? Aber er meinte, der Handlungsdruck durch die demografische Wende ist so groß, also einfach zu automatisieren, dass man aus dem letzten Unsinn noch irgendwas gestaltet. Die Hauptsache, man ist nicht auf Recruitingstour und sucht irgendwelche Leute. Und das ist natürlich im Militär eine der größten Gefahren überhaupt, dass wir demnächst, und Harari hab ich jetzt auch in so einem Interview gesehen, wo er so meinte, naja, bislang haben wir Technik entwickelt und haben eine Entscheidung darüber getroffen, wie wir sie einsetzen. Nur jetzt haben wir Atombomben, die selber nachdenken. Die einfach selber entscheiden, wann sie losfliegen und so. Und in die Richtung, würde ich sagen, muss man es dramatisieren. Was die Kriege mit menschlicher Beteiligung angeht, würde ich sagen, die Kosten sind so hoch, es wird diese großen Auseinandersetzungen nicht geben. In China muss ich mit sich selbst befassen. Wenn haben wir ein größeres Problem mit Terrorismus? Also dass Putin die Ukraine überfällt, wieder aller ökonomischen Logik, ist für mich ein terroristischer Akt, ein ideologisch getriebener Akt.
Wir kommen ja zu dieser Thematik heute noch, weil wir uns mit den strukturellen Realisten beschäftigen wollen, die sagen, Putin hat rational gehandelt.
Xi und seine Regierung ist ganz weit von so einer Art irrationalem Handeln entfernt. Also die kalkulieren wirklich alles auf dem Schachfeld durch.
Wir werden gleich mal diskutieren, ob das vielleicht doch rational war. Aber lass uns noch kurz über die AfD sprechen. Krah hat sich wieder was geleistet. Nämlich hat er ja gesagt, naja, die Leute da in der SS, die waren ja jetzt auch nicht alle Täter. Kannst du das erklären? Warum er das tut.
Warum er das in der internationalen Presse sagt. Nochmal so eine Verherrlichung des alten Nazidenkens. Dass er auf Anschlusssuche ist, die große neue Rechte internationale. Okay, aber mit so einem Blick zurück.
Ja, das war einfach sehr dumm. Ich glaube, dass er darüber nicht nachgedacht hat und nicht darüber nachgedacht hat, dass er jetzt gerade auf der europäischen Ebene spricht. Denn natürlich hat die neue Rechte sowohl in Frankreich wie auch in Italien jetzt nicht den deutschen Faschismus aufgearbeitet, aber sie hat doch versucht, eine Distanz zu ihm einzunehmen und auch die deutschen Neurechten importieren ja eigentlich dann französische und italienische Faschismen, faschistische Theorien, um auch selbst jetzt nicht zum Beispiel zu nah an die Nazis assoziiert zu werden, weil sie sich dann ja solchen Sachen wie dem Holocaust stellen müssen. Der Verstörung Paris. Genau, diese Sachen. Also das ist nicht etwas, was so gut gesehen ist. Ich glaube, dass man auf der europäischen Ebene zumindest so im Hinterzimmer hat. Marine Le Pen vielleicht gar nicht das größte Problem damit, wenn da irgendwas mit SS oder so kommt. Aber es gibt einen anderen Zusammenhang, glaube ich. Und das ist interessant. Ich hatte den Sebastian Friedrich, den ich für den profundesten Kenner der AfD halte, der hatte im Freitag, wir sind befreundet, um das nur an dieser Stelle zu sagen, also Compliance, der hatte einen Text geschrieben über diese neue Sache von Kra. Und er sagt, na ja, also, Rassemblement National, also die Partei von Meloni, die hatte schon früher Probleme mit Kra. Kra ist da hemmserblich unterwegs. Und zwar hat er Guillaume Pradoura aufgenommen bei sich als Mitarbeiter. Der ist von den Identitären. Und der wurde aber vom RN rausgeworfen wegen Antisemitismus. Und wir wissen ja, Le Pen ist eine Person, die bereit ist, für die politische Macht mit Leuten zu sprechen, die ihr eigentlich nahestehen. Und zwar mit dem eigenen Vater. Sie sagt zu dem eigenen Vater, das geht gar nicht, du bist Antisemit und so, das wollen wir hier nicht. Sebastian Friedrich schreibt jetzt im Freitag, Kra's identitäre Fraktionsmitglied schafft, wurde zeitweise sogar suspendiert. Weil er den rechts von Le Pen stehenden Eric Simour bei den französischen Präsidentschaftswahlen unterstützte. Also Kra hat auch den schon unterstützt. Beschädigt war das Verhältnis zwischen der AfD und den Krampen der europäischen Rechten schon länger. Und jetzt geht es auf eine Ebene nochmal über Kra hinaus. Der Europaparteitag im vergangenen Sommer musste mit Grußworten aus Frankreich und Italien auskommen. Zu größeren europäischen Treffen der Rechten wurde die AfD in der letzten Zeit nicht eingeladen. Und von den relevanten Rechtenkräften hielt zuletzt nur noch die österreichische FPÖ zu. Dann heißt hier Georgia Melonis Partei Fratelli d'Italia, gehört im Europaparlament derweil der anderen Rechtenfraktion an den europäischen Konservativen und Reformmann EKR. Ebenso wie Abgeordnete von PiS, Spanischer Vox, die Finnen und Schwedendemokraten. Und nun stellt sich also hier die Frage, sagt er, wird also Melonis Weg einer sein, dem Le Pen Volk? Und was bedeutet das dann auf europäischer Ebene? Wir haben alle schon die herzigen Bilder gesehen, Meloni und Biden, Meloni und von der Leyen. Es ist vollkommen klar, dass die deutschen Konservativen nichts mit der AfD auf europäischer Ebene machen können. Man kann nicht zum einen mit Margot Friedländer auftreten und zum anderen mit jemandem koalieren, der sagt, die SS war ja gar nicht so wild.
Machen sie auch nicht.
Ist unmöglich. Aber mit Meloni ist das eine andere Geschichte. Und Le Pen scheint ja, in Anführungszeichen, in die Mitte sich zu bewegen, also in die Mitte dieser Leute, wo man sagt, Antisemitismus nicht, bitte keine SS und so weiter. Aber sonst natürlich hat man sich nicht gemäßigt, sondern man ist natürlich extrem gegen Migration, gegen all das. Also hier sagt Sebastian Friedrich, innerhalb der AfD würde man schon, also bei diesem Umfeld, Höcke, Gra, schon von einer Melonisierung sprechen. Der AfD, nämlich Weidel, scheint durchaus daran interessiert zu sein. Und was ist nämlich jetzt interessant, dass man sich ganz anders verhalten hat. Nämlich, diese neuen europäischen Rechten jetzt sind nicht mehr die, die fundamental die Europäische Union ablehnen. Höcke tut das, deswegen kann er da nicht mitspielen. Und jetzt die geopolitische Ebene finde ich hochinteressant, sagt Friedrich. Auch bei den meisten großen Rechtsparteien in Europa orientiert man sich gerade seit dem Ukraine-Krieg stärker in Richtung der NATO. Selbst beim französischen RN hält man sich mit allzu großen Advancen in Richtung Moskau inzwischen zurück. Das heißt, hier, weil wir jetzt eben über die Aufrüstung sprachen und Möglichkeiten, wie das dann ginge, glaube ich, sehen wir eine ganz große, neue, bürgerlich CDU bis eben dann rechts postfaschistische Koalition drohen und wenn wir Jens Spahn hören, der hat eure aktiven Interview gegeben, da sagte er, die Brandmauer, das potenzielle Partner der EVP pro europäisch, pro NATO, pro Rechtsstaat und pro Ukraine sein müssen, verläuft im Europaparlament rechts von Melonis Partei.
Also, dass es sehr erfolgsträchtig ist, außenpolitisch keine großen Aufhebens zu machen und dass die EU nur als Geldlieferant gesehen wird. Das hat man ja jetzt, also wir nicht, aber diejenigen, die das organisieren müssen, die haben das ja gelernt am Fall Ungarn. So, wenn du zu sehr über die Stränge schlägst, kriegst du einfach von der EU kein Geld. Was die EU sonst macht, kann egal sein. Also es geht wirklich nur um diesen Geldströme. So, die Geldströme nicht abreißen zu lassen, das ist natürlich auf zwei Ebenen. Zum einen die Rechtsstaatlichkeit, die jetzt ein bisschen fester ins rule-based-Politikgeschehen eingraviert wurde durch die Erfahrung mit der PiS. Nee, nicht der PiS, sondern der, wie heißt er? Na ja, also Orban-Partei. Und dann auf der anderen Ebene... Fidesz, genau. Gibt es aber diese persönliche Ebene. Wenn sich Meloni mit von der Leyen gut versteht und von der Leyen eine zweite Amtszeit bekommt, dann droht Italien einfach weniger. So, auf der Ebene irgendwie. Wenn die am Tisch alle gute Stimmung haben und niemand groß auffällt und nervt, passt das. Deswegen wird dieses innenpolitische Programm von Meloni ja vorsichtig und langsam, aber rigoros durchgezogen. Also Angriffe auf die Juristerei, auf die Medien und so weiter. Das findet da alles statt. Aber ohne Aufhebens in Europa. Und wenn du jetzt Alice Weidel da, sehr interessant. Also wenn man die Liste der AfD-Chefs noch mal durchgeht, Bernd Lucke, Frauke Petry, Jörg Meuthen, jetzt Alice Weidel, die versuchen alle das. Nur, den wird eben von ihrem gährigen Haufen das immer wieder zerschossen. Inklusive, dass der Erste auf der Liste für die Europawahl Krah seinen Blödsinn macht die ganze Zeit, Nummer Zwei hat dann plötzlich gar keine meldefähige Adresse, also kann gar nicht vorgeladen werden, stellt sich raus, da lebt irgendein Asylbewerber in so einer viel zu kleinen Wohnung, die kann gar nicht ihm gehören und laute solche Sachen. Und diese Unprofessionalität ist natürlich ein echter Stolperstein.
Ja, ja, nur man muss jetzt sehr aufpassen, was jetzt gerade so in den deutschen Medien und in der Rezeption dieser Krah-Affären stattfindet, ist, dass man sagt, ha ha, jetzt besiegen wir die AfD. Ich glaube, dass das bei den Wählern nicht allzu viel Unruhe verursacht, und das sieht man ja auch an den Umfragen. Mag sein, dass die jetzt zwei Prozent verlieren.
Werden aber in der Thüringkommunal-Bei, die es noch ein bisschen anders zeigen, ne?
Der Rechtsruck kann auch ohne die AfD vollzogen werden. Also ich habe jetzt einige Podcasts gehört, die dann mit sehr viel Empfase aufrufen, dies ist die historische Wahl, bitte geht alle wählen. Das machen wir hier nicht in dieser Weise mit so schrillen Tönen. Und dann war immer direkt gleich daran angeknüpft, wir müssen endlich eine andere Flüchtlingspolitik bekommen, das Asylrecht muss Humana werden, wir müssen das stoppen und so weiter. Die Sache ist nur, diese Podcasts, wo ich das gehört habe, geben keinerlei Wahlempfehlung, weil da müsste man in die Programme gucken, wo steht das so? Und da würde ich sagen, da wird man nur bei ganz wenigen überhaupt fündig. Und dann sprechen sie auch nicht an, was eigentlich droht. Also eigentlich müssten sie sagen, ja, also wählt bitte nicht die AfD. Aber seid euch auch sicher, dass Meloni und Ursula von der Leyen sich gut verstehen. Also ist es sehr gut möglich, dass man eine neue Koalitionsbildung hat, die so aussieht, dass mit deiner Stimme für CDU-CSU, du gleichzeitig die Postfaschistin Meloni unterstützt. Das wäre eigentlich die ehrliche Kommunikation. Und die kann man ja jetzt auch ableiten, ohne ganz tief in der Materie zu sein. Wir können ja mal diesen einen Clip, vielleicht kannst du den mal anklicken, von Harte aber fair, da ist Julia Klöckner zu Gast und wird da auch befragt nach Brandmauer.
Wir werden jetzt, Frau Klöckner, ich kann dir gleich mal etwas sagen auch zu ihren Leuten, mit ihren Linkspopulisten, mit denen sie zusammenarbeiten. Wir können auch noch mal Sanchez anschauen. Ich will aber auch die Frage, aber auch die Frage würde ich gerne antworten. Eines ist sehr klar, es wird überhaupt keine Zusammenarbeit geben mit der ID, also mit den Identitären, den Rechtsextremen. Es wird auch nicht mit der Linken bei der Rechten eine Zusammenarbeit geben. Es wird mit Einzelnen, und das muss man raussuchen, und da wird es konkret die Brandmauer. Brandmauer schwebt hier oben. Wer ist pro-europäisch, wer nicht pro-europäisch ist, mit dem kann man überhaupt zusammenarbeiten. Frau Meloni pro-europäisch? Zweitens, wer ist pro-rechtsstaat? Und drittens, wer ist für die Reine?
Aber das ist doch aufschlussreich.
Es reicht, gegen Putin zu sein, und dann darf man wie Frau Meloni aus einer verschisslichen Welt kommen.
Die Kriterien würde ich lieber nicht ansetzen an ihrer Stelle, weil dann bekommen sie keine Mehrheit für Frau von der Leyen.
Doch, das könnte man schon kriegen. Wir häcken die mit Problemen gar nicht, wenn nicht z.B. die Liberalen, die Grünen und auch die Sozialdemokraten genau das aufgekündigt hätten, was wir in der Mitte hatten. Und wenn die beiden jetzt gleich sagen, oder alle drei sagen... Alle drei sagen, sie unterstützen Frau von der Leyen. Sie können das jetzt wegschieben.
Ja, die Brandmauer ist schwebend. Die schwebt nämlich da oben. Und die setzen wir dann dahin, wo wir sie brauchen. Und was hier auch noch mal von ihr gesagt wird, also pro-europäisch, und das meint natürlich gleichzeitig pro-NATO, die entsprechende Haltung zum Ukraine-Krieg und auch dann mögliche Zölle gegen China und sowas, muss natürlich gewährleistet sein. Aber sonst ist da viel möglich. Und das ist tatsächlich beängstigend, dass wir jetzt so einen Rechtsruck erleben, dass wir eine inhumanere Flüchtlingspolitik bekommen werden. Aber nicht durch die AfD. Die AfD spielt in dem Sinne da keine Rolle. Der Krah kann sehen, ob er da noch lange es aushält in dieser Partei, oder ob sie ihn dann irgendwann rauskicken, ob irgendwann Alice Weidel sagt, na, das ist eigentlich doch ganz begehhrlich, ganz schön, so wie Meloni und Le Pen dann irgendwann Hof 4 zu werden. Das wird sich zeigen. Aber man kann ja, wenn man über die Europawahl nachdenkt, nicht nur über die AfD nachdenken, sondern ich glaube, diese neuen Koalitionsbildungen, die da entstehen könnten, sind so gefährlich deshalb, weil man nicht mehr genau dieses hat, ach ja, das sind jetzt irgendwie die Nachkommen der Nazis, die jetzt da noch mal in die Politik gehen oder was, sondern man denkt, na, die sind doch bürgerlich. Das betont ja auch dann eine Julia Klöckner laufend.
Ja, da würde ich auch sagen, die Gefahr droht von der CDU. Man hat jetzt gesehen, ich habe immer noch Florian Schröder im Ohr, wie er sagt, warum würde die AfD keinen Erfolg haben? Sie ist zu doof und ehrlichweise, sie ist zu doof. Sie hat jetzt in Thüringen eigentlich so ein 32, 33, 34% Umfrageergebnis gehabt. Dann sind diese Kommunalwahlen, wo es wirklich jetzt darum ging, niemand kennt hier irgendeine Person, wer AfD wählen darf, will, macht es jetzt einfach. Er hat jetzt die Möglichkeit und dann kamen sie aber nur so auf 25%. Und bei 25% kann man sagen, okay, das ist ganz schön viel. Aber nach eigener Anschauung sage ich als Geburts-Thüringer, es haben offenbar noch nicht alle überzeugten Neonazis in Thüringen jetzt AfD gewählt. Also sie schafft nicht mal, ihr Klientel quasi auszubeuten, weil sie einfach zu doof ist.
Okay, du würdest sagen also das Potenzial ist eigentlich höher?
Ja, das liegt locker bei 30%. Und nicht bei 0,2%.
Das ist ja erschreckend.
Aber das ist ja immer so eine Sache. Wir sehen europäische Zusammenarbeit. Und ehrlicherweise ist es so, wenn die Geldströme durch Europa, Meloni, so disziplinieren, dass sie im Europäischen Parlament ihre eigenen Fraktionen dann, also ihre eigenen Leute nicht, aufwiegeln da irgendwie so ein Trerat, macht man hier nur YouTube-Videos und so, wie die AfD im Bundestag, und auch in den Ministerräten Entscheidungen abfallen, bei denen man irgendwie so ein Rational rausrechnen kann. Dann bleibt es bei den faschistischen, neonazistischen, ausländerfeindlichen Sachen regional begrenzt, nämlich auf ihr Land. Und dann müssen die Italiener das einfach selber entscheiden. Also da, klar, man ist irgendwie immer angeleitet, da irgendwie irgendwo noch so Kontrapunkte zu setzen und dann macht man eine Aktion auf der Straße hier und eine Veranstaltung da und versucht, irgendwelche Aufklärungssachen, aber der Lauf der Dinge ist dann einfach, die Italiener müssen es entscheiden, so wie wir das in Deutschland eben auch selbst entscheiden müssen. Wie viel Raumgewinne geben wir jetzt der CDU? Welche Fernsehdiskussionen ermöglichen wir denn? Und nehmen sie auch einfach so hinten als Publikum? Du hast ja zuletzt, wie im Fernsehen diskutiert wird, wir haben selten so viele Zuschriften bekommen, auch aus den Reihen derjenigen, die sie verantworten, dieser Sendung. Und das ist ja ein haarsträubender Arbeitsbedarf, der da vorliegt.
Wir werden genau das nochmal ansprechen, inwieweit man dann sagen kann, das sollen die Italiener entscheiden. Und dann ist das demokratisch. Wie ist das zu akzeptieren? Ich verspreche da ein Buch, das sich gewaschen hat, das ich in den Salon mitbringe. Lass uns noch einen Clip hören, und zwar den darüber von Christoph Möllers. Er war vor einigen Monaten bei Caroline Imke im Süddeutsche Zeitung Podcast zu Gast. Und er ist derjenige, der beraten hat bei der Frage, kann man die NPD verbieten? Und er sagt jetzt als Rechtsphilosoph, Staatsphilosoph etwas sehr Interessantes zur AfD.
Eine wirklich attraktive Sache an der AfD, das kann ich wirklich so sagen, ist, dass sie ja tatsächlich an Politik glaubt. Dass die AfD-Politiker glauben, sie könnten das Land verändern mit politischen Mitteln. Vielleicht nicht so, wie ich mir das vorstelle, aber sie haben schon diesen Gestaltungsoptimismus in gewisser Weise. Das mag man jetzt zu sagen. Im Inhalt kann man daran zweifeln. Aber diesen Gestaltungsoptimismus sieht man ja bei der Politik, der repräsentativen demokratischen Politik auf der anderen Seite eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig. Der ist ja sehr oft sehr defensiv. Und das scheint mir zusammen zu hängen.
Ja, und das würde ich total bestätigen. Ich habe die Wahlprogramme ja alle gelesen jetzt für die Europawahl. Und es ist fast nur defensive. Ich würde schon sagen, bei Linke und BSW ist ein bisschen mehr. Das könnte man verändern, aber da geht es dann wieder um Mehrheiten. Aber eigentlich ist auch da, es ist sehr viel schwächer formuliert, weil man schon so weiß an die Gebundenheiten, an die Sachzwänge, während die AfD einfach mal drauf losschießt und sagt, dann binden wir das mal wieder ans Gold, unsere Währung. Jetzt kann man sagen, das ist ja reiner Irrsinn. Und das ist natürlich auch Irrsinn. Und Möllers lehnt das natürlich genauso ab wie ich. Nur ist es interessant, dass da der Politik das noch zugestanden wird, was die anderen alles nicht machen. Und wenn ich mir anhöre, jetzt diese ganzen Aufrufe geht zur Wahl, dann ist es ja meistens nur aus der Defensive. Also es heißt eigentlich nur, bitte verhindert die AfD. Aber sonst gibt es keinerlei irgendwie geartete positive Visionen, die mit dieser Europawahl verbunden ist.
Das wird uns auf die Füße fallen. Allen voran mit der Abwahl Joe Bidens, weil das wird einfach eine Abwahl sein. Und mit ihm könnte man Trump verhindern, also das wird nicht ziehen. Aladdin El-Mafalani war bei so einer Veranstaltung, da gibt es ein Video, das er bei Twitter selbst geteilt hat, wie er zehn Minuten lang einfach mal zahlenmäßig durchgeht, was bedeutet es, dieses Remigrations-Ding durchzuziehen. Also wenn man das Programm der AfD nimmt und einfach mal ernsthaft kurz durchkalkuliert. Und er kommt dann mit allen möglichen Zahlen, die die AfD ja sonst immer benutzt, um Stress zu machen, wie zum Beispiel 40% der heute geborenen Kinder in Deutschland haben Migrationshintergrund, ein Teil der Eltern hatte gar keinen deutschen Pass oder so. Oder man hat einen deutschen Pass, aber der kam erst so im Laufe des Lebens dazu, dann zählt man ja auch schon nicht dazu. Und er geht das dann so durch und sagt, okay, 24 Millionen Leute, wer ist das eigentlich? Und er sagt dann, die Rentner sind es nicht. Also da ist der Auslandanteil einfach nicht nennenswert. Bei den Kindern alle raus. Ärzte, 60% der Hausärzte auf dem Land, raus. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Die Pointen liegen da auf dem Tisch, also man muss sie nicht aussprechen. Das ist einfach völlig selbstverständlich, dass diese Programmatik einfach nicht funktioniert. Und es ist erstaunlich, mit welcher Vehemenz das aber als ernsthaftes politisches Angebot, also Goldpreisbindung wäre dann noch das Mindeste, die das einfach durchpauken. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, das dann mal zu hören.
Wir nutzen jetzt die Gelegenheit, um auf den Salon hinzuweisen. Wie schon angekündigt will ich da ein Buch vorstellen, das mich wahnsinnig begeistert hat, und zwar von Philipp Manow. Der beschäftigt sich damit, inwieweit die liberale Demokratie in die Krise geraten ist und fragt sich, ob das überhaupt eine Krise der Demokratie ist. Denn dieses Gerede von der liberalen Demokratie ist etwas relativ Neues, und das hängt zusammen mit den Verfassungsgerichten. Und die Aufwertung der Verfassungsgerichte ist ein Phänomen, das wir auch erst in den letzten 30 Jahren so stark erlebt haben. Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn andere und er nimmt die bösen Buben, Erdogan, Orban etc., das Verfassungsgericht beschneiden? Und wir haben ja gerade eben auch was besprochen, was das Verfassungsgericht tangiert. Wir finden das ja eigentlich doof, dass wir so eine Schuldenbremse haben, die uns so bindet, die also nicht den demokratischen Willen befreit, sondern ihn domestiziert. Und er kommt dazu sehr vielen kontraintuitiven Schlüssen. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon, ich muss das unbedingt dann vorstellen. Worüber wir aber in aller Ausführlichkeit gemeinsam sprechen, ist das neue Buch von Richard David Precht. Das heißt, das Jahrhundert der Toleranz, Plädoyer für eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik. Precht legt hier also das vor, was ihn jetzt in den vergangenen Jahren sehr beschäftigt hat, nämlich die Frage, muss man einfach diesen Baerbockweg folgen? Aber irgendwie funktioniert das ja nicht. Muss man sagen, wir gehen ganz weg von irgendwelchen Werten? Nein, er nennt es ja wertegeleitete Außenpolitik. Und er versucht uns jetzt aufzuzeigen, was dann diese Toleranz meint. Also ist das eine Toleranz im Sinne von, ist uns egal, was die anderen machen? Oder ist da auch irgendetwas dabei, was vielleicht sogar missionierend ist? Ich hab's noch nicht gelesen, bin aber sehr gespannt darauf. Und versuche auch heute hier im Podcast eine Grundlage dafür zu legen, da ich diese andere Schule vorstellen will mit den strukturellen Realisten.
Ich habe geschaut, es gibt ein Buch, Die Sprache des Kapitalismus. Ich hab schon mal reingelesen. Ich finde, wir sollten es mal heuristisch durchgehen, auch wenn ich nicht ganz so überzeugt bin, dass es eins zu eins jetzt als Lobgesang zu lesen ist. Aber die Themensetzung ist natürlich sehr gut. Außerdem bei Gilda Sahibi bei Lanz und hat dort dem CSU-Typen, der neben ihr saß, einfach gesagt, ob die jetzt in Sylt, Ausländer aus Deutschland, den Deutschen singen oder ob ihr sagt, wenn jemand eine doppelte Staatsangehörigkeit hat und die Deutsche kamen dann eben erst nachträglich, während der Biografie schon läuft dazu, dann können wir das einfach, und sei es nur strafrechtlich, du hast irgendwas getan, dann ist die wieder weg. So, und sie sagt, das ist auf Augenhöhe. Und sie sagt das aber ganz nüchtern, ganz ruhig. Und ich fand das so überzeugend, meine Methodik, wie sie das macht, dass ich mir dachte, als ich bin dann so nachgegoogelt, habe ich gesehen, ah ja, wie wir uns Rassismus beibringen. Sie hat also ein Buch gerade so auf dem Markt zum Thema Rassismus. Und üblicherweise, wenn irgendwo ein Aufklärungsbuch über Rassismus, weiß ich schon, 200 Seiten präampel und dann nochmal drei interessante Seiten vielleicht. Ich glaube, diesmal ist anders. Also wir schauen da mal rein. Ansonsten Scott Galloways Buch. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Bücher ich schaffe, weil jetzt auch gerade eine Veranstaltung nächste Woche geplatzt ist, weil ich erfahren habe, dass ich da gar keinen Honorar und nicht mal Reisekosten kriege. Deswegen, ich habe viel Zeit zu lesen. Eintag mehr Zeit zu lesen. Vielleicht dieses Buch von Scott Galloway. Ich habe ihn ja immer mal betont und er hat jetzt...
Aber das ist so ein Investmentbuch.
Ja, es ist so ein Buch über Lebensgestaltung und so weiter. Ich warte ja im Grunde auf seine Ausarbeitung zum Thema die Jungen.
Ich habe da reingelesen, aber es war eher so, dass ich dachte, gut, ist bestimmt interessant, wenn ich mal so 10 Millionen gespart habe, was ich mit meinem Geld mache.
Also es ist ja so, wir haben ja häufiger hier Bücher, bei denen wir es den Autoren anerkennen, aber nicht ganz durchgehen lassen, dass sie auch mal was populärwissenschaftliches schreiben. Einfach nur, um dann mit ihrer Uni-Professur auch mal ein paar Bücher zu verkaufen. Und es nicht nur für die eigentliche Identität zu schreiben. Von daher, Scott Galloway hat gerade einen spektakulären, vielleicht einen, also wirklich der top spektakulärsten Ted Talks gehalten, wo es ja immer so verdampft auf 15 Minuten ist zum Thema Lieben wir eigentlich unsere Kinder? Und wenn ja, warum lassen wir ihn ökonomisch gar keine Luft zum Atmen? Also er ist eine Anklage gegen die eigene Klasse, die wirklich seinesgleichen sucht in dieser Deutlichkeit. Von daher würde ich mich von diesem Buch nochmal überraschen lassen. Vielleicht schaffe ich es jetzt für diesen Salon. Ansonsten liegt das weiterhin noch auf Halde. Allein deswegen, ja, aber an meistens freue ich mich eigentlich auf Precht, weil dieser Titel, also ein ganzes Jahrhundert unterzubringen, mehr als eine Lebenszeit, ist schon mal viel. Toleranz, eigentlich der größte Streitbegriff gerade, der so im Raume steht irgendwie. Alle fühlen sich nur noch getriggert und wollen irgendwie abarbeiten und Werte geleitet. Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass wir uns ja nicht da einreihen, wo die sich die Leute lustig machen, über eine feministische Außenpolitik. Obwohl es so naheliegend ist, sich über diese feministische Außenpolitik nun wirklich lustig zu machen. Aber wir vermuten ja dahinter ist noch irgendwas. Also vermuten wir ja hinter Werte geleitet da.
Auch noch was.
Vermuten wir ja eigentlich was. Also wollen wir mal wohlwollend daran gehen und die Sachen rauskramen, die da drin stehen.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Man kann das dann alles hören. In der nächsten Woche kommt dann der Salon. Aber man kann natürlich jetzt schon ein Abo abschließen. Und zwar empfehlen wir, dies über Steady zu tun. Man geht auf unsere Seite neuzwanziger.de. Ist auch verlinkt. Und dann kommt man dort auf den goldenen Salon-Button und kann sich dann eines der drei Pakete raussuchen. Das ist nur die Frage, inwieweit man den Podcast bereit ist zu unterstützen. Es gibt also nicht mit einer höheren Zahlung mehr Inhalte, sondern das ist alles ganz demokratisch für alle gleich.
Also wenn man die teuerste, die dritte Variante nimmt, kann man auf seine Kosten nochmal drei weitere. Für alle vier wird es dann insgesamt die billigste Option. Also wenn ihr ein Lesefreundeskreis zu viert seid, dann könnt ihr das machen.
Oder man möchte das weiter verschenken.
Niemand kriegt eine Postkarte von dir.
Oder Sponsor. Nein, keine Autogrammkarten von Stefan. Auch von dir schon? Ja, wir empfehlen also den Salon über Steady zu abonnieren. Das kostet 2,50 Euro im Monat dann. Es gibt aber auch noch andere Wege. Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann das darüber dann auch tun. Wer bei Apple ist, kann auch darüber das buchen. Ist aber dann etwas teurer, weil Apple natürlich eine höhere Gebühr verlangt als Steady und Patreon. Aber wem das bequemer ist, der kann das gerne darüber tun. Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen. Und es ist auch eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, weil es jetzt auch für alle, die jetzt neu abschließen, natürlich wahnsinnig viele Salons noch zum Nachhören gibt. Und man kann sich sehr gut, weil immer die Cover wechseln. Stefan macht immer ein neues Cover, daran orientieren, also welche Bücher wurden besprochen. Also zum Beispiel kann man sich jetzt nochmal, bevor wir den neuen Precht besprechen, nochmal die Besprechung anhören von dem Buch, das Precht und Wälzer gemeinsam geschrieben haben.
Das ist immer noch aktuell. Ja, das ist ja das Zauber dieses Gruppes.
Oder nein, es ist eigentlich das traurige Unseres Diskurses, dass es immer noch so aktuell ist. Wir springen jetzt zu einem Thema, das zugleich die Grundlage sein soll für die Precht-Lektüre. Immer wieder wurden wir auch gefragt, wie halten wir das mit diesen Realisten? Du hast wahrscheinlich auch schon im Laufe der Zeit, seit dem Krieg, immer wieder John-Merschheimer-Videos geschickt bekommen. Und nun war es tatsächlich so, dass ich dachte, ja, wir greifen das mal auf. Auch deshalb, weil im Deutschlandfunk darüber gesprochen wurde, also der Deutschlandfunk hat mit John-Merschheimer einem dieser Vertreter ein längeres Interview geführt.
Ja, ich glaube, das muss man noch mal einbetten. Denn es ist der Deutschlandfunk-Politik-Podcast, der ja üblicherweise als Redaktionsgespräch entweder bei einer Veranstaltung, da stehen sie in der Lobby des Bundestags und sagen die ganze Zeit, dass sie jetzt in der Lobby des Bundestags stehen, oder sie treffen sich halt so kurz vor Feierabend, wo aber auch alle so im Stress sind, weil sie jahreschneidern und so. Also es ist immer so eine Hektik. Diesmal ist es so, dass Stefan Dethjen in Amerika war und das Gespräch ja auch einleitet mit so, ja, wir haben ja noch schnell sein Hotelzimmer umgebaut in so eine Sitzecke, dass man da so ein Gespräch führen kann. Also es ist nicht nur inhaltlich, so ein bisschen Outer Space, sondern es ist auch an den Deutschlandfunk herangetragen worden, weil sich Stefan Dethjen dachte, nach, was weiß ich, 300 Folgen oder so, müssen wir vielleicht auch mal ausbrechen aus der einen oder anderen Denkschablone. Ich fahr mal alleine, ich hab mal einen Interviewpartner, ich nehme mal eine Stunde Zeit, ich bin mal nicht in Berlin. Das merkt man dann auch.
Ja, man sollte sich das auch in Gänze vielleicht nochmal anhören. Wir steigen aber jetzt erstmal ganz anders ein. Wir gehen erstmal zu dem Clip zu Precht, nämlich der einen Menschenrechtsexperten zu Gast hatte, Manfred Nowak. Und mit ihm diskutiert er darüber, inwieweit denn das Versprechen, dass die Menschenrechte für alle gelten sollen, eingelöst ist. Was wäre zu tun? Und ist das nicht eigentlich alles eine große Krise? Wir wollen uns erstmal über diese Frage der Werte an das Thema annähern.
Jetzt gibt es aus meiner Sicht, aber Sie werden mir erklären, warum ich da falsch liege, einen Widerspruch zwischen auf der einen Seite gibt es ein Recht der Staaten auf Nichteinmischung. Gerade China sagt das bei jeder Gelegenheit, immer wenn es kritisiert wird. Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn Menschenrechte universell gelten. Und wenn sie von all diesen Ländern auch unterzeichnet worden sind, dann müssen sie ja doch irgendwie auch einforderbar sein. Auch von der internationalen Staatengemeinschaft. Bringen Sie mal ein bisschen Licht in das Dunkel. Also wie verhält sich das Recht auf Nichteinmischung der Staaten zum sozusagen normativen Zwang zur Einmischung der Menschenrechte verletzt werden?
Stimmt, das kennen wir alle. Wenn China sich äußert, dann meistens mit dem Verweis darauf, dass man sich bitte nicht einmischen soll. Jetzt wissen wir, in China geht es den Uiguren nicht gut. Das ist also ein menschenrechtliches Problem. Und da will man sich also doch einmischen. Und China versucht aber dann darauf zu verweisen. China jetzt nur mal herausgegriffen. Andere Länder machen das natürlich auch. Jetzt kommt die Antwort.
Also das Recht auf Nicht-Einmischung ist eines von vielen Prinzipien des Völkerrechts. Man soll sich nicht ohne irgendwelchen Grund in die Angelegenheiten anderer Staaten einmischen. Die Menschenrechte sind eine Ausnahme davon. Das heißt, der Schutz der Menschenrechte bedeutet immer Einmischung in die innerstaatlichen Angelegenheiten.
Das heißt, was jetzt gerade passiert, dass beispielsweise die Hamas-Führer sowie auch Netanyahu vom Internationalen Strafgerichtshof angeklagt sind, ist ja eine Einmischung von außen. Und ist aber auch gerechtfertigt, wenn man also dort dringenden Verdacht hat, dass da irgendetwas falsch läuft.
Oder Gefahr im Vollzug ist.
Wir haben jetzt mal nicht dieses Thema hier aufgegriffen. Ich glaube, du hast da auch keine Clips zu mitgebracht, wie das jetzt zu beurteilen ist, dieser ganze Prozess. Ich glaube aber, dass das, was wir uns jetzt hier anhören, auf jeden Fall vor dem Hintergrund dieser Anklage zu sehen ist. Vor allem, dass Netanyahu angeklagt ist und dass möglicherweise dann in den nächsten Wochen oder Monaten so ein Haftbefehl rauskommt. Und das würde ja auch bedeuten, dass Deutschland, wenn Netanyahu hier zu Besuch ist, ihn verhaften müsste. Weil eigentlich der Internationale Strafgerichtshof wird so hoch anerkannt, das ist Teil der wertgeleiteten Außenpolitik. Zugleich kann man sich natürlich die Frage stellen, würde Deutschland Netanyahu verhaften? Meine Antwort darauf ist natürlich nicht. Damit das nicht geschieht, gibt es also zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder hat man irgendeinen Sonderbeschluss, warum man das nicht macht. Oder man sagt Netanyahu einfach, du kannst nicht hier zu uns kommen auf Staatsbesuch, denn das würde dazu führen, dass wir dich verhaften müssen. Wir kommen dann in die Präduie, wir kommen lieber bei dir vorbei.
Also die Details sind da wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, finde ich. Aber das denke ich häufiger, wenn ich Ausarbeitungen im FAZ-Einspruch-Podcast höre, wo sie es wirklich auf die juristischen... Also in dem Fall ging es wirklich, wo steht das Komma in diesem Text? Was bedeutet das jetzt? Und meine kleine Vulgär-Verkürzung ist jetzt, wenn Netanyahu in Deutschland ist, bricht das Weltrecht über Deutschland herein. Und dann werden Menschenrechte durchgesetzt. Und Deutschland hat, also das üblicherweise vorhandene Immunitätsrecht für Staatspräsidenten, Regierungschefs usw. gilt dann nicht. Und Deutschland hat kein eigenes Gnadenrecht, dass da irgendwie auf Anweisungen des Bundeskanzleramts reagiert, die Polizei nicht oder sowas. Also das gibt es dann einfach nicht. Und faktisch gesehen, also juristisch faktisch gesehen, wird Deutschland dann tätig werden müssen. Deutschland hat die Verträge unterschrieben. Netanyahu muss dann ausgeliefert festgehalten werden, damit er dann da vor Gericht gestellt werden kann. Die Diskussion, die in Deutschland ja geführt wird, ist ja haarsträubend, weil da nämlich genau diese Rule-Based-Ordnung aufgehoben wird. Und am krassesten fand ich das bei Augstein. Augstein hat ein sehr interessantes Gespräch über die möglichen Zukunft Israels und des ganzen Raumes dort geführt. Und referierte dann nur kurz, dass sein Kumpel Blume, vom damals Spiegel, heute irgendwo, RTL, genau, RTL-Chef da beim Nachrichtenbetrieb, dass der meinte, wenn es dazu kommt, das Netanyahu herkäme, dann wäre ihm dieses ganze Weltrechtszeug egal, dann gilt für ihn einfach nur die Lehren des Holocaust. Wir dürfen Israel nicht beschädigen. Und da hab ich so gedacht, jetzt beißen sich alle Paradoxien gegenseitig. Denn es ist eine Folge der Aufarbeitung des Holocaust und so weiter, dass man überhaupt so eine Weltordnung hat, in der es möglich ist, ein lokales Recht auszusetzen oder Menschen von außerhalb, also sich in ein Land einzumischen und zu sagen, ihr müsst ihn jetzt festnehmen. Also gerade dieser Haftbefehl ist historisch wirklich sehr gut herleitbar aus diesen Nürnberger Prozessen. Dass man sagt, okay, ihr habt wirklich hier nicht nur Menschen, sondern die Menschheit selbst ist euch zur Opfer gefallen und wir stellen euch jetzt vor Gericht, wir richten jetzt hier ein Gericht ein. Und dass Blohm dann auf so eine Idee kommt, erst mal nur referiert von Augstein, keine Ahnung, wie er das dann begründet, sowas.
Ich hab das schon häufiger gehört jetzt. Also bei Twitter konnte man ähnliche Takes ja lesen von Journalisten, die sagen, nein, das spielt keine Rolle. Ich würde auch sagen, wenn ich es jetzt realpolitisch betrachte, kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen, dass es stattfindet. Also momentan haben wir die Situation, dass selbst wenn da in Gaza Zelte bombardiert werden und Menschen einfach verbrennen, man immer noch solche Tweets vom Auswärtigen Amt liest, die sagen, wir möchten an dieser Stelle noch einmal anmahnen, dass es wichtig ist, sicherzustellen das. Und dann kommt irgendwann, es sollten nicht so schlimme Dinge passieren. Und das ist so das Höchste der Gefühle, wie weit man sich herauswagt. Und dann gleichzeitig zu denken, dass Netanyahu verhaftet wird, ist einfach so ein Kontrast dazu, dass man sagen wird, ja, man würde einen Weg finden, damit eine solche Verhaftung nicht stattfinden muss. Und das einfachste wäre selbstverständlich, dass Netanyahu nie wieder Deutschland besuchen wird.
Ja, zu diesem Pragmatismus würde ich auch sagen, selbst wenn es dieses Gericht und die Anklage und was auch immer dieses Ersuchen nicht gäbe, es wäre gerade nicht vorstellbar, dass Netanyahu überhaupt noch Deutschland zu suchen, Deutschland bekommt. Also in der Ansicht ist das so eine theoretische Diskussion, die pragmatisch einfach eh schon abgeräumt war. Aber es ist trotzdem erstaunlich, dass allein, weil die Theorie jetzt im Raum steht, dass es passieren könnte, ganz viele Kommentatoren entweder die Frage aufwerfen, was tun wir denn dann, oder sich wie Blume direkt festlegen. Und in der Ansicht ist es sehr lehrreich.
Vielleicht kommen wir heute noch dazu, zu diesem selektiven Universalismus. Das ist auch gut, selektiver Universalismus. Ja, immer dann, wenn man es gerade braucht. Also ich würde sagen, dieser selektive Universalismus, jetzt kommen wir schon ein bisschen ab vom Thema, aber der ist doch gerade bei dem Nord-Ost-Konflikt oder Krieg mit Händen zu greifen. Einmal das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, dass man sagt, nein, dann internationale Krieg. So, UN, was soll das überhaupt eigentlich alles? Wo man sich aber noch zwei Jahre vorher bei Russlands Angriffe auf die Ukraine genau auf das die ganze Zeit bezogen hat.
Das sind alles Menschenrechtsverletzungen und alles Kriegsverbrechen.
Richtig hat man da gemacht. Zugleich aber, würde ich auch der Fernness halber sagen wollen, oder es ist mir ein Anliegen, das zu sagen, dass auch der selektive Universalismus bei einigen Protesten zu erleben ist. Also es gibt Leute, die protestieren gegen das Leid in Gaza. Die protestieren dagegen, dass Deutschland weiter Waffen liefert. Und das finde ich auch alles richtig. Aber wir haben auch jetzt zum Beispiel an Universitäten gesehen, dass dann an die Türen von jüdischen Dozenten Hamas-Zeichen geschmiert worden. Oder denk an den Eurovision Song Contest. Das war sehr interessant. Ja, ich hab's natürlich auch nicht gesehen, weil ich die Veranstaltung, die Musik schrecklich finde. Aber ich war in Wiesbaden und habe dort Anna Netrebko gesehen. Und ich kann sagen, es ist grandios. Aber darauf würde ich jetzt nicht eingehen. Aber was fand da statt? Also vor der Oper Wiesbaden demonstrierten laut dpa 400, ich würde sagen 200 Leute, haben Slava Ukraini gerufen, no Netrebko. Ich habe mir sagen, dass ein Netrebko entweder von der Polizei eskortiert werden oder heimlich in Privatautos durch die Gegend gefahren werden, damit sie überhaupt in dieses Theater gelangt, weil sonst die Wege blockiert werden. Ich dachte, mein Gott, wie falsch ist das, so etwas zu tun? Also was für ein Wahnsinn, dass man seine Kritik an Putin jetzt an Netrebko rauslässt. Oder dann muss man vor dem Kanzleramt stehen und sagen, wir demonstrieren hier, der soll mehr Waffen liefern, oder was auch immer. Aber Netrebko, weil die da früher mal im Kreml aufgetreten ist, das halte ich für völlige Nonsens. Und dann, einen Tag später, ist der ESC, und dann demonstrieren Abertausende vor dem Hotel der israelischen Sängerin und lassen ihre Wut über Gaza, über Netanjahos Politik an dieser Frau aus, als sei sie dafür verantwortlich. Und da muss ich sagen, das hat dann schon eine ganz klar antisemitische Komponente, wenn man jetzt plötzlich sucht, wer ist jetzt jüdisch oder wer ist Israeli, und die müssen jetzt zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden. Die eine singt, die anderen dozieren an der Uni, möglicherweise vertreten die Positionen, die man nicht mag, dann kann man diskutieren. Und dass das aber dann in so einer Weise stattfindet, finde ich so falsch. Und zugleich ist es wieder so, dass die CDU und die Bild-Zeitung dann einen ganz besonderen tut, als seien alle, die an der Uni gerade demonstrieren, in Wahrheit Hamas-Unterstützer. Also das ist ein solcher Wahnsinn, der da stattfindet.
Konflikte werden generalisiert.
Und da sieht man einfach, dass dieses Prinzip selektiver Universalismus sich längst überall ausgebreitet hat. Aber gehen wir mal zu diesen Fragen der Menschenrechte. Was ist denn, wenn Menschenrechtsverstöße stattfinden?
Das war zur Zeit des Kalten Krieges sehr, sehr schwer möglich, weil das einzige Organ der Vereinten Nationen, das Zwangsmittel hat, der Sicherheitsrat ist, und der war blockiert. Deswegen hat sich das verändert nach Ende des Kalten Krieges. Und wir haben klare Fälle, wo zugunsten von Menschenrechten eben auch der Sicherheitsrat tätig wurde.
In der Erfenbeinküste und in Libyen.
Das war später dann mit der Responsibility to Protect. Aber wir haben schon vorher, wenn Sie nur denken, zum Beispiel an Ost-Diemer zum Beispiel, wir haben auch die ganze Zeit nach dem Bosnienkrieg. Also während des Bosnienkriegs hat es leider noch nicht funktioniert, weil das Ganze noch ziemlich neu war und die europäischen Staaten hier unterschiedliche Spiele gespielt haben.
Also wir merken jetzt schon, ja, es gibt dieses internationale Recht, aber Staaten können ihre eigenen Spiele spielen und dann gibt es so ein Veto-Recht. Aber manchmal hat man dann auch tatsächlich diese Verstöße ahnden können. Jetzt gibt es noch etwas, das verbunden ist mit den Menschenrechten, nämlich das Gewaltverbot in der UNO-Satzung.
Zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte der Menschheit wurde der Krieg verboten. Das Gewaltverbot der UNO-Satzung ist ganz was Wesentliches. Und man hat gesagt, wenn ein Staat einen anderen angreift, dann ist der Sicherheitsrat gefordert, hier Frieden zu schaffen. Und wenn das nicht anders geht, mit einem stehenden Heer der Vereinten Nationen. Das ist aber nie geschaffen worden. Wer finanziert dieses Heer? Wer befehle ich dieses. Da gibt es viele Überlegungen, zu sagen, ein stehendes Heer, so wie es auch ohne Polizei gibt und so weiter. Das kann man ohne Beamte geben. Der Oberste Befehlshaupt ist der Generalsekretär, dann gibt es einen Militärausschuss.
Das klingt ja alles mal sehr plausibel, aber wir können uns ja jetzt mit den strukturellen Realisten fragen, ist das realistisch? Also ist es vorstellbar, dass man ein stehendes Heer hat, das eine solche Macht ausüben kann, wo die einzelnen Nationalstaaten dann nicht sagen können, oder es wohl war aber jetzt gerade nicht. Das heißt also, gibt es eine übergeordnete Instanz? Kann es die in dieser Weise geben, wie das hier ausgemalt wird? Wir überhalten das jetzt also im Hinterkopf und widmen uns den strukturellen Realisten tun, das zunächst mit Susanne Weige, den Schwietzschrig. Sie war bei Junge naiv zu Gast und hat da über China gesprochen. Sie erklärt erstmal, was struktureller Realismus ist.
Also ich bin ein sogenannter struktureller Realist. Das heißt also, mich interessieren, wie Länder sich in einem von mir angenommenen System von internationalen Beziehungen positionieren und wie sie ihre Beziehungen zu anderen Ländern definieren. Und zwar unabhängig davon, ob ich jetzt über Länder ähnlicher ideologischer Ausrichtung nachdenke oder nicht, oder ob ich über Länder nachdenke, die sehr ähnliche Interessen haben oder nicht.
Könnte man eigentlich sagen, das sind einfach Spieltheoretiker?
In gewisser Weise ja. Sie sind Spieltheoretiker bzw. es sind Analytiker von Strukturen. Spieltheorie ist ja sehr, so was wird der andere machen, wenn der eine dies und das tut. Aber ja, im Prinzip ist es eine Art der Spieltheorie. Und es ist damit losgelöst von Werten, von normativen Grundlagen.
Bei mir ist das das 1. Mai jetzt untergekommen. Also dieses strukturelle Realismus. Klingt ja schon so, als hätte sich jemand Gedanken darüber gemacht, so eine Schule zu formen. Dass man weiß, wann man jetzt im Rahmen dessen ist oder nicht. Ich hab mich jedenfalls, ich weiß das noch so als Schüler, als ich hörte, ja, Hitler und Stalin haben dann so einen Pakt geschlossen. Dass sie sich nicht angreifen. Und ich dachte so, warum? Also wie? Ja, war da jemand mit dem Raum? Wo klagt man das ein, wenn man da doch überfallen würde, wie auch immer? Also da liegt so eine gewisse Hanebüchigkeit drin irgendwie, die so völlig bescheuert ist. Und seitdem war ja eigentlich klar, keine Ahnung, das ist, also ich frag mich, warum das jetzt erst kommt. Haben wir, wir haben uns ja viel darüber unterhalten im letzten Salon, Demokratie und ihre Theorie. Und dann hab ich ja immer versucht, naja, aber diese Theorie ist doch immer noch Quatsch gewesen. Also eine Demokratie-Theorie, ja, wir haben Sonntagsreden und der ganze Kram. Also jetzt hat man so ein Label für strukturellen Realismus. Und ich hör das gerade zum ersten Mal und denk mir, warum ist das nicht der Ausgangspunkt?
Das ist genau die richtige Frage. Und die würden sowohl John Marschheimer wie auch Susanne Weiglen-Schwietzschrick stellen. Nämlich sie hat sich gedacht in den 70er-Jahren, als sie studierte.
Hab ich irgendwann als relativ junger Mensch mir die Entscheidung abgerungen, dass ich die Welt nicht so sehen will, wie ich sie gerne hätte, sondern, dass ich lernen möchte, die Welt zu sehen, wie sie ist.
Und dabei arbeitet sie, und das ist aber nur dies, also die Welt zu sehen, wie sie ist. Und ich will hier deutlich machen, ich werde, M. Schheimer hat tausende Interviews jetzt gegeben in den letzten zwei Jahren. Nicht, dass mir jetzt morgen jemand schreibt, ja, aber der hat das falsch gesehen, das war mit Jelzin damals so und der hat dann eine falsche Sicht auf Russland oder so. Das interessiert mich jetzt hier alles nicht. Und ob ich hier nochmal eine andere Haltung zu China einnehmen würde, als weigelehnen Schwietrich kann, ich weiß nicht richtig, wie ich den Namen ausspreche, ist sicherlich zu finden. Aber ich glaube, diese Haltung zu sagen, ich versuche mal nicht mit meiner Moral und allem ranzugehen, sondern versuche erstmal zu beschreiben, wie die Welt ist. Allein die Beschreibung sorgt in einer deutschen Talkshow dafür, dass Strack Zimmermann sagt, ja, da sind sie doch, sie Putin-Versteher. Also ist es einfach gar nicht möglich, nur zu sagen, ja so scheint es wohl zu sein. Ich weiß, dass wir hier anfangs, als der Krieg begann, so eine Debatte abgebildet haben über die Frage, ist das ein Stellvertreterkrieg? Und dann haben die, die sich auch gerne jetzt in Deutschland so Realisten nennen, ja so aus der Masala-Sicherheits-Podcast-Ecke. Die wollen natürlich von sowas dann gar nichts wissen. Also die versuchen realistisch zu sein mit, ja irgendwie wir brauchen so eine realistische, alltägliche Härte, aber auch unsere Moral. Aber dass man einfach sagt, ja natürlich ist das ein Stellvertreterkrieg, wird natürlich von so Realisten viel eher erkannt. Und dann ist davon ja erst mal gar nichts abzuleiten, außer die Frage, wie geht man dann damit um, wenn das so ist?
Ja, also bevor du jetzt die Clips spielst und wir uns darauf einlassen, will ich noch mal markieren, wie schräg und unverständlich ich es finde, dass es überhaupt einen anderen Ansatz gibt, der, und hier hört man ja, sie muss das mal begründen, warum sie da so und so rangeht. Ich war beim Gespräch von Michel Friedmann, der ja zu jeder Opernpremiere immer so eine Talkrunde nochmal macht. Mir ist ja egal, worüber und welcher Anlass, ihm auch erstaunlicherweise. Ja, der Tannhäuser, der Tannhäuser. Es war zur Premiere des Tannhäuser. Ich habe ihren Namen gerade nicht parat, aber er hat sich das Thema Sexualität rausgesucht und hatte eine wirklich sehr renommierte Wissenschaftlerin ihm gegenüber, die zum Thema Sexualität seit Jahrzehnten und auf allen Kontinenten forscht, lehrt, was auch immer. So, und ich habe selten jemand akademisch so scheitern sehen am Alltag. Also, dass einfach Fragen kommen, warum mögen Menschen, ich nehme jetzt mal mich als heterosexueller Mann, Schwule nicht? Diese Frage hat Friedman so in den Raum gestellt.
Als seine schöne Provokation.
Ja, einfach, und auch mit so Nachfragen, nachdem dann ewig nichts kam. Sie wurden doch ausgebildet in diesen Fragen, oder? So, also er hat sie wirklich provoziert. Er hat diesen Advokatus Diaboli-Rolle genommen und wirklich nicht nur referiert, dass manche Menschen Schwule nicht mögen, sondern er hat wirklich auch in deren Wortlaut diese Ablehnung, Abneigung dargebracht. Und das Einzige, was von ihr kam, war... Ja, das ist ja auch ein Problem. Und darüber sollte man ja auch nachdenken, und wäre es nicht besser, das?
Klar.
Und es war dann wieder so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, wenn jetzt die strukturellen Realisten kommen, und zwar gerade in so einer Zeit, in der Kriege toben, brauchen wir wirklich Kriege, damit vernünftige, mitdenkende Menschen wie Politikwissenschaftler nicht einfach morgens ihr Haus verlassen und sagen, ich musste mich jetzt in die Realität mit einem Kind rumschlagen, mit dem Berufsverkehr, mit was auch immer, jetzt sitze ich in meinem Büro und mache meine Arbeit und denke mir eine Welt aus, ist mir doch scheißegal, was in der Realität vorliegt. Ich möchte gern normativ durchprügeln, was ich hier als Idee habe. Dann erinnert man sich irgendwie an Aristoteles und Hannah Arendt, und deren tollste Sinnsprüche, und schreibt Kalendersprüche auf 50 Seitenlänge.
Du wirst jetzt als zynisch beschrieben, aber wir hatten diese Diskussion ja auch schon im Salon, wenn wir solche D-Cross-Ansätze beschäftigt haben. Dann stellt man sich die Frage, ist das wahrscheinlich, dass wir, wie wir hier so sitzen, reden, oder die, die uns zuhören, auf 80% ihres Lohns verzichten, damit man eine Umverteilung machen kann, damit alle auf der Welt auf einem Standard sind, wie ein deutscher Bürgergeldempfänger, und dann sagt man nein. Gibt es Beispiele von Ökonomien, die radikal geschrumpft wurden und wo die Menschen glücklich waren? Nein. Ist es also politisch vorstellbar, dass sowas umgesetzt wird? Nein. Aber dann ist es doch vom Tisch. Wäre das irgendwie schön, wenn das dann dadurch alles ökologisch wäre? Ja, kann sein. Aber das ist doch ein, und das verstehe ich auch nicht, dass man einfach, also man kann ja Fiktion schreiben. Also es gibt ja tolle Science-Fiction-Autoren.
Also ich sehe sehr viele Mörschheimer Clips, ich kenne nur die vom Deutschlandfunk. Und es ist nicht nur ein persönliches Interesse von mir, jetzt mir noch mehr dazu anzuhören, und du widest es uns dankbarerweise da, sondern ich will auch Gott schildern. Dieses Deutschlandfunk-Gespräch gehört zu haben, war für mich auch erlösend, befreiend. Endlich hat mal einer irgendeinen vom Deutschlandfunk, und sie haben es dann auch gesendet, mal den Kopf gewaschen.
So. Haben sofort auch welche vom Sicherheitspodcast geschrieben. Ja, das sei ja unmöglich. Hier würde man wieder sehen, wie mörschheim und so weiter ist. Ich hab mir das Originalgespräch angehört, man kann es in Englisch gar nicht hören. Es ist eine Stunde lang, und daraus sind auch die Clips. Aber wir gehen erst noch mal zu unserer Chinarexpertin. Sie stellt ihr Dreieck vor.
Und sage, in unserer augenblicklichen Welt gibt es drei Länder, die nenne ich das strategische Dreieck. Und diese drei Länder bestimmen im Grunde genommen, so böse das klingt, über unser Wohl und Wehe. China, Russland und Amerika, das sind die drei größten Nuklearmächte.
Und die anderen spielen erst mal keine Rolle. Und dann vergleicht sie das jetzt realitätsangebunden an folgende Konstellationen.
Wenn man über ein Dreieck nachdenkt, dann sagt man normalerweise, also ich bin eine Mutter von drei Kindern. Und ich weiß, die einfachste Lösung für meine drei Kinder ist zwei gegen ein.
Ja, also wenn die Kinder was durchsetzen wollen, muss man sich einen Verbündeten nehmen. Und genau diese Dreieck-Konstellationen finden jetzt gerade statt. Das wirkt jetzt wahnsinnig schlicht. Aber man kommt damit, glaube ich, wenn man so draufblickt, erst mal sehr weit. Man wird nicht alles damit laufen erklären können. Und es gibt natürlich auch Widerstreitendes. Und das habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht. Zum Beispiel gibt es ja die, jetzt war ja so der Diskurs sehr stark, China und Russland paktieren. Und man würde erst mal sagen, ja klar, die machen jetzt gerade sehr viel und profitieren davon. Zugleich wissen wir, die chinesische Seitenstraße sollte auch durch die Ukraine gehen. Die Ukraine hat eine ganz wichtige Funktion. Dieses Projekt ist durch Russlands Angriff erst mal auf Eis gelegt. Also ist nicht so, dass das nur so, aber wir haben da wieder eine Dreieck-Konstellation, wo man dann sagen kann, aha, aber was ergibt sich jetzt aus dieser neuen Konstellation des Krieges für die drei Akteure?
Vielleicht können wir ja bei den Clips, wo sie es anbietet Schritt für Schritt, skeptische Hörer mitnehmen. Denn ich hab ja eben schon grinsen müssen, bevor du den Clip gespielt hast, weil du schon drei Kinder reingeschrieben hast, den Clipnamen. Und dieser Bogenschlag aus die drei großen globalen Atommächte, die also grob überschlagen 1,8 Milliarden Menschen repräsentieren, werden jetzt auf drei Kinder morgens am Frühstückstisch. Und jetzt hört man schon die kritischen Stimmen, die sagen, das ist zu einfach und das muss man differenzierter betrachten. Und ich sage, nein, wir brauchen hier eine allgemeinverständliche Heuristik. Wir brauchen eine Approximationshoffnung und ein, nicht ein Verständnis, sondern eine Sensibilität dafür, dass auch die Atommächte von 1,8 Milliarden Menschen von Menschen regiert werden. So, wir haben es hier wirklich mit drei, keine Kinder, aber Menschen zu tun. Joe Biden, Xi, Putin. Und wenn jetzt jemand kommt, nee, wir brauchen eine ganz komplizierte Theorie. Wir müssen davon abstrahieren, dann sagen wir, nee, diese ganze Idee der, wir haben hier drei Atommächte, wie sie sagt, kommt daraus geboren, dass wir drei Atommächte haben. Nicht vier und auch nicht eine andere Basis als Atommächte, sondern es sind drei Atommächte. Und warum sollte man jetzt nicht einfach da ansetzen und sagen, es ist wie in der guten alten Gesellschaft, also die gute Gesellschaft. Am Hofe kommt es drauf an, ob die Interaktion gelingt. Wenn ja, ist alles gut. Wenn nicht, ist Krieg. Aber drei Leute reden hintereinander. Oder nicht?
Die deutsch-französische Freundschaft beruht sehr stark darauf, dass sich die beiden Staatsoberhäupter gut verstehen. Und wenn sie sich nicht gut verstehen, dann ist das ganze Gefüge in Gefahr.
Wir haben das Buch von Patrick gelesen. Die Autobranchen, die jeweils wichtigen Branchen des Landes, schlagen sich kurz und klein und stehen in einem echten Krieg. Aber für uns ist nur entscheidend, ob sich Chirag und Kohl die Hand geben.
Der Herr Putin, nach meiner Analyse, hat unter anderem auch deshalb zum Mittel des Krieges gegriffen, weil er gemerkt hat, oh, das ist ja interessant, diese Amerikaner und die Chinesen, die stehen zwar in starker Konkurrenz miteinander, aber die überlegen gerade, ob sie sich nicht die Welt so ein bisschen teilen können. Die eine Hälfte für China, die andere Hälfte für Amerika. Und wo sitze ich dann mit meinen ganzen Nuklearwaffen? Ich bin doch die größte Nuklearmacht der ganzen Welt. Und die reden gar nicht über mich. Und seitdem der Herr Putin diesen Krieg gegen die Ukraine begonnen hat, ist interessanterweise ja so, dass niemand wagen würde zu sagen, ja eine zukünftige Gewälte brauchen wir doch über Russland nicht nachzudenken.
Wir hören ja jetzt aus einem dreistündigen, sehr höhenswerten Gespräch nur einzelne Clips, aber wir bekommen Verständnis für diese Art des strategischen Denkens. Sie buchstabiert das dann noch weiter aus.
Nach meiner Auffassung ist die Veränderung der Weltordnung eine ganz wichtige Zielsetzung, die er interessanterweise mit dem Mittel des Krieges herbeiführen will. Da würde man sagen, ja warum eigentlich, wieso kann man das nicht anders lösen? Das ist immer so, dass Länder, die sich im Hinterhalt fühlen, zum Beispiel auch Japan im 19. Jahrhundert, zu dem Schluss kommen, dass es keinen anderen Weg gibt, die anderen Länder dieser Welt davon zu überzeugen, dass man ihnen zuhören muss als den militärischen.
Das ist natürlich eine fatale Logik, die hier beschrieben wird. Und wir, bei allem Respekt für diesen Blick auf die Geopolitik, ist es natürlich etwas sehr Trauriges, dem man so beiwohnt. Denn auch wenn das ein schönes Bild ist mit den Kindern, also man ist quasi Launen ausgesetzt, aber man selbst ist ja machtlos in dem Sinne. Also ich kann nicht sagen, wir machen es jetzt folgendermaßen, sondern man ist dem ausgesetzt, diesem Gefüge. Und deswegen muss natürlich immer diese Utopie, und das negiert sie im Übrigen auch nicht, da sein. Gäbe es denn noch eine ganz andere Möglichkeit? Also könnte man doch irgendwas jenseits dieser nationalstaatlichen Dreiecks organisieren oder so. Aber das ist etwas, was jetzt nicht die strukturellen Realisten beschäftigt, was uns aber natürlich beschäftigen sollte, weil man natürlich sagen kann, dann kann man immer nur hoffen. Also dann kann man jeden Abend beten, dass die Herrscher sich auch morgen noch gut vertragen werden.
Ja, aber das ist nun mal die Logik. Wir sind dem ausgeliefert.
Das ist die Logik, genau. Und das ist aber, verschliesst jetzt nicht alles utopische. Aber ich glaube, wenn man das heute und auch noch das morgen besprechen will, dann kann man das nur so sehen, dass man denen ausgeliefert ist. Jetzt gibt es ja diese Rede davon, dass Putin Imperialist ist, ein neuer Imperialist. Scholz gebraucht das Wort, aber auch viele andere. Will also Putin sehr viel mehr erobern, steht der jetzt bald vor Berlin. Wie das ja jetzt gerade in der Aufrüstung...
Was die deutsche Hysterie ja so treibt.
Ganz richtig.
Wenn diese Gefahr als ach nee, doch nicht, dann sieht alles ganz anders aus. Also dann werden Corona-Maßnahmen von heute auf morgen feingelassen. Und dann gibt es auch doch keine Impfpflicht, obwohl doch alle so dafür waren und so.
Du hast ja eben schon uns von Truppenstärken und Demografie einiges gesagt.
Diese Logik wird, glaube ich, bei uns im Augenblick ein bisschen wenig diskutiert. Sondern man denkt immer, Russland will die ganze Welt erobern und solche Sachen. Das ist meiner Meinung nach nicht der Fall. Ja, also es gibt ja Leute, die, glaube ich nicht dran. Nein, die haben gar nicht die Kapazität. Die müssen ja nicht nur uns erobern, die müssen uns ja auch besetzen. Und wenn man jetzt mal überlegt, dass die Chinesen meinen, dass sie 500.000 Soldaten brauchen, um so einen kleinen Ort wie Taiwan zu besetzen, wie viel Soldaten braucht Herr Putin, um uns alle zu besetzen?
Also für Frankfurt alleine würde ich sagen 100.000. Darunter wäre das nicht zu machen. Muss ja jede Straßenecke irgendwie sagen, ich bin der neue Landesherr und so. Sonst geht hier einfach weiter Berufsverkehr und es interessiert niemanden. So wie auch so niemanden interessiert, was die Politik hier gerade macht.
Wir springen jetzt schon einmal vor zum Mörschheimer, der kommt auch auf die Truppenstärke zu sprechen.
Furthermore, he went into Ukraine, the Russian army went into Ukraine with at the very most 190,000 troops. There is absolutely no way he could have conquered all of Ukraine with 190,000 troops. When the Germans went into Poland on September 1st 1939, and you want to remember the Germans were only going to capture the western half of Poland, because the Soviet Union was going to capture the eastern half of Poland. So the Germans went into Poland September 1st 1939 to conquer it and incorporate it into a greater Germany with 1.5 million troops. Does anyone seriously believe that Putin with 190,000 troops at the very most was going to be able to conquer all of Ukraine, which is much bigger than Poland and certainly much bigger than the western half?
Ja, und daraus, Schlussfolger hat er dann auch, dass es also nicht sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass Putin bald in Deutschland auf der Matte steht. Nun gehen wir noch einmal.
Da finde ich, also demografisch, man kann ja mal alle Kategorien, also das ist jetzt erstmal nur Tropenstärke. Beim Thema, was ist, wenn jetzt, so wie vorhin beschrieben, dieser Ukraine-Krieg überwunden ist. Ich will nicht sagen beendet irgendwann, einfach nur so überwunden im Sinne von, ja, das ist jetzt so eingehegt wie nach 2014. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, na 1,5 Millionen, so viel haben ja die Chinesen. Aber die Chinesen sind auch tausende Kilometer weit weg. Also es sind auch wieder so Kategorien über die, also wo man auch wieder von ihm so einen Spruch hätte. Ja, also die können sich gar nicht in Bewegung setzen, ohne dass man das sieht und so weiter. Also lauter solche Sachen. Dass mal eine Rakete, die ukrainische Grenze nach Polen, da haben wir gesehen, was das schon bedeutet und so. Wie dann alle miteinander erst mal telefonieren müssen. Also es gibt hier ganz viele Kategorien, zu denen man nichts anderes sagen kann, als einfach mal realistisch drauf geguckt. Also bei Arte, mit offenen Karten. Das ist so erstaunlich, wenn man sich die Weltkarte anschaut und mal nicht dieses mega lang gezogene Russland, sondern einfach mal so groß, wie es wirklich ist. Und dann sieht man, ach so, Afrika. Afrika, wir sollten eigentlich nur über Afrika nachdenken, weil das einfach zehnmal so groß ist wie Europa und wie immer die ganze Zeit dieses eurozentrische Weltbild und so. Also es gibt so ganz viele Kategorien in diesem strukturellen Realismus, hoffe ich, die man da einfach mal mobilisieren könnte. Wo es dann jedem wie dem Schuppen von den Augen fällt, der jetzt so eine Hysterie die ganze Zeit fährt.
Gehen wir nochmal zu Frank Nowak, dem Menschenrechtsexperten bei Precht. Der wird auf den Nahostkrieg angesprochen und sieht durchaus die Möglichkeit, dass aus der UNO so ein Welt-Schiedsrichter werden könnte.
Also halten Sie tatsächlich denkbar, dass wir in den nächsten Jahrzehnten in eine solche Entwicklung gehen können, die die UNO wirklich zu einem ernstzunehmenden Welt-Schiedsrichter machen könnte?
Ich glaube nicht in Jahrzehnten, ich glaube schon viel früher. Ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass der derzeitige Krieg Israels gegen die Hamas in Gaza eine große Chance für die UNO wäre, hier wirklich wieder aktiv zu werden, wenn die USA bereit sind, ihr Wetterecht aufzugeben. Sie haben das bei der letzten Sicherheitsratsresolution schon getan. Sie haben damit ein deutliches Zeichen gesetzt.
Aber sind die USA oder ist irgendein Land aus diesem Dreieck, können wir auch fragen, bereit, sich zurückzunehmen? Also wenn wir jetzt in dieser Dreieckslogik bleiben, dann ist das der absolute Kontrast dazu. Und deswegen spiele ich es natürlich auch. Also das wäre ja wünschenswert, was jetzt Manfred Nowak uns hier schildert. Und Precht kann das auch nur noch mal so bestätigen. Er fasst das gesamte Gespräch mit ihm zusammen.
Also Ihre Vorstellung, dass die UNO als Phönix aus der Asche, aus dem Nahost-Konflikt aufsteigen könnte und dass sie eine wichtige und unverzichtbare Rolle dabei spielen könnte, den Übergang hin zu einer multipolaren Weltordnung friedlich. Statt durch Kriege zu lösen, ist eine so schöne Vorstellung, dass ich sie gerne mit Ihnen teilen würde.
Also, was wir hier übersehen ist die deutsche Blickrichtung auf die UN, so wie wir gerade an der Seite Israels stehen, kann gar nicht in den Blick nehmen, erstens wie sehr dieser Gazakrieg, die nicht nur muslimische Welt, die allein schon zwei Milliarden Menschen sind, sondern darüber hinaus aufwühlt, also wirklich bewegt einfach, schon allein weil man da andere Reports kriegt von vor Ort. Man sieht einfach anderes von Gaza und vor allem Rafa. Und alles was daraus erwachsen würde, also dass sich Länder zusammenschließen und dann auch miteinander schon vereinbaren, so du nimmst jetzt diese Menschenrechtsklage, du nimmst die und so weiter und dann baut sich das alles so zusammen, dass das gegen die deutsche Sichtweise organisiert wird. Also dass gerade die, wie nennen wir es, den globalen Süden und so, dass der globale Süden sich gerade politisch gegen uns mobilisiert. In welche Richtung, keine Ahnung, aber diese Idee, warum nicht, Europa könnte ja noch eine Rolle spielen. Macron hat es ja jetzt ganz deutlich gemacht. Also er hat wirklich explizit gesagt, ich bin bereit, die französische Atomabwehrkraft auf europäischen Niveau neu zu denken. So, dann kam natürlich wieder Pistorius und so weiter. Nee, wir haben doch die Amerikaner und so. Also es wurde wieder unten gespielt. Aber angenommen, das würde wirklich verknüpft mit so einem ganz großen Europa spielt sich jetzt weltweit mal wieder ein bisschen auf. Denn ich habe mir jetzt die Tage mit meinem kleinen Sohn die Weltkarte angeschaut und so. Und dann war echt die Frage, warum ist Europa ein eigener Kontinent? Also man sieht das so und denkt, ja, ich kann es dir nicht erklären. Na ja, aber da ist so eine kleine Landzunge, die halb so groß ist wie Indien oder so. Und die sagt dann, ich bin Europa. Warum? Also wenn du sagst, so guck mal, das ist Afrika, das ist Südamerika, das ist Nordamerika, das ist Europa. Verstehe ich nicht. Warum? Also es ist doch nur so eine kleine Ecke an Asien oder so. Ja, also da ist so große Frage. Und wenn wir jetzt so eine Mobilisierung im Geiste, weil es einfach so viele Leute bewegt, was da in Gaza passiert, und dass es aber getrieben ist, von so einem eurozentrischen Denken, dass man die UN da irgendwie mal so marginalisiert und dann mal so über dem Recht steht und es einfach so zulässt, obwohl man doch Errungenschaft hätte. Und wenn Europa jetzt so einen Schritt ginge, zu sagen, okay, also diese Abwehrsache wegen Putin, machen wir jetzt mal europäisch. Und in Zuge dieser Diskussion wird aber auch dieser französische Sitz im Sicherheitsrat mal so europäisiert, so eine rule-based Sache unterworfen. Da macht sich Europa wieder adressierbar für Anliegen. Das ist nicht Südafrika über den Umweg irgendwelche Rechts und so, sondern, nee, dass einfach mal ein südafrikanischer Präsident vielleicht mal in Europa eine Adresse hat zum Vorsprechen und dann einfach solche Fragen mal diskutiert. Ja, das wäre ja alles möglich, wenn Europa als Kontinent das erste Mal dieses Prinzip aufhebt, dass in der UN so Länder gegeneinander. Sondern, nee, es kommt jetzt mit Europa, auch ein europäischer Ideenraum, der die ganze Zeit diskutiert wird, oder wie auch immer. Also, wäre schon möglich, dass jetzt viel Bewegung da ist. Vielleicht wirklich wünschenswerter als, und man hört ja auch an mir, wie ich es sage, so wie Precht, dass man sagt, die Idee alleine ist so gut. Gut, dass wir sie jetzt nicht verteufeln, weil irgendwer wieder mal ein Schlaumeier sein will. Mit einem besseren politischen Argument.
Wir halten dem zwei jetzt gar nicht den harten Realismus entgegen, wollen aber sagen, ja das ist eine sympathische Idee, wenn ich noch eine weitere Gefahr sehe und ich möchte nicht missverstanden werden, ich bin absolut für eine Waffenruhe und war das auch schon vor vielen Monaten und auch schon vor, dass andere Leute jetzt plötzlich auch mal fordern. Aber was ich auch sagen würde oder was mein Verdacht ein bisschen ist, dass sich einige Länder jetzt gerade auf Israel und auch einige Menschen sehr auf Israel einschießen, was nicht nur jetzt mit dem realen Leid, das die israelische Regierung verursacht zu tun hat, sondern auch darüber hinaus, dass man sagt, naja, wir mögen die eh nicht. Und ich will das jetzt gar nicht mit all den großen Begriffen versehen, aber ich sehe da gewisse Doppelstandards und ich habe ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass wenn das mit Israel jetzt meinetwegen alles mal so vollzogen wird und Netanyahu einen Haftbefehl bekommt, dass es nicht unbedingt dazu führen wird, dass man mit anderen Ländern dann auch entsprechend umgeht. Also ob daraus aus diesem, ich sehe das Leid in Gaza, protestiere dagegen, ob daraus ein Universalismus per se erwächst, da bin ich mir zumindest bei vielen Ländern naja, wie soll ich das ausdrücken? Also ich bleibe skeptisch da. Und würde sagen, dass man eher sagt, na Gott sei Dank, jetzt haben wir hier unseren Sünden Bock. Und es ist auch so, dass Israel da ja ganz falsch handelt, das will ich hier nochmal unterstreichen. Aber ich sehe auch sehr viel Wegschauen bei anderen und bin skeptisch. Also meine Tendenz wäre eher, dass es sein kann, dass der Eurozentrismus geschwächt wird. Und er hat es auch eigentlich verdient, weil es wirklich so eine verquere Situation und Diskussion in Deutschland ist und so was. Aber ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass daraus etwas so viel Besseres erwächst.
Ja, aber so wie du jetzt sagst, manche leben jetzt einfach in Antisemitismus aus und den gibt es ja auch staatlich organisiert. Also nicht nur Iran, würde ich sagen. Aber vielleicht ist allein, dass der Vorwurf im Raum stehen kann, hier antisemitisch zu handeln. Ein Katalysator dafür, umso mehr zu betonen, nein, ich will auf die Rule-Based-Ordnung abstellen. Und damit stärkt man sich dann wieder.
Ja, das wäre gut und zu wünschen. Wir gucken uns aber jetzt mal ganz kurz an, was Multipolarität, weil das war jetzt gerade so diese Idee, Multipolarität funktioniert so, dass man da so einen Welt-Schiedsrichter hat in Form der UNO. Multipolarität wird von China anders verstanden.
Also die chinesische Position ist meiner Meinung nach folgende. Einigen wir uns doch mit den Amerikanern darauf, dass wir im Augenblick keinen Krieg gegeneinander führen wollen. Ja, damit haben wir ein bipolares System an der Spitze unserer Weltordnung geschaffen. Da sind zwei sehr starke Mächte, die auch sehr unterschiedlich sind, sehr unterschiedliche Verbündete haben, die einen gehen zu den Chinesen ins Bett, die anderen gehen zu den Amerikanern ins Bett und die achten darauf, dass die Mäuse nicht auf dem Tisch tanzen. Aber eine Etage drunter, da können wir jetzt die vielen Länder, die auch so gerne mit regieren wollen, die könnten wir da aufnehmen. Wir könnten Indien aufnehmen, Japan, wir könnten die EU oder vielleicht sogar Deutschland aufnehmen usw. Und dann ist das aber so, dass diese Volatilität dieser Länder, die wir da auf dem, ich sag immer am Platz der Multipolarität aufnehmen, diese Multipolarität, die können wir dadurch sozusagen regieren, dass wir ja die zwei da oben haben, die immer acht geben, dass es da unten an diesem Tisch nicht zu viel Krach gibt.
Das heißt, diese zwei entmachten sich nicht. Und das ist immer diese Kerntese von den Realisten, Menschenrechte. Alles gut und schön. Aber wer setzt sie durch? Wer kann sie auch übertreten? Und wer entscheidet dann, wo was geahndet wird? Es sind die, die am mächtigsten sind. Es ist das Dreieck, das wäre dann in dieser Idee, die den Chinesen vorschwebt, wären es zwei. Und ähnlich sehen das eigentlich auch die USA mit so einer Bipolarität, aber eigentlich mit dem langfristigen Ziel, dass es wieder eine Unipolarität gibt, nämlich dann eine amerikanisch geführte Welt. Wir hören noch mal zum Sicherheitsrat was.
Und das ist meiner Meinung nach das Bild, was der Xi Jinping sich vorgestellt hat. Das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich, wie auch der Völkerbund sich die Welt vorgestellt hat. Dass man eben sozusagen diese Organisationen der Multilateralität, wie jetzt die UNO, dass man die hierarchisch organisiert. Und wenn man sich die UNO im Augenblick anschaut, dann weiß man ja ganz genau, dass der UNO-Sicherheitsrat zum Beispiel Dinge entscheiden kann, die die Generalversammlung nicht entscheiden kann. Und das ist innerhalb des UNO-Sicherheitsrates. Zum Beispiel Länder gibt es mit Veto-Recht, die entscheiden können, was andere nicht entscheiden können.
Also die Frage ist, wird dieses Dreieck, das sie anfangs beschrieben hat, jetzt möglicherweise aufgelöst, wie das Frank Novak möchte, dass da eine höhere Instanz da ist? Oder bleibt dieses Dreieck oder wird es eine Bipolarität, aber eigentlich bleiben die Machtverhältnisse an den Nationalstaat verquickt? Ja, das ist so, würde John Mersheimer sagen. Und jetzt hören wir dieses Interview, das Stefan D im Deutschlandfunk geführt hat. Erstmal die Frage, was ist denn so ein Realist? Und diese Balance hat jetzt ja eben schon die Chineexpertin beschrieben, indem sie sagt, ja, dieses Dreieck, die müssen schon mal rivalisieren, aber die sind sich jetzt gerade zumindest eigentlich, dass zwischen ihnen direkt kein Krieg ausmacht.
Das ist eigentlich ganz interessant. Hier wird ein bisschen deutlich, warum man überhaupt so einen strukturellen Realismus, ich bleib mal bei diesem Grundbegriff, braucht. Und vor allem für die Beobachtung von außen. Also hier gibt es ja, klar ist er ein Amerikaner, aber wir hören ja schon, es wird über China gesprochen usw. Weil wenn du nur eine Hegemonie hast, also einer regiert die ganze Welt, dann kann der sich selbst verherrlichen. Und dann wäre auch völlig erklärbar oder verständlich, warum der sich die ganze Zeit so Bücher schreiben lässt, in denen er noch mal usw. und ich bin der große Xerxes, ich bin der große Xie. Und dann gibt es eine App mit einer KI, die einem noch mal das rote Buch aufschließt oder wie auch immer. Da kann man alles verherrlichen. Aber wenn es darum geht, dass zwei oder drei, bei vier wird es auch schon wieder kritisch. Und dann hat er eben gesagt, eine Balance finden. Und dann ist es die Macht. Die muss immer neu ausgehandelt werden. Macht auch als Drohmacht. Und die rote Linie ist dann Gewalt. Also man droht nur. Und da, also dieser Denkraum, dass der in Deutschland so gar nicht offen ist, dass man sich zum Beispiel auch nicht fragt. Ok, China schlägt in seiner Region über die Stränge. Da werden Militärübungen in Taiwan abgehalten. Da wird dieses südchinesische Meer, erst mal so unbenannt, das südchinesische Meer. Dann fahren da so Boote, dann bauen da irgendwelche Inseln. Und immer denkt man, ja die sind auf dem Weg, sich selbst zum Hegemon zu machen. Die wollen Amerika überflügeln. Während gleichzeitig in so einer Denke, wie er das vorstellt, Amerika Interesse daran hat, dass es einen Adressaten gibt. Also wenn wir schon nicht der Hegemon der ganzen Welt sind, Amerika, dann noch wenigstens nur einen Adressaten. Also könnte man sogar eine amerikanische Politik verstehen, die sagt, wir lassen China insoweit diese Region dort kontrollieren, dass wir uns nicht auch noch mit Indien rumschlagen müssen, sondern das soll China regeln. So, während in Deutschland dann kommentiert wird, also die Chinesen, die schlagen jetzt völlig über die Strenge, und dann müssen auch die Amerikaner mal aufpassen, und das wird die nächste große, wie dann Tu Sack, schießende Auseinandersetzung, China gegen Amerika. Obwohl es eigentlich auch im amerikanischen Interesse ist, dass wenn man Apple da irgendwie, man braucht eine Million Mitarbeiter und so weiter, und dann gibt es plötzlich einen Konflikt zwischen, sollten die jetzt nicht besser in Indien arbeiten? Nee, das will man ja gar nicht. Also man will es ja da auch verständlich, einfach, überschaubar. Das ist ja wie bei allen kleinen kleinen Diskussionen. Das Wichtigste ist nicht, dass alle irgendwie Geld haben oder so, oder möglichst viel, sondern dass es so eine Perspektive gibt, das geregelt ist, dass man eine Adresse hat, wenn man mal ein Problem hat und so weiter und so fort. Also das mal so runtergedampft, nimmt man mit diesem strukturellen Realismus schon ganz schön viel Dampf, der ansonsten durch so Verherrlichungs- und Verklärungs... Ich würde jetzt sagen, Historien statt Heuristiken. Und dann plötzlich ist Putin immer, der die ganze Zeit die ganze Welt erobern möchte. Dann kommt die so um die Ecke und sagt, locker. Das ist eigentlich super gut.
Er sieht aber auch ein großes Problem jetzt in der amerikanischen Politik. Also Biden ist jemand, der auch idealistisch arbeitet und nicht realistisch arbeitet. Wir hören uns jetzt mal an, also wie sieht denn die Welt eigentlich aus? Also wenn man jetzt mal aus den nationalstaatlichen Logiken rausgeht, wenn man jetzt von außen draufblickt...
Well, the fundamental difference between what happens inside a society or in domestic politics on one hand and the international system on the other hand is that inside a society you have a higher authority that you can turn to for protection. It's called the state. You have hierarchy inside states. In the international system you do not have hierarchy. You have no higher authority. So it's anarchy.
Und wir können jetzt nicht sagen, ja, wenn das jetzt um die Welt geht, also oder um Nationalstaaten, die bestraft werden müssen, dann geht es nicht so leicht, dass man sagt, Manfred Nowak soll sich bitte darum kümmern. Schlussfolgerung?
Das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig interessant, weil wir den Krieg immer unter Eroberungsgesichtspunkten gesehen haben. Also jemand erweitert seinen Handlungsspielraum durch eine Eroberung und wie macht er das? Na ja, militärisch. Und wenn man sich jetzt fragt, was gibt es denn zu erobern? Die Chip-Fabriken, ne, die gibt es nicht zu erobern. Also die werden nur zerstört. Krieg erobert nicht mehr, Krieg zerstört einfach nur noch. Und seine Frage, wie garantiert man jetzt, ich würde sagen, so ein friedliches Zusammenleben? Na ja, alle haben so viele Werte, die einfach nur zerstört würden durch Kriege und nicht erobert, also die kriegt man nicht zurückerobert oder so, die sind dann einfach zerstört. Dass darüber einfach so eine Kostenkalkulation anfängt. Und das hat man ja jetzt immer durchkalkuliert. Also es gibt ja wirklich diese ab wann, im Vergleich zu was kostet ein Krieg, würde es sich rechnen, Taiwan einfach softpowermäßig zu übernehmen. Durch hier mal die Wahl beeinflussen, da mal irgendwie und dann wird halt in 30 Jahren einfach der Stadthalter oder wie auch immer der Ortsbürgermeister chinesischer Herkunft sein oder sowas. Und dass das ernsthaft durchkalkuliert wird und es da so Jahreszahlen in der Diskussion gibt, ich glaube ich habe eine bei Lanz und Brecht da im Podcast gehört, das finde ich schon erstaunlich. Und es ist so ein bisschen, wie wir es eigentlich in vielen Diskussionen haben, beim Thema Klima. Manche Länder der Welt gehen so richtig unter, wenn sich die Welt da nicht einigt, dass man über den letzten Hierarchien der Staaten nochmal was regelt. Nur Deutschland ist trotz allem mehr betroffen vom Klimawandel, weil hier einfach mehr kaputt gehen kann. Und das ist ja jetzt auch eingesickert in die Diskussion.
Nur haben wir ja nicht diese Hierarchie darüber. Also die Hierarchie ist innerhalb der Nationalstaaten und dann vielleicht noch in diesen Verbündeten, die haben auch noch mal eine Hierarchie. Also sicherlich kommen erst die USA in der NATO und dann kommen die anderen Länder. Aber es gibt nicht noch mal eine Hierarchie darüber. Nur in Europa. In Europa genau. Aber über Europa dann nicht noch mal was eigen ist. Und das bedeutet...
Das Problem im internationalen System ist, dass es keine Leviathanen gibt.
Ja, da kommt jetzt so langsam der Einspruch. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit dem Naturzustand? Der herrscht also vor, da gibt es keinen Leviathan. Wenn man jetzt einen Welt-Schiedsrichter hätte, wie Manfred Nowak das gerne hätte, dann könnte man sagen, doch, da ist ja einer. Ist aber nicht da. Würde auch bedeuten, dass die Nationalstaaten freiwillig sich selbst binden, festbinden und Souveränität abgeben. Ist das wahrscheinlich? Hier wieder jetzt die Frage, die sich Realisten stellen. Realisten sagen nein. Er sagt jetzt zu den internationalen Institutionen.
Die Allgemeine Nationen, die United Nations und alle anderen internationalen Institutionen haben keine echten Züge. Wenn ein großer Machtstab wie die USA, Russland oder China entscheidet, dass es die Regeln ignorieren wird, kann es nichts von diesen Institutionen tun.
Ja, wir haben ja jetzt immer so häufig gehört, der völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg wurde also immer noch mal betont, dass Putin sich nicht an Recht und Gesetz gehalten hat. Ja, weil er es kann. Und Irak-Krieg hat stattgefunden, weil sie es können. Und nicht, weil man erst mal sich irgendwo was einholen muss oder so. Man macht es da einfach, wenn man das auch noch bekommt, wenn dann auch noch irgendein Sicherheitsrat oder so noch ein Okay gibt, auch geht es gut. Aber eigentlich macht man, was man kann, wozu man die Macht hat.
Ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass die strukturellen Realisten, um bei mir, denen ja, wie ich eben schon darstelle, etwas hören, ich erkenne das sehr an als Theorie- und Grundlagenbasis, nur dann will ich das auch realistisch in der Gegenwart verortet haben. Ich will dann nicht so was hören mit Hobbs und Leviathan und was in alten Büchern steht. Ich will das bei den einen nicht hören mit Hannah Arendt und Tio und so weiter. Ja, es ist eine tolle Metapher.
Na, es ist ein Naturzustand.
Ja, aber er hat ja gerade in diesen Clips zwei Möglichkeiten gehabt. Entweder uns nochmal was von Hobbs, Naturzustand, Leviathan zu erzählen, oder die UN hat einfach keine Zähne. Warum bleiben wir nicht einfach bei, die UN hat keine Zähne?
Weil der Begriff des Naturzustandes glaube ich schon sehr wichtig ist, um zu begreifen. Also natürlich ist das ja auch eine Fiktion der Politologie, die es aber braucht, damit man beschreiben kann, wie ist also ein Zustand ohne Staat. Und wir sind im zwischenstaatlichen Bereich, weil es keinen übergeordneten Staat gibt, eigentlich wieder in einem Art Naturzustand, wo der Stärkere gewinnt. Es gab aber mal so einen Moment, wo man unipolar agieren konnte.
Mein Argument ist, dass für fast alle seiner Geschichte die USA in einer realistischen Fassung hat und die Realistik des USA mit liberalen Rhetorik verweist. Die eine Exzeption davon ist der unipolare Moment.
Und das war zwischen 1990 und 2017. Da war Ende der Sowjetunion und man konnte jetzt schalten und walten. China war noch nicht stark genug. Und dann hatte man diesen unipolaren Moment.
Aber jetzt wo du die Zeitmark nennst, vor 1990 haben sich einfach zwei Hegemon's gesehen, die sich die ganze Zeit verherrlicht haben. Und wir machen uns so lustig darüber, wie diese Geschichtsbücher aus dem Sozialismus aussehen. Das ist erst mal zehn Seiten Präambel und so weiter und so fort. Ja, und es ist auf der anderen Seite genauso.
Ja klar.
Wir schleppen diese Erben der Die Demokratie-Theorie und hier und die Grundgesetzfeier und das ist das Beste, was Deutschland je hervorgebracht hat. Oton Steinmeier. Das sind auch diese Hegemon's Verherrlichungen. Wir sind gar kein Hegemon. Wir machen es trotzdem immer noch die ganze Zeit.
Ja, und auch diese Bekenntniskultur finde ich so wahnsinnig. Also dass man auch nicht gleich ins Gespräch gehen kann. Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, wir müssten bei jedem Podcast nochmal vorab sagen, dass wir den Krieg von Putin verurteilen, dass wir zwar beide geimpft sind, aber durchaus manche Corona-Maßnahmen nicht so gut fanden, dass wir auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes stehen und trotzdem sagen, gibt man den Vermietern kein Geld mehr. Also dass wir erstmal mal alles auftischen, wofür wir so stehen. Und du sagst dann nochmal, du bist Vater und bist an sich auch für eine anti-autoritäre Erziehung, aber manchmal braucht es auch ein ernstes Wort. Das können wir alles nochmal auflisten.
Wir sollten so eine Fanfare für Artikel 5 Meinungsfreiheit, der uns ermöglicht, dass wir den Podcast machen.
Und vielleicht haben wir dann noch 5 Minuten Zeit und können über was vernünftiges reden.
Das finde ich übrigens bei Friedmann so gut, der ja auch immer diese Vorwürfe kriegt. Wie erklären Sie jetzt Israel? Wieso soll ich jetzt Israel erklären? Freuen Sie sich nicht, dass Jun jetzt wieder in Deutschland, das halte ich für eine Selbstverständlichkeit. Er kann das immer ganz explizit machen, weil er das, was du jetzt sozusagen humorisch vorgetragen wirst, das kriegt er die ganze Zeit serviert. Dann macht er sich darüber lustig.
Wir hören jetzt mal, wie Deetjen nach der internationalen Ordnung fragt.
Aber deine Gegner, zum Beispiel John Eikenberry, die Widerstandsfrau des internationalen Liberalismus, sie sagten, natürlich nicht! Die internationale liberalische Ordnung war nie perfekt, aber wir müssen erlauben, dass es etwas ist, dass Nationen und Staaten sich für etwas umsetzen, und warum sollten wir das erlauben, dass es all die Zeit Fehler waren? Wir sollten weiterhin für das, was sie liberales internationales Ordnung nennen.
Und der Grund, warum du es hattest, war, dass es nur ein großer Machtstück im System war, auf die Definition.
Punkt. Und sonst kann man über das andere reden, das für wünschenswert halten oder auch nicht, aber es war nicht da und wird auch nicht sein. Jetzt schätzt man scheinbar mal die Lage zu China ein. Also er spricht jetzt so Opiumkriege und alles, was danach folgte.
Und wenn du heute in China gehst, werden sie dir sehr klar sagen, sie haben keine Wille, das wieder zu verhören. Sie wollen in Asien das dominantste Staat sein. Und ich verpasse die Chinesen nicht. Ich möchte das stärkste Staat in Asien sein.
Da sind wir also wieder in diesem Dreieck. Jetzt hören wir noch mal als Kontrast Frank Nowak.
Irgendwann einmal hoffe ich, dass die Menschen und die Politikerinnen klug genug sind, zu sagen, wir brauchen keinen dritten Weltkrieg, weil der wird höchstwahrscheinlich ein Atomarer sein. Das heißt, wir müssen vor heute Notbremse ziehen. Und daher die UNO nicht näher finden. Die UNO ist im Prinzip eine sehr, sehr gute Organisation. Sie hat nur gewisse Geburtsschwierigkeiten, die damals halt notwendig waren, um sie zu schaffen, aber die man mit einem Willen zur Reform auch durchaus reformieren kann.
Die Frage ist jetzt, ob hier Klugheit der richtige Begriff ist, beziehungsweise kommt man mit Klugheit weiter? Wenn wir sehen, es gibt taktisches Kalkül. Eigentlich geht es nur darum, wie dieses Dreieck zueinander steht und dann all die Akteure in den Ebenen darunter. Und da ist also die Frage der Klugheit sicherlich eine im Sinne von, ja, es ist klug, dass es keinen dritten Weltkrieg gibt. Aber diese Logik, die Mörschheimer da aufzeichnet, bedeutet natürlich auch, dass also das Eskalationspotenzial wächst. Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, die Aufrüstung wächst, du hast es zwar vorgerechnet, aber schnell kann es eine Schamütze geben und das kann sich dann auf was ausweiten. Und ökonomisch vernünftig waren Kriege ja in der Vergangenheit auch nicht. Und trotzdem hat man sie dann Kriege geführt, die ruinös waren. Und wenn man jetzt auch nochmal überlegt...
Ja, also das sagst du jetzt so. Aber so wie er jetzt sagt, die Klugheit, es wäre doch wünschenswert, wenn die Leute klug sind und sich darüber verständigen, keinen dritten Weltkrieg zu haben. Also ich finde, realistisch gesehen, wir haben gerade keinen dritten Weltkrieg. Also scheint es irgendwo diese kluge Verständigung gerade zu geben. Da bist du ja auch wieder so im Normativitätsparadox drin, dass so die ganze Zeit so ein, ja, wir hatten das ja immer wieder, das Präventionsparadox hier. Jetzt wünscht er sich keinen dritten Weltkrieg und sagt, wir bräuchten dafür kluge Leute. Und ich sage aber rückwärts gedacht heißt das ja, wir haben gerade keinen dritten Weltkrieg, also sind wir ganz schön klug und so. Und das sind schwere Diskussionen.
Er würde sagen, naja, also wir haben keinen dritten Weltkrieg, aber er könnte jeden Tag kommen und das bedeutet...
Das musst du immer sagen können.
Genau, und das würde er aber sagen, das kann man aushebeln, dass man immer in dieser Gefahr schwebt, wenn man eine übergeordnete Instanz etabliert. Das heißt, man würde die Souveränität der Weltmächte und dann auch der anderen Staaten einschränken. Die würden etwas abgeben. Also wir haben ja... Also wir können ja Dinge zum Beispiel in Deutschland nicht mehr selbst entscheiden, weil wir das an Europa delegiert haben. Es sind nicht so viele Sachen, am Ende sind doch die nationalen Staaten wieder sehr entscheidend. Aber so ein paar Sachen gibt es. So und diese... Jetzt gibt es aber nicht noch mal eine übergeordnete Instanz. Und damit könnte man natürlich, hätte man eine solche Weltpolizei oder so. Und das ist ja auch so eine Idee von internationalen Strafgerichtshof und all das. Wenn man dies hätte und das wäre auch so, dass die was durchsetzen könnten, dann würde man ja gar nicht jetzt warten, darauf kommt irgendein Präsident zu Besuch, den man dann verhaften müsste. Sondern man würde jemanden losschicken und sagen, der muss verhaftet werden. In Deutschland kann man das, wenn du jetzt irgendwas klaust, dann wirst du verhaftet. Da sagt man nicht, oh, da muss man mal gucken, wenn Herr Schulz das nächste Mal verreist nach Frankreich, dann können wir ihn verhaften. Und diesen Punkt zu machen, zu sagen, also da hofft man auf Klugheit, ist aber, finde ich, sehr schön, aber sehr illusorisch. Weil wenn ich die Realisten ernst nehme, ich dieses Dreieck mir angucke und niemand wird von denen bereit sein, Macht abzugeben an eine höhere Instanz. Wo ja auch die Frage ist, wer ist denn diese höhere Instanz? Dann wird die gewählt, wird die ernannt.
Ja, wer ist diese höhere Instanz? Ich versuche jetzt mal einen ganz abwegigen Argumentationsversuch. Also die Heuristik ist ein bisschen durchgeknallt, aber und ich werde sie über Bande spielen. Ich habe gestern wieder diese Reportagen geguckt, die gucke ich immer mal gerne, wie Hans Zimmer Filmmusik macht. Und es gaben dann Beispiele, wie klingen Filme, die im Weltraum spielen? Star Trek, Star Wars und so weiter. Es sitzt ein Beethoven-Orchester da und spielt irgendwas durch. Melodien kennt man ja. Vier Viertel Takt, was auch immer. Wie gehabt. Dann kriegt Hans Zimmer diese Aufträge mit Christopher Nolan und so weiter Musik zu machen. Und Christopher Nolan schreibt noch so rein in das Skript selber, wie das klingen soll. Inception zum Beispiel. Also Bläser. Aber irgendwie mehr als Bläser. Ich möchte gerne diesen Rhythmus der Zeit und so weiter über Akustik darstellen in dem Film. Also ich bin ein Regisseur, ich kümmere mich ums Bild, schreibe aber Anweisungen, wie es klingen soll mit rein. Das ist ja schon mal abwegig. Also so wie wir jetzt auch bei politischen Diskussionen. Okay, ich bin Politiker, ich bin Politikberater, ich bin irgendein Nachdenker, ich hab's mit Politikern zu tun. Politiker sind Menschen, Menschen ordnen sich in Hierarchien. Bei Staaten hört's auf, was kommt denn als nächstes? Als höhere Instanz. Und dann sagt Hans Zimmer, wir können ja mal jenseits des Menschen denken. Oder gerade den Menschen mal ins Zentrum setzen, aber irgendwie anders. Und dann hat er Dune bekommen und bei Inception war halt noch klar, okay, dann nehmen wir einfach Bläser und dann machen wir so ein Flügel auf und dann hauen die aber ihr Gebläse so krass auf die Seiten des Flügels, dass einfach dieses Klavier, das gar nicht gespielt wird, sondern einfach nur als Resonanzraum und dann hat man so einen anderen Sound. Und plötzlich hört man den über Jahrzehnte in allen Trailern, über all diesen Getute und so. So, und dann bekommt er Dune und fragt sich, okay, was mach ich jetzt hier? Das ist ein Universum, in dem gibt es verschiedene Fraktionen, Familien, wie auch immer, aber es sind alles Menschen. Was eint diese Menschen? Na ja, im Grunde gar nichts mehr. Die sind vor Jahrtausenden, wurden die ausdifferenziert, haben sich angepasst usw. Eigentlich eint die gar nichts mehr. Und dann sagt sich Hans Zimmer, okay, um diese Idee jetzt in die Gegenwart zu holen, in einen Film, sage ich, okay, alle Geräusche, die wir hören, kommen von Menschen. Aber es gibt keinen Rhythmus mehr. Nichts für den Vierteltakt. Es gibt keinen Beethoven-Orchester mehr. Keine Streicher, die ganze Kram. Wir gehen in den Baumarkt, wir holen uns Sachen, wir pusten irgendwo rein und nehmen den Equalizer und machen da irgendwas mit und so. Also der Mensch ist sozusagen omnipräsent, aber er kennt sich nicht wieder. Er hört diesen Film und fragt sich, was für ein Instrument das ist. Er sagt, das ist eine menschliche Stimme. Aber ich hab die halt so viel mit Kompressor und zerhackt und hier und da und hall und so. Also der Mensch ist im Mittelpunkt, aber er erkennt sich nicht wieder. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, bei dieser höheren Instanz, die man hier braucht und die sich alle wünschen, also Nowak sitzt da und sagt, ich wünsche mir hier jemanden, der das Zepter in der Hand, und dann kommt der Mörscheimer und sagt, die UN und irgendwas und der Richter hier, der Generalsekretär da. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, soziologisch ist es doch, wir können uns doch jetzt mal diesen Hans Zimmerwege gehen und sagen, wir setzen den Mensch in den Mittelpunkt. Der Mensch hat einen Körper, der hat Bedürfnisse, der möchte gerne Gewalt vermeiden, er möchte Hunger vermeiden, ganz viele Sachen. So und die abstrahieren wir jetzt raus. Und jetzt denken wir nicht mal, also wir denken jetzt einfach nicht weiter in diese Politikrichtung. Sondern Wirtschaft. Die höhere Instanz ist eine Markt-Blogik, auf die sich alle einigen. Der kleine Farmer in Minnesota, der gerade in die Großstadt umgezogene, 400 Kilometer von seinen Eltern weggezogene, junge Chinese, der ja irgendwie auf drei Quadratmetern und so weiter lebt, so die eint alle ein was. Und das kann man durchaus als eine höhere Instanz sehen, die, und ich hab das ja auch versucht bei der Alten Republik zu sagen, die Demografie selbst ist der politische Akteur. Nicht die Politiker, die mal zur Demografie was machen, sondern die Demografie selbst. So, und hier ist es einfach die wirtschaftliche Logik. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen Klugheit, nun ja, es ist nicht besonders klug, wie wir Wirtschaft organisieren. Also da fällt ganz schön viel ab, wo wir sagen, das ist so doof, aber wir verstehen doch eins, dass es nach Profit-Logik funktioniert. So, also Amerika macht jetzt Zölle auf chinesische Autos, die das Klima schützen. Das Problem der Welt ist gerade zu viel klimaschützende Autos. Kann man sich das vorstellen?
Klimaschädliche Autos.
Nein, das Problem ist gerade zu viele klimafreundliche Autos.
Nein, das ist das Problem nicht für die Welt, sondern für Amerika.
Ja genau, aber es ist doch irre, dass wir die ganze Zeit in Deutschland eine Investition nach der anderen, damit irgendeine Uni und irgendwie da und überall Klimaschutz, Klimaschutz, Klimaschutz, aber das Problem ist eigentlich, wir haben zu viele klimaschützende Autos im Vergleich zu den Autos, die wir vorher haben, nur wir können sie auf diesem Markt nicht zulassen. Das ist politisch ganz dumm. Wirtschaftlich ist das total erklärbar. Wir kennen diese Rationalität, wir wissen, der amerikanische Präsident möchte gerne seine Leute in Brot und Lohn haben und so weiter. Deswegen wird das organisiert, wie es organisiert wird.
Ich würde es genau umdrehen. Ich würde es genau umdrehen und sagen, politisch ist das total klug, im Sinne des Dreiecks gedacht. Wirtschaftlich ist es total dumm.
Ja, weil es viel kostet und so. Ja, aber mir geht es ja nicht. Also die Vorzeichen kann man drehen, wie man will, ich will nur sagen.
Weil du hast eigentlich jetzt doch die beste Grundlage gelegt. Also eigentlich müsste es, ich hatte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, und jetzt kommt dein großes Plädoyer für den Freihandel. Und ich wäre gebildet gewesen, heute damit einzustimmen. Denn ich würde schon sagen, also bei allem, was die Globalisierung auch am falschen gebracht hat, ist eigentlich diese Art der Vernetzung, die über Wirtschaft stattfindet, und wo es tatsächlich um Profitloge geht, immerhin noch eine Möglichkeit, dass man nicht kriegerisch tätig ist. Es gibt Leute, die jetzt gerade sagen, man sieht jetzt gerade, wie der Kapitalismus dazu führt, dass wir in den nächsten Krieg reinschüttern. Und ja, natürlich gibt es Partikularinteressen. Rheinmetall wurde heute schon erwähnt, die sehr befriedigt werden dadurch, dass man jetzt aufrüstet. Aber wenn wir uns jetzt mal ansehen, was man gerade tut, dann ist es ja eine politische Ideologie, über die ökonomische Logik zu stellen. Es ist für die deutsche Autoindustrie wichtig, mit China zusammenzuarbeiten. Für BASF ist China wichtig. Die Außenministerin sagt, sie ist ein Diktator. Bei BASF sind die dann stinksauer. Biden sagt, China ist unser Problem. Apple funktioniert nur dank China. Das heißt, wir haben die ganze Zeit eigentlich eine politische Ideologie, die die ökonomische, realistische Logik torpediert. Von daher würde ich auch sagen, noch mal ganz stark auf das Ökonomische zu gehen, dann ist nicht Ungleichheit und alles besiegt. Also da sind noch mal ganz andere Themen. Aber ich würde deutlich machen, dass wir momentan bei all den Dingen, die wir erleben in Bezug auf Rekrut-Aufrüstung, sehen, dass sich das Politische über das Ökonomische stellt und damit das Nationalstaatliche über das Ökonomische. Weshalb auch viele jetzt, die den Neoliberalismus so lange kritisiert haben, die die Globalisierung kritisiert haben, gerade einen Fehlschluss machen, wie schon bei Corona, dass sie sagen, endlich wieder Staat. Endlich nicht die Konzerne, sondern jetzt entscheidet der Staat über Investitionen. Und dann geht das bis hin zu Ulrike Hermanns Kriegswirtschaft.
Also ich weiß, wie du das denkst. Und ja, also es wäre jetzt logisch gewesen, dass ich direkt anschließe mit, dann lassen wir doch die Ökonomie gewähren, so wie wir auch festgestellt haben beim Klimaschutz. Ganz schön lange hat das unter politischen Doktrinen gar nicht funktioniert, aber jetzt war einfach ein Marktmechanismus, der sagt, Solaranlagen, vier Cent die Kilowattstunde, ist es vorbei mit der Kohle, weil es sich einfach nicht mehr rechnet. Aber, und jetzt kommen wir ja in diese brenzliche Lage, warum man hier so viel Denkarbeit dieser strukturellen Realisten braucht. Diese Arbeitsteilung, die daraus folgt, dass man sagt, okay, dann kommt unser medizinisches Zeug einfach nur noch aus China, greift ja nur so lange, bis wir ein medizinisches Problem haben. Und dann sind plötzlich zu wenig Masken da und wir haben keine eigene Produktion. Und dann fällt man zurück in diese, wir brauchen die Hierarchie, wir können es nur innerstaatlich organisieren, weil zwischenstaatlich werden dann irgendwelche LKWs aufgehalten, wie auch immer, da haben wir ja keine Handhabe, weil die Polizeiarbeit endet halt an den deutschen Grenzen. So und Christian Kern hat ja damals dieses Wort geprägt von Freihandelsverträgen neuer Typs, die also nicht nur regeln, was an der Grenze passiert, sondern auch was in Konfliktfällen passiert. Wir haben dann diese CETA-Diskussion, aber die haben da so ein Schiedsgericht, das passt gar nicht in unsere Hierarchie, also das passt gar nicht in unsere Denkgewohnheit. Natürlich immer mit diesem politischen, würde ich sagen, noch mehr historischen Problem, dass die Leute, die diese Freihandels-Schiedsgerichte dann konzipieren, natürlich erst mal komplett partikularistische Interessen da reinschreiben, obwohl die Idee ja genau richtig ist. Eine WHO, eine Welthandelsorganisation und so weiter und so fort. Also in der Ansicht, ja, das Plädoyer für Freihandel liegt dann auf der Hand.
Ist ja WHO.
Zum Beispiel, genau. Aber man müsste es halt wieder verknüpfen mit so Notfallmechanismen, Konfliktlösungen. Eigentlich würde man über längere sich dann doch die staatliche Regie wieder nachbauen. So wäre die Europäische Union sich Schritt für Schritt, jetzt haben wir uns in der Europawahl, bei der alle so das Gefühl haben, die ist schon irgendwie wichtig. Gestartet ist das vor 40 Jahren als Redeparlament. Da sind deutsche Bundestagsabgeordnete nach Brüssel gefahren und haben halt mal geredet. So, und dann sind sie wieder nach Hause gefahren. Irgendwann sind die dauerhaft da geblieben, dann haben die da eigene Rechte bekommen, dürfen jetzt plötzlich die EU-Kommission mit einem Veto einfach nicht bestellen und solche, solche Sachen. Also man hätte über die Ökonomie nach Wehend dann doch wieder so eine Etablierung von Hierarchie. Deswegen würde ich sagen, ne, es ist eben nicht so dieser reine Freihandel, aber der Tür, der den Freihandel, der ist überall derselbe, den erkennen wir überall wieder. Und den kann man ruhig mal als politischen Akteur, auch wenn er keine Person ist mit einem Namen und so weiter, aber der auf dem Markt tätige und zwar kognitiv lernende, wirtschaftliche Akteur ist tatsächlich einer, der gerade ganz schön viel strukturiert, ganz schön viele Erwartungen orientiert.
Nur, ist es am Ende, so zumindest jetzt, der Staat oder sind es die Staaten, die entscheiden, darüber was gemacht wird? Und solange man in dieser Logik ist, ist man natürlich in einer Logik der Aufrüstung der Eskalation, ist man auch in einer Logik von Eroberung, nicht im Sinne von Hauptsache ganz viel Land gewinnen, das ist ja ein ganz anderes Konzept noch gewesen, aber welche Strategie verfolgt man mit einer kleineren Eroberung? Jetzt haben wir eben von Mörscher einmal gehört, naja, der Putin hat jetzt gar nicht darauf angehakt, die gesamte Ukraine zu bekommen, aber doch einige Teile sind für ihn strategisch wichtig. Er will da so eine Pufferzone haben. Und jetzt hören wir mal nochmal unsere Chinarexpertin, was sie sagt zu China und den Begehrlichkeiten hin zu Taiwan.
Taiwan ist eine ganz kleine Insel und an der Südseite dieser Insel gibt es lauter Tiefseehäfen. Diese Tiefseehäfen braucht die Volksrepublik China, um von dort aus, ohne dass die Satelliten das sofort bemerken, die U-Boote auslaufen zu lassen, die man braucht, um so ein riesiges Meer beherrschen zu können. Das ist das strategische Interesse.
Es ist die offensichtliche und letzte Frage dann, warum bauen sie dann keine eigenen Tiefseehäfen?
Ja, weil das geht aus rein geologischen Gründen nicht. Weil die Landmasse, auf der die Volksrepublik China sitzt, ist eine Landmasse, die ganz langsam ins Meer reingleitet. Und da kann man nicht einfach eine kleine Bombe hinlegen und sagen, okay, jetzt machen wir mal die Landmasse kaputt, damit wir da einen Tiefseehaufen haben. Es geht leider nicht. Tiefseehaufen hat man da, wo die Natur es einem gibt.
Geografie ist hier Schicksal. Das finde ich einen sehr interessanten Gedanken, weil wir so viel über die Chip-Verbrecken sprechen. Aber diese Perspektive nochmal. Und jetzt können wir mal so weit gehen und sagen, wir lassen uns mal von Mörscher mal erklären, wie ist das mit Putin und ist er dann rational oder irrational? Aber es gab Argumente dafür.
Er hat über diese Idee der großen Russischen Empire geschrieben, dass Ukraine als Staat nie existierte. Es gab dieses Artikel, das er ein halbes Jahr bevor er in die Russlandung entgegengeblieben hat, das ein Imperialistisches Programm aufgeteilt hat.
Im Endeffekt sagt das Artikel genau das Gegenteil.
Ja, also er geht es um bei zu sagen, im Prinzip ist das an den Haaren herbeigezogen. Ich hab mir daraufhin nochmal so ein paar Ausschnitte aus dem Tucker Carlson-Video angeguckt und hatte so bei mir gedacht, kann das sein, dass Putin einfach Tucker Carlson so anderthalb Stunden lang verarscht? Also dass der da einfach sitzt und dem da irgendwas entrollt und diese 1700 war das so und 1900 so. Also dass man dann so denkt, ja, der erzählt ihm da irgendwas, aber eigentlich hätte, eigentlich müsste Putin sagen, ja wissen Sie, es gibt ja dieses Dreieck und es gibt ja da Puffer-Zonen und so. Also eigentlich müsste er so mit ihm darüber reden und erzählt ihm dann irgendwas von der großen russischen Historie.
Oder wir folgen Christoph Heuskrim, der eben sagt, nee, der hat sich wirklich so radikalisiert. Der glaubt diese Geschichte.
Gut, das wäre dann so eine, wer weiß. Ich hab ja eher so eine Madman-Theorie jetzt hier. Das ist ja so spieltheoretisch. Der spielt halt für Tucker Carlson mit Verrückten. Und alle im Westen sehen das und sagen, ja, der ist aber wirklich verrückt.
Aber da gibt's, also, da ist halt wirklich große Unlogikkeiten drin.
Naja, diese Mörscher-Argumentation ist ja zu sagen, Putin fühlt sich da bedroht, ob er das dann ist oder nicht. Spielt ja gar keine Rolle, fühlt sich bedroht. Von der NATO-Osterweiterung. Er will da eine Pufferzone haben. Das ist der Grund, warum der das gemacht hat.
Ja, ich denke mir jetzt, also gerade bei dieser Frage, ist Putin jetzt rational oder nicht? Wie sieht so Gremium aus, dass so zu Fragen kommt? Jetzt ist Christoph Heusgens Meinung, der hat sich da radikalisiert durch Vereinsamung in so einem kleinen Kreis. Das haben wir ja im Westen spürbar nicht. Und so wie wir jetzt schon oder ich versucht hab, okay, vielleicht geht es nicht immer nur um die Politiker. Wie sähe es jetzt mal dieses wirtschaftliche Argument runtergebrochen auf, wenn wir sagen, okay, bei G7 sitzen immer auch die wichtigen CEOs mit. So, und das prägt ja auch. Also vielleicht ist nicht immer nur alles Politik, sondern so wie du jetzt sagst, Geologie ist Schicksal. Also auch ein prächtiger Akteur, welcher Wissenschaftler da was so sagt, welches Gebiet sich wie eignet und so. Und ja, vielleicht sollte man auch die Wirtschaft, also nicht nur die Staaten, sondern jetzt auch die Nationen mal in so einen strukturellen Realismus, es ist ja kein politischer Realismus, ein struktureller Realismus, der sollte ja durchaus offen sein für die Realität, dass ganz schön viele Wirtschaftsbosse auch mit in der politischen Arena sind. Was hätten die eigentlich Putin gesagt? Also, dass es keinen Krieg zwischen China und Amerika gibt, das scheint ja sehr viel von, ja, ja, also man sieht sich das halt an und sagt, 30 Milliarden extra für Soja-Bohnen, also das macht jetzt gar keinen Sinn. Das ist uns hier zu teuer, lieber Xi. Mach's mal wieder vernünftiger. Jetzt bei dem Ukraine-Überfall würde ich sagen, ja, da fehlt vielleicht der ein oder andere Konzernlenker mit im Raum, der Putin das noch mal ausgeredet hat.
Möglich, ja. Jedenfalls war Mörschheimer dafür, dass die Ukraine die Atombombe behält in den 90ern. Nun hat die Ukraine keine Atomwaffen mehr.
Ich weiß auch nicht, war nicht die Erklärung auch, das sind russische Atomwaffen, mit denen der Ukraine gar nichts anfangen kann, sondern das ist mehr so ein nukleare Teilhabe, ohne dass da noch jemand teil hat, sondern die lagern da einfach nur.
Na also wie ich das jetzt so...
Hätten die die selber irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich schon....
im Sinne von ich schieß die morgen ab und so.
Da fragst du mich jetzt nach Details, aber ich hatte das eher so verstanden, dass die schon möglich waren. Wir hören jetzt noch mal Weige den Schwiezig, die beschreibt noch mal jetzt, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man dieses Dreieck hat. Das will nicht direkt in einen Krieg gehen. Jetzt hat man eine Ukraine, die hat keine Atommacht mehr, aber ist da in einer besonderen Lage zwischen dem Westen und Russland.
Innerhalb des strategischen Dreiecks Russland, China, USA gibt es bisher, ich sage ausdrücklich bisher, eine Grundregel. Wir gehen nicht gegeneinander in den Krieg. Warum? Weil alles drei Nuklearmächte sind. Und weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn die gegeneinander in den Krieg gehen, sie auch Nuklearmächtige, Waffen einsetzen, leider sehr groß ist. Deshalb sind sie brav in der Hinsicht, dass sie sagen, also ging einander nicht. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass sie ja nicht ständig in Konkurrenz zueinander stehen. Und das bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass sie sich Territorien suchen, auf denen der Krieg stattfindet, aber immer nur einer von den drei Mächten involviert ist direkt. Siehe Ukraine. Ja, also Ukraine ist bedauerlicherweise das Territorium, auf dem dieser Krieg stattfindet, weil wir sehen, solche Kriege sind schreckliche.
Und jetzt wird wahrscheinlich mancher sagen, ja, aber die ukrainische Bevölkerung, die tendiert doch auch noch Europa. Und Detjen fragt dann auch Mörscheimer, ob er das dann völlig ignoriert. Seine Antwort darauf?
Die Ukrainer klagten, nein, wir wollten NATO beteiligen. Wir wollten ein Teil der westlichen Welt der Europäischen Union werden.
Das ist ein Teil unserer Selbstdetermination.
Und das ist ein Teil einer internationalen, regler-basierten Ordnung, die sich vor Selbstdetermination von Staaten schützt.
Du kannst das Argument machen, aber das ist ein witziges Argument. Die USA hat die Monroe-Doktrin.
Kuba zum Beispiel, immer noch Mittelalter.
Das ist etwas, was er erwähnt, und er sagt auch Folgendes.
Das Endeffekt der NATO-Empfangung in die Ukraine ist, dass die Ukraine als Staat zerstört wird.
Jetzt klingt das alles so, als sei ihm eigentlich die Ukraine egal. Er steigt dann auch ein Deal vor, wir hören uns das auch noch an.
Und in der Rückkehr werden die Russen die meisten der Territory, wenn nicht alle der Territory, beinhalten. Das wäre der Deal. Wird jemand in der Ukraine oder in den USA oder in Europa das Deal beantworten? Es ist alles ein Wast der Zeit.
Und wir sehen, dass der Krieg weitergeht. Viele tausende Menschen sterben weiterhin. Und das klingt jetzt so, als sei er fast zynisch. Und jetzt kommt aber so eine interessante Wendung am Ende dieses Gesprächs, dass er, nachdem er jetzt diesen Deal davor gestanden hat, und damit sind sicherlich viele in der Ukraine nicht glücklich, wenn es so käme. Andererseits könnte damit der Krieg aufhören. Das ist ja auch eine Abwägung, die da zu treffen ist, dass er sagt, jetzt muss ich als der Realist auf die Moral zurückgreifen.
Das klingt komisch, wenn es von einem Realisten kommt, aber es gibt eine wichtige moralische Dimension zu meinem Argument hier. Aber wie ich dir vorhin gesagt habe, ich glaube nicht, dass jeder mich hören wird. Ich denke, wir werden die Kampf weiterführen.
Es wäre jetzt eigentlich ein moralisches Gebot, das jetzt zu machen, weil man von westlicher Seite gern verkündet hat, ihr werdet mit unserer Hilfe diesen Krieg gewinnen. Das findet jetzt so nicht statt. Das haben viele schon früher gesagt, dass das so nicht stattfinden wird. Und jetzt hat man da natürlich sehr viele Leute dazu gebracht, zu kämpfen, weil sie glaubten, dass sie diesen Wort trauen können. Und jetzt steht man vor diesem Dilemma. Viele sind tot. Und jetzt wird es eigentlich eine moralische Verpflichtung, da was halbwegs gescheit ist, noch hinzubekommen. Und das ist schon so fatal, wenn man das hört, und auch so traurig.
Ja, aber ich verstehe nicht genau, wo er da… Also das kommt ja wirklich aus heiterem Himmel. Wenn ich höre, der strukturelle Realismus als Paradigma für sein Denken. Warum ist dann jetzt plötzlich wieder Moral?
Also den Menschen gegenüber. Also ich glaube, dass er nicht den strukturellen Realismus richtig verstanden hat. Aber dann schaut er ohne diese ganzen normativen und metaphysischen Konzepte auf die Konstellation, in der sich Staaten befinden. Aber der strukturelle Realist hat auch eine Sicht auf die Menschen. Und ich glaube, dass viele strukturelle Realisten sehr stark auch davon geprägt sind, dass sie sagen, wir müssen Leid verhindern. Und können das vielleicht auch besser tun, weil wir von diesen ganzen normativen Dingen absehen. Also wenn wir natürlich sagen, die Demokratie Europas steht und fällt, damit ob die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnt oder nicht, dann muss ich das Leid der einzelnen Menschen, die dort sterben, hinten anstellen, weil ich sage, dies ist das höhere Prinzip. Wenn ich aber gar nicht normativ, wie das ja die Realisten machen, wenn ich da gar nicht normativ reingehe und als Realist sage, wie sind die Konstellationen, aber ich will das Leid verhindern, dann habe ich diesen metaphysischen Überbau nicht und kann vielleicht zu schnelleren Deals gelangen. Die mögen nicht einem Idealismus verpflichtet sein, aber die werden dem Gedanken der Leidverhinderung verpflichtet sein. Ich glaube, das ist eine grundsätzliche Moral, die man schon so artikulieren kann.
Also Moral gibt es ja nicht mehr im Singular. Das ist ja eins der größten Probleme und du hast ja den Witz schon gemacht mit selektiven Universalismus.
Aber wir sind uns ja, ich glaube, es gibt ja schon auch die universelle Moral, dass man sagt, Menschen sollen nicht leiden. Wir wollen das Leid von Menschen...
Ja, aber die teilt ja Putin nicht. Der erholt sich ja irgendwelche Innen da, die er irgendwie rekrutieren lässt und die da verfeuert werden. Dem ist das ja egal.
Putin ja, aber dem...
Na ja, auch einem ganz großen Teil des Apparates. Sonst wäre das ja gar nicht möglich.
Ja, natürlich, aber das ist ja... Aber Mersheim macht Vorwurf, ist ja hier ziemlich explizit, dass er sagt, dem Westen war das jetzt auch egal. Der sagt, naja, so 100.000 Ukrainer können wir für den Kampf schon opfern. Das macht ja nichts.
Und wenn ich jetzt einpreise, dass die Moral bisher egal war, kann ich nicht plötzlich ein Plädoyer machen, dass ich jetzt aber was zählen sollte, sondern für ihn zählt sie. Ja gut, für ihn.
Ich glaube, dass diese Perspektive ist ja, glaube ich, nicht nur eine, die sagt, so stehen die sich machtvoll gegenüber. Und dann sollen sie mal sehen. Sondern ich glaube, es geht ja schon darum, Schlimmeres zu vermeiden. Und das würde dann hier bedeuten, dass man sagt, also wie kann das Leid beendet werden? Und ich glaube, das ist auch so eine Perspektive. Ich weiß nicht, ob man den Oberstreisner jetzt zu den Realisten zählen kann. Er ist jedenfalls jemand, der oft ähnliche Einschätzung hat. Und für ihn ist ja immer da, dass man sagt, also entweder sagt man, das ist so das Wichtigste für uns überhaupt mit der Ukraine, dann muss man alle hingehen. Oder man sagt, nee, dann darf man den aber nicht so weiter köcheln lassen, denn das produziert unendlich Leid. Dann muss man sagen, jetzt ist Schluss mit dem Leid, dann brauchen wir irgendeinen Deal.
Ja, das Reisender dieser Frage auch...
Mark Milley ja auch, Mark Milley ist ja auch jemand, der da sehr früh schon drauf hingewiesen hat, dass man nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass das militärisch zu gewinnen ist. Zumindest nicht, wenn man so vorgeht, dann müsste man auch all in gehen. Oder man sagt jetzt, das wird ein endloser Stellungsrieg, das produziert endloses Leid, deswegen muss das jetzt verhindert werden. Und da würde ich sagen, hat man eine Moral. Und das Interessante ist, dass Mörscher das am Ende des Interviews auf die USA bezieht.
Bevor wir das hören, er hat sowohl den Deal als auch die Moral da so reingeholt. Und jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, wir haben das ja in Deutschland gar nicht geklärt. Weshalb der Reisner uns immer wieder darauf, der kommt ja mit so einem österreichischen Blick, noch mal eine andere Neutralität durch keine NATO-Mitgliedschaft und so. Und sagt dann, man muss sich da entscheiden. Also entweder geht man jetzt moralisch all in und sagt dann aber auch, koste es, was es wolle, Putin muss jetzt besiegt werden. Oder, aber man lässt es nicht köcheln. So, die amerikanische Sicht. Und ich hab dann immer wieder diesen Clip vor Augen, wie heißt der jetzt, der Minority Leader im Senat? Nee, nicht Lindsay, sondern der Alte hier.
Aber der englische Außenminister war jetzt auch in Amerika, hat das auch nochmal ähnlich formuliert. Vielleicht find ich den Clip noch mal mit, die Amerikaner sterben hier, sterben nicht in dem Krieg, er ist relativ günstig.
Ja genau, es kostet einfach 10 Milliarden im Monat, und man hat Russland da, wo man's haben will. Also weil er knallhart, nicht moralisch nachgedacht, sondern einfach ökonomisch kalkuliert.
Da ist das Leid der Ukrainer völlig egal.
Genau. Und für mich ist überhaupt nur ein in Anführungszeichen Friedensvertrag, also der die Kriegssituation ablöst, möglich, indem wirklich seitenweise aufgedröselt wird, wem jetzt was zusteht, wie was zu regeln ist und so weiter. Rasmussen hat diesen ersten Vorschlag gemacht und gesagt, also die Linien bleiben, wie sie jetzt sind. Russland anektiert diese Gebiete, dafür kann die Westukraine, und der Westukraine sind, also manchen Westukrainern ist der Osten auch egal. Es ist so ein bisschen Dirk Oschmann, es ist der Osten. Uns wäre Thüringen auch egal, wenn jetzt die Polen einmarschieren. Also so in dieser Gesichtspunkt. Dafür zieht aber die Hauptstadt, Kiew, die ganze Region, ganz West-, Mittelukraine, was auch immer, alles ohne diese Gebiete, die ziehen einfach in den Westen ein, werden in der NATO aufgenommen, EU-Mitgliedschaft vielleicht, und so weiter und so fort. Und dann wird aber richtig knallhart.
Aber hältst du das für wahrscheinlich? Also wahrscheinlich würde er genau sagen, dass das nicht kommt.
Ja, und deswegen fand ich es überraschend. Ich hätte unter den strukturellen Realisten gerade gedacht, dass die schon mal durchspielen, wie so eine Pendel-Diplomatie aussehe, bei der so ein Vertrag nach und nach wächst und dann einfach unterschrieben wird.
Ja, wir lassen es mal offen. Wir hören mal noch was Mörschheimer sagt zu seinem eigenen Land, denn er wird von Dating darauf angesprochen, dass er doch auch Sanders unterstützt hat.
Aber warum? Ich denke, es hat mit amerikanischer Domestikpolitik mehr zu tun als mit internationalen Politik. Ich denke, die USA sind in tiefen Träumen zu Hause. Ich will klar sein, dass einer der Reasons, warum ich vor dem Auslösen von Europa und den Endpunkt NATO angetreten habe, war, dass ich mit Barack Obama verabschieden habe, dass wir Nationen zu Hause bauen müssen.
Ja, und wir haben einen alten Bundespräsidenten und einen neuen Bundespräsidenten, die sagen, Deutschland muss sich mehr in der Welt engagieren. Und vielleicht sollte man auch mal über Nation Building at Home nachdenken. Du bringst uns jetzt gleich das Bauen und da muss auch vieles aufgebaut werden. Wir geben aber die letzten Worte noch Susanna Weiglin.
Ich finde das ja interessant, dass er als Realist sagt, ich habe Senders unterstützt wegen Problemen an der Heimat, zu Hause. Das ist ja wirklich diese Semmsrott-Idee. Man entscheidet über sich selbst. 10.000 Euro Monat Gehalt. Jeden Tag, den man zur Arbeit geht, gibt es ein Sitzungsgeld. Man ist unterwegs, Reisegeld. Ach, man hat eh schon eine Bankart 100, kommt nach oben drauf. Der ganze Kram. Ich brauche jemanden an meiner Seite. Hier kannst du ein Sekretariat bezahlen und so weiter und so fort. Also für sich selber geht man genau den realistischen Weg und macht sich so angenehm wie möglich. Für alle anderen nicht. Also ist jemand wie Zenders, der kommt und sagt, Leute, denkt doch mal nach. Klar müssen wir davon ausgehen, dass alle so leben möchten wie wir. Und wir können es uns leisten. Also sollten wir es auch machen, dann geht es nämlich allen besser. Und es zahlt sich als Win-Win für alle aus. So, also das liegt, finde ich, dann wieder auf der Hand. Da einfach kurz zur Besinnung zu kommen, und sagen, nee, da brauche ich auch keine Moral oder so. Sondern es ist einfach logisch, dass Regeln, die ich für mich schon gefunden habe, für alle gelten sollten. Punkt. Das ist der strukturelle Realismus in der Innenpolitik.
Richtig. Und jetzt stellt sich noch die Frage, was ist auf europäischer Ebene notwendig? Denn wir haben jetzt über China, Russland, USA geredet, aber Europa kommt da gar nicht so vor. Tilo fragt mal, wie denn Baerbock einzuschätzen ist.
Hättest du Baerbock für eine gute Diplomatin?
Muss ich die Frage beantworten?
Ich hab sie dir gestellt.
Und sie führt das jetzt aus, denn Baerbock sagt, sie ist ein Diktator, und das sagt sie ja auch, Weiglin Schwiezig.
Nein, sie hat nichts. Ich sage das übrigens auch. Aber ich bin eine Wissenschaftlerin und eine China-Beobachterin, und ich analysiere die Situation in China. Sie ist eine Diplomatin, sie ist die oberste Diplomatin der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und es tut mir leid, nach meiner Verständnis von Diplomatie gehört deshalb das Wort Diktatur nicht in ihr, oder Diktator, nicht in ihr Vokabular.
Auch wenn es wissenschaftlich richtig ist.
Ja, es ist eben was ganz anderes.
Ja, es sind, wie kannst du jetzt sagen, die zwei Arenen, die hier durcheinandergebracht werden, nämlich Wissenschaft und Politik. Und was bedeutet das denn jetzt eigentlich für Europa?
Während in Amerika es immer sozusagen zwei gegen einen ist, ist es in Europa eher so, dass man sagt, okay, eigentlich können wir jetzt nicht uns mit den Chinesen gegen die Russen verbinden. Wir können uns nicht mit den Amerikanern gegen die Chinesen und die Russen verbinden. Und wir können uns auch nicht mit den Russen gegen die Chinesen verbinden. Sondern wir haben so eine Position im System der internationalen Beziehung, das eigentlich verlangt, dass wir uns mit allen dreien ins Benehmen setzen.
Ja, das ist aber nicht nur ein außenpolitisches Problem in Europa, sondern wir haben jetzt eine Europawahl. Und niemand kann die Frage antworten, mit wem muss ich mich jetzt eigentlich wie verbünden, damit der und der irgendeinen Posten bekommt. Das ist unterschaubar. Das sind irgendwelche anderen Regeln, die da gelten. In deren Sicht, sehr gut. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt alle so ein bisschen strukturelle Realisten, oder?
Vielleicht. Wir sind gespannt, was prächt uns dazu zu sagen. Vielleicht gibt es noch mal eine andere Perspektive. Er sagt Werte geleitet. Das klingt schon nach doch etwas anderem.
Wir lassen das Tor offen, doch noch mal die Wertegeleitetheit berechtigtermaßen zuzulassen. Je nach Argumentationslage entscheiden wir das dann nächste Woche. Ein Thema, das uns alle eint. Du wohnst, ich wohne. Meine Oma wohnt, mein Vater wohnt. Alle Leute, die ich nicht kenne in Deutschland, wohnen auch. Also wir sind bei einem Thema mal richtig Schicksalsgemeinschaft. Wir wohnen in allem. So und Wohnen ist aber gleichzeitig eigentlich, obwohl es so selbstverständlich ist, eins der größten Probleme, wenn nicht das Größte. Also ich weiß, sehr viele haben jetzt gerade gute Laune. Sie waren irgendwie auf der Republik, auf der OMR, da wurde irgendwie die Welt gerettet, wie auch immer. Jetzt ist Monatsende. Es ist leider, wir holen uns jetzt auf den Realitätsboden zurück. Wir sind jetzt wohnende Realisten. Es geht nicht, so wie es in Deutschland gerade ist, geht es nicht. Trotzdem will ich mit einer Positiven oder sag mal mal einer, naja, eine Heuristik, die so ein bisschen vom absoluten Abgrund abführt, beginnen. Und zwar mit Tweets von Marc Schiritz. Wir kennen ihn ja von der Zeit. Der hat sich jetzt nochmal die Rente vorgeknüpft und gesagt, es ist eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm. Und ich als Rentenexperte würde auch sagen, es stimmt irgendwie, weil seine Argumentation lautet, angenommen es würde sich alles ändern. Keine Ahnung, also alles wäre komplizierter. Er schreibt dann in dem siebten Tweet von so einem Thread, wenn sich das ändern sollte, also die Konstellation aus was auch immer, wir haben zu wenig Geld, weil zu viele Rentner, zu wenig Nachwuchs, zu wenig Zuzug, wie auch immer. Also es sind Sachen in Bewegung und sie verschärfen sich. Dann gibt es jede Menge Stellschrauben, um etwas zu ändern. Und es wird jetzt sehr düster und ich will das immer, dass das immer im Hintergrund bleibt als Wissen. Wir haben ganz viele Stellschrauben in einer 4 Billionen Euro pro Jahr Volkswirtschaft mit 20 Billionen Vermögen, da ganz viel zu ändern. Aber man müsste eben auch alles ändern. Aber man könnte, also wir haben es hier nicht mit echten, realistischen Knappheitsdiskussionen, sondern mal wieder mit Verteilungsfragen zu tun.
Also es gibt kein Schicksal wie bei China und Taiwan mit der Geografie, dass man sagt, wenn man Häfen haben will, dann muss man die da machen, sondern hier kann man sagen, wir haben verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Hierüber befindet ein Bundestag und verschiedene Landtage, die wir wählen dürfen. Wir sind nicht einer Diktatur, einer fremden Macht ausgeliefert, sondern wir sind es wirklich selbst, aber müssten es dann auch in die Hand nehmen. Na gut, wir haben ja letztes Jahr schon mal reingeschaut. Der Wohnbautag beginnt in ähnlicher Weise stimmungsvoll.
Hier ist der Wohnungsbautag mit der Pressekonferenz Jetzt live aus Berlin moderiert von Anke Plettner.
Man nimmt sich wieder Manfred Lehmann, der im Hintergrund immer diese Moderationsautomatismen liefert. Ich will nur erinnern an die Pointe. Letztes Jahr stand die. Ricarda Lange von den Grünen da und meinte, diese Stimme bräuchte ich auch mal für den Wahlkrampf, weil sie schon nicht mehr Bules Willis Filme synchronisiert hört. Irgendwann ist hier ein Generationenabriss, liebe Fernsehleute. Niemand denkt hier, das ist aber der Schirathipper Dieu, den fand ich ja damals schon nett oder so. Es ist ganz peinlich, Manfred Lehmann zu buchen für diese Aufgaben. Es gibt dann noch eine andere Veranstaltung, die ist auch ganz interessant. Das ist die Eröffnung des Wohnbautags der Pressekonferenz. Letztes Jahr haben wir die Veranstaltung mit voller Länge gehört, mit Habeck auf der Bühne. Wie er sagte, verarschen sie uns nicht, wenn sie eh nach Standards bauen, die subventioniert werden, machen sie es bitte ohne die Subventionen usw. Es gab in diesem Monat noch eine andere Veranstaltung, das Verfassungsgespräch. Das ist eine Veranstaltung, die findet direkt im Sitzungssaal des Bundesverfassungsgerichts in Karlsruhe statt. Also man sitzt vor der Richterbank, zwischen Richterbank und Kläger und Verteidigung und so. Da ist eine kleine Bühne aufgebaut. Jörg Schönborn moderiert. Er hat das Thema gleich ein bisschen anders gesetzt, nämlich nicht über Stimmlage, sondern Inhalte.
Wir haben uns ein Thema ausgewählt, das Deutschland ehrlicherweise eher teilt als verbindet. Millionen Menschen wohnen sorglos und bezahlbar in ihrem Zuhause. Millionen andere haben entweder eine Wohnung, die sie sich kaum leisten können oder sind auf der Suche, weil sie eine Familie gründen oder woanders arbeiten wollen oder überhaupt zum ersten Mal eine Wohnung suchen. Wer auf den Wohnungsmarkt stößt, für den gilt häufig die 3G-Regel. Man braucht Geduld, Glück und vor allem viel Geld.
Die 3G-Regel.
Nicht mehr geimpft, genesen, gedingst, sondern Glück, Geduld und Geld. Find ich nicht schlecht. Wir brauchen hier eine andere 3G-Politik. Gut, wir gucken vor allem auch, hauptsächlich den Wohnbautag, aber dann immer wieder dieses Verfassungsgespräch, weil da Politiker sitzen. Zum Beispiel Marco Buschmann, unser Justizministerbund, der also im Grunde die Initiativrechte zum Thema Wir verändern mal das bürgerliche Gesetzbuch, in dem geregelt wird, wie so Verträge miteinander gehandelt werden. Ich habe ja schon häufiger gesagt, Mietverträge, dass Länder und Kommunen da gar keine Handhabe haben, sondern immer auf den Bundestag warten müssen, indem die FDP alles wegvetoisiert.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Gut, erste Stimme vom Wohnbautag. Lukas Siebenkotten, Mieterbund.
Der Bedarf auf dem Wohnungsmarkt hat sich weiter erhöht. Das heißt, wir haben in diesem einem Jahr keine Fortschritte erzielt, was den notwendigen bezahlbaren zusätzlichen Wohnungsraum betrifft. Wir haben es mit erheblichen Mietsteigerungen zu tun, die mit der Verknappung des Wohnungsangebots zusammenhängen. Und wir müssen davon ausgehen, dass von den deutlich weniger Wohnungen, die gebaut werden, dann auch noch der größere Teil für Menschen ist, die viel Geld haben.
Das sind ja richtig gute Nachrichten.
Ja, das sind sehr gute Nachrichten. Und wir denken jetzt, okay, das ist ja nun der Mieterbund. Das ist also eine Einrichtung, die steht ja auf der Seite der Armen. Natürlich jammern die Romen und so weiter. Also auf der Bühne stehen nachher auch noch der Bauwirtschaft, Immobilienwirtschaft und so weiter. Noch können wir Hoffnung haben, dass die anders klingen. Statt 100.000 Sozialwohnungen nur 25.000. Das ist natürlich blöd.
Und die Bundesregierung hatte sich beispielsweise vorgenommen, pro Jahr 100.000 Sozialwohnungen an den Start zu kriegen. Und tatsächlich waren es zuletzt nur knapp 25.000.
Wie kann das denn sein? Jetzt können wir natürlich sagen, ja, da gibt es eine ökonomische Schieflage, aber das wollen wir gleich mal... Es gibt bei keinem Gut mehr Nachfrage. Also dass hier kein Angebot da ist, liegt nicht an der Nachfrage. Also nach ökonomischen Regeln müsste hier gebaut werden wie blöd. Irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Jaja, also das muss man glaube ich auch nochmal deutlich machen in Bezug auf Schuldenbremse. Es ist jetzt nicht nur eine Frage von, kann man sich so eine völlig verrückte Ausgabe leisten, sondern die Ausgabe ist nicht verrückt. Die Ausgabe rechnet sich total.
Absolut. Wir haben ganz viele Investitionen, bei denen der FDP wichtig ist, dass sie privat gemacht werden, damit die Renditen privat sind. Wenn es die Privaten nicht schaffen, darf es trotzdem nicht der Staat machen. Das ist deren Ideologie. Beim Thema Wohnen 825.000 Sozialwohnungen und von den 400.000 auch gar nicht so viel. Egal, dann wird halt nicht gebaut. Ist doch gut für die Vermieter, weil knappes Angebot, hohe Miete. Das ist die FDP-Logik.
Denn die Sozialwohnungen sind ja auch in privater Hand. Also diese Sozialwohnungen baut ja nicht der Staat, in dem Sinne, dass die Geilwitz jetzt da die Vermieterin ist.
Aber im öffentlichen Bauen sind wir ganz weit weg, wenn wir sozial bauen.
Manche verbinden das noch. Deswegen sage ich das nochmal sehr deutlich. Und da gibt es also auch viele, die damit eigentlich gutes Geld verdienen könnten.
Absolut.
Wir gucken kurz hart, aber fair. Kevin Kühne hat gefragt, warum es jetzt so wenig bezahlbaren Wohnraum gibt.
Die strukturellen Mehrheiten im Deutschen Bundestag sind so, dass die Parteien, die von einem stärkeren Mietrecht, darauf spielt das Plakat ja an, etwas halten, dass die keine gemeinsame Mehrheit haben. Egal, wie man das Blatt dreht und wendet. Und so war es in der letzten Regierung mit der Union schwierig, was fürs Mietrecht zu tun. Und jetzt haben wir die FDP vor der Brust. Ich hab selber den Bereich damals verhandelt in den Koalitionsverhandlungen. Ich weiß, was ich dort reinverhandelt habe. Konkrete Dinge, die Absenkung der Kappungsgrenze beispielsweise, in angespannten Wohnlagen, auch Verbesserungen bei Mietspiegeln. Ich weiß aber auch, dass wir einen dafür zuständigen FDP-Justizminister haben, Herrn Buschmann, von dem wir seit mittlerweile über zwei Jahren auf Gesetzentwürfe warten, für das, was seine Partei an Kompromissen unterschrieben hat. Und ich nutze auch diese Gelegenheit hier, um die Kollegen der FDP anzumahnen, vertragstreu zu sein.
So, also die Aufforderung von der Kanzlerpartei an die Vizekanzlerpartei, jetzt mach doch mal. Buschmann war ja bei diesem Verfassungsgespräch, ist ja gut für uns, da können wir ja hören, wie er sich zum Thema Wohnen, den 3 Gs äußert. Buschmann kommt mit einer ganz alten Geschichte. Ich meine, die ist schon nicht mehr aktuell, da war er selbst im Kindesalter, hat man ihm das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr als Märchen erzählt. Aber gut.
Es gab viel zu lange die Überzeugung, dass wir weniger Wohnraum brauchen, weil es Projektionen gab, auch was die Bevölkerungsentwicklung anging, die von einer schrumpfenden Bevölkerung ausging. Und deshalb haben natürlich die Planer, die sich auf diese Zahlen verlassen haben, gesagt, dass das Thema vielleicht gar nicht ist, mehr Bauland auszuweisen, sondern dass man eher über Steigerung von Lebensqualität, über Probleme bei der Versiegelung gesprochen hat.
Da stecken zwei Ausreden drin. Zum einen, mehr bauen sollten wir machen. Wir haben uns zuletzt um die Qualität des Wohnens gekümmert. Wo denn? Grundsätzlich dieses, die Demografen haben uns gesagt, Deutschland schrumpft vor 30 Jahren vielleicht. 2024 plötzlich zu sagen, ach so, ja, es sind zu viele Nachfragen in den großen Städten. Ganz überraschend, neu. Also es ist wirklich nicht neu.
Neun Jahre nach 2015 sagt er das. Und wo ja auch in den letzten Jahren dieser Entwicklung auch davor, nicht in dem Sinne abzusehen, was man sagt, naja, es wird so ein Drittel weniger, dann wird es mit dem Wohnraum klappen. Das sind ja auch nie Prognosen gewesen, die sagten, bald wird in Deutschland alles so schrumpfen, dass nur noch 60 Millionen hier leben.
Genau, du sagst jetzt 2015, das ist neun Jahre her. Das ist also das große Schicksalsjahr Einwanderung. Wir hatten jetzt in 22 nochmal ein Kriegsjahr, damals Jury, jetzt Ukraine. Ich würde sagen 2008 eine Vermögenspreisinflation, Bankenunsicherheit und so weiter. Quantitativ Easing, also dass relativ viel Geld in die Gesellschaft kommt, um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln und dann aber nicht wieder abgesogen wird über Steuern, Abgaben, wie auch immer, sondern einfach so, ach ja, der reichste Mann der Welt hat jetzt 10 Milliarden, jetzt hat er 80 Milliarden, jetzt hat er 200 Milliarden und so. Also das bläst natürlich dieses, ich brauche ein Investitionsgut, was nehme ich mir denn, was ist denn so nachgefragt? Ah ja, Häuser in der Großstadt, also werden die erstmal alle für Fremdnutzung weggekauft. So, Bushmann ist noch mehr im Märchenmodus.
Juristen verstehen ja von allem ein bisschen was, aber vom Bauen eben dann auch dann nicht so viel. Aber ich glaube, das Problem, dass wir Boden nicht vermehren können, ist ja nicht neu, aber wenn wir feststellen, dass es Urbanisierungstrends gibt, dann wachsen Städte eben vielleicht nicht in die Breite, sondern in die Höhe.
Sehr gute Idee, wir stellen die Häuser einfach aufeinander. Wir bauen einfach mehrere Häuser übereinander. Dann bleibt meine Klientel, kann dann sogar noch ein bisschen was drauflegen, so, weil der Boden und so. Jetzt sitzt ihm gegenüber ohne Scheren einer...
Also zunächst mal ist es ja eine gute Idee, in die Höhe zu bauen, da bist du ja auch sehr dafür.
Also es klingt logisch.
Aber es ist natürlich schwer machbar da, wo schon Häuser da sind. Also man kann jetzt nicht ins Frankfurter Westend...
Man kriegt noch mal ein Stockwerk drauf.
Ja, aber man kann nicht ins Frankfurter Westend gehen und sagen, wir verdreifachen jetzt mal die Höhe. Das kann man nur, wenn man erst abreißt und dann neu baut.
Ja, und man muss auch sagen, wenn er vorher so viel Wert drauf legte, dass man ja ganz viel für die Qualität des Wohnens gemacht hat, dann nützt es einem wenig, im 37. Stock zu wohnen mit drei Nachbarn auf Augenhöhe und den Rest kriegt man gar nicht mit. Man kriegt das Fenster nicht auf, weil da oben das gar nicht ermöglicht wurde, dass man da nochmal ein Fenster kippt. Niemand hat einen Garten und so, und alle leben nur noch in irgendwelchen Wohntüren.
Ja, beziehungsweise man könnte es ja als Anreiz nehmen und sagen, dann muss irgendwo Flächenversiegelung noch mal in größerem Stil stattfinden, also dass man einen neuen Bezirk hier in Frankfurt beispielsweise eröffnet. Und dort müsste dann in die Höhe gebaut werden und dann aber mit Qualitätsstandards, die es einem auch ermöglichen, dass man oben gut leben kann. Das gibt ja Städte, in denen Leute sehr, sehr hoch leben und jetzt nicht unglücklich darüber sind.
Ja, es gibt in Frankfurt natürlich auch Wohntürme, nur die zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass sie nicht mehr in Millionen, sondern in Milliarden Euro wertgerechnet werden. Also billiger wird es nicht pro Wohneinheit, nur weil die Wohnung jetzt im 37.
Stock ist.
Ole Scheren sitzt ihm gegenüber, ein recht junger und wohl weltweit gefeierter Architekt, der sich seine Projekte so ein bisschen aussuchen und selbst gestalten kann. Er schildert Erfahrungen aus Singapur und wir hören mal, was ihm besonders wichtig ist, Marco Buschmann zu sagen.
Wie könnte man anders wohnen? Und das war eben ein Thema, das mich dort in Singapur besonders interessiert hatte. Das war eben ein Projekt, da ging es darum, 1.030 Wohneinheiten zu bauen in einer ziemlich hohen Verdichtung und dann eben ein Modell zu entwickeln, das ganz anders war als das, was dort war. Dort wurden eigentlich immer Türme gebaut und ich habe dann eine Struktur entwickelt, die komplett horizontal ineinander verflochten ist, in denen offene Räume entstehen, große Gärten und in denen es eben nicht nur den Privatraum gibt, sondern auch den Gemeinschaftsraum und eine große Staffelung der Räume dazwischen. Also ein Gedanke von Freiheit, den man mit umsetzt in einer räumlichen Struktur, in den Menschen auch entscheiden können. Sind sie viel zu Hause, sind sie miteinander und damit der Wohnung selbst oder der Zelle der Wohnung, wenn man so will, eine ganz andere Wichtigkeit geben, weil man sie in einem größeren Kontext schafft. Und ich glaube, darin können andere Ansätze liegen.
So etwas möchte natürlich Marco Buschmann nicht haben.
Das ist ja gegen jede Logik.
Denn die FDP möchte die Verkapselung der einzelnen Individuen, die dann sagen …Gemeinschaftsräume, weißte? Nur die FDP kann mir diese Verkapselung sicherstellen. Und alles, was der da vorschlägt, ist für Buschmann wahrscheinlich schon blanker Sozialismus.
Buschmanns Idee ist, du wohnst im 37.
Stock.
Du trittst aus deiner Wohnung in einen 5-Quadratmeter-Gemeinschaftstreppenhaus. Steigst in den Fahrstuhl, fährst direkt bis in die Tiefgarage.
Steigst in dein privates Auto, fährst durch die Stadt.
Diese Idee von, ich komme aus der Tür und sehe erstmal ein bisschen Weite, Menschen, Gemeinschaft, ist nicht. Also er war hier, nee, da hat man eigentlich Wohntürme gebaut, lernt davon, macht das jetzt nicht.
Nee, also wenn er in die Höhe, er denkt jetzt an diese Luxushäuser mit Concierge-Dienst da unten, wo man den Concierge vielleicht noch mit Namen kennt und sonst weiß man überhaupt nicht, wer da mit einem lebt.
So, zurück zum Wohnbautag, nachdem wir jetzt den Mieterbund hatten, der schon gesagt hat, schlimm, letztes Jahr war schon schlimm, jetzt ist es auch schlimm. Katharina Metzger, Verbandschefin Baustoff-Fachhandel.
Frau Metzger, wir hören, der Bedarf ist klar da, aber wie stellt sich das denn auch für die Baubranche an sich da, also für die Prozesskette, Sie sprechen ja für den Baustoff-Fachhandel. Im letzten Jahr war viel davon die Rede, dass man den Kipppunkt befürchtet, dass es dann noch schlechter wird. Wo stehen wir jetzt?
Ja, wir stehen jetzt in einer Situation, wo der Kipppunkt stattgefunden hat. Wir sind nach dem Kipppunkt. Die Situation ist absurd, 800.000 Wohnungen fehlen und wir haben den dramatischsten Einbruch, den wir je verzeichnen konnten.
Der Kipppunkt ist überschritten, 800.000 Wohnungen fehlen und die ganze Branche wickelt sich gerade ab. Also die wissen, die kriegen jetzt euch nicht mehr los, da kommt keiner, kauft irgendwas, hier dämmt niemand. Also es ist einfach hier nicht zu...
Findet nichts mehr statt, ne?
Also für Sie ist die Branche einfach einmal vor die Wand gefahren.
Aktuell brechen die Baugenehmigungen und die Baugebinde dramatisch ein. Die liegen seit 2023 mit 25 bis 40 Prozent unter dem Vorjahr. Der Kipppunkt ist erreicht. Ich habe es gesagt, das wollte vor einem Jahr keiner so wirklich hören. Jetzt haben wir ihn. Im Herbst letzten Jahres wurden die ersten Werke geschlossen. Unternehmungen sind in Kurzarbeit. Die Insolvenzwelle rollt bei Projektentwicklern, bei Bauunternehmungen. Und wir erfahren keinerlei positiven Signale.
Also die FDP sonnt sich in dem Lichte der angedichteten Wirtschaftskompetenz. Es gibt kein Gut, das so hoch nachgefragt ist. Die Leute sind bereit, die Hälfte ihres monatlichen Einkommens dafür auszugeben. Und die Branche wird abgewickelt.
Und wenn du jetzt sagst, die Branche, muss man eigentlich sagen, die deutsche Wirtschaft. Denn wir wissen, dass Bauwirtschaft und die Wirtschaftsleistung einer Volkswirtschaft nahezu gleich betrachtet sind. Entweder guckt man aufs BIP oder man guckt auf die Bauwirtschaft.
Das ist egal.
Also ist auch anteilsmäßig...
Also Wirtschaftswachstum und Wachstum in der Baupranche verlaufen parallel.
Also wir hören jetzt einen Forscher von DIW, der das mal aufdröselt. Wir wollen jetzt wissen, wie hoch ist denn der Anteil des Wohnbaus an der deutschen Wirtschaft? Er vergleicht es mit der Autobranche. Wir können jetzt schon mal überlegen, ist es höher, ist es weniger? Ich will dazu sagen, wir reden hier nur über Wohnbauen, Wohnungen bauen. Es gibt noch das industrielle Bauen, es gibt die Infrastruktur und so weiter. Also es gibt private Investoren, die große Werkzeiten, was auch immer. Brummt, Infrastruktur, so langsam kommt es ja aus dem Knick. Windräder müssen gebaut werden. Da wird viel gebaut. Also wir hören jetzt nicht die ganze Baubranche, wir hören nur die Wohnbaubranche und fragen uns trotzdem wirklich so groß.
Sie sehen hier eine Grafik. Ja, das sind doch sage und schreibe gut vier Millionen Beschäftigte, die unmittelbar mit der Produktion und der Reparatur von Autos beschäftigt sind. Ja, wie sieht es nun mit dem Wohnungsbau aus? Im Wohnungsbau sind es dann noch mal gut eine halbe Million mehr Beschäftigte, die man dem Wohnungsbau zuordnen kann. Sie sehen hier ist sozusagen der dunkle Balken der direkten Beschäftigung größer. Also insbesondere das, was wir in der Bauwirtschaft sehen. Aber eben auch hier gibt es indirekte Effekte, beispielsweise bei den Baustoff-Zulieferern oder eben auch bei den Architekten und Planern. Also die erste Idee ist zu sagen, oh, also der Wohnungsbau, der ist schon ziemlich groß. Aber wenn man das sozusagen in die gesamtwirtschaftliche Bedeutung als einordnen will und nicht nur sagen will, okay, das ist ein bisschen mehr als, wie allein das Auto bei uns bedeutet, haben wir versucht, das in so einem Modell wirklich umfassend zu erfassen und haben neben den direkten Effekten bei den Baufirmen, den indirekten Effekten bei den Zulieferern eben auch berücksichtigt, dass diese Produktion von Wohnbauten natürlich Einkommen generiert, also diese Einkommen auch nochmal neu verausgabt werden. Und diese sogenannten Kreislaufeffekte oder indizierten Effekte sind durchaus von großer Bedeutung. Wenn Sie das jetzt hier mal insgesamt schauen, dann kommt zu den sozusagen 4,5 Millionen Beschäftigten, die wir direkt und indirekt durch den Wohnungsbau generieren, nochmal gut zwei Millionen dazu, die man den Kreislaufeffekten zuordnen kann. Insgesamt kommen wir also auf eine Zahl von 6,5 Millionen Beschäftigten.
Das ist die Hälfte mehr als die Autobranche. Kann man einfach mal vor die Wand fahren lassen, gar kein Problem. Da braucht man auch keinen bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten, der dann hier doch nochmal eine Verirrung macht. Es wird gar nicht thematisiert. Macht dann hart, aber fair dankenswerterweise meine Sendung. Und das war es. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dieses Verfassungsgespräch, da war es einmal im Jahr, als ich das runtergeladen habe, hatte das 2000 Views oder so. Es ist jetzt nicht, dass das Deutschland bewegt, auch wenn da Jörg Schönborn und alle dahin und ein Bundesminister. Das ist irgendwie ganz komisch. Also jetzt haben wir hier 6,5 Millionen Menschen in einer, keine Ahnung, 45 Millionen Menschen arbeiten. Also das ist wirklich Substanz.
Ein Wort noch dazu sagen, weil du jetzt hast, dass es die Leute dann merkwürdigerweise nicht so interessiert, obwohl alle so sehr betroffen sind. Alle wohnen, 6,5 Millionen Menschen arbeiten, direkt oder indirekt in der Wohnungsbaubranche. Also eigentlich müssten alle Leute die ganze Zeit davon reden. Warum tun sie das in Bezug auf Migration und andere Themen? Nun, die Sache ist, glaube ich, dass das Bauen noch mal etwas ist und auch das Wohnen, dass zum einen so abstrakt gefasst werden kann. Und dann ist das ganz stark von individualistischen Dingen geprägt. Also jeder, der was bauen will, hat seine ganz eigenen Sorgen. Jeder, der eine Wohnung sucht, hat seine ganz eigenen Sorgen. Also es geht nicht allgemein nur um bezahlbaren Wohnraum, sondern auch, wo liegt das, ist da Kita in der Nähe, gibt es da einen Kita-Platz. Und dadurch, dass das so sehr auch mit ganz vielen individuellen Problemen zu tun hat, kommt man ganz selten auf so eine abstrakte Ebene, dass man sagt, da müsste jetzt eigentlich die Diskussion entlang gehen. Weil es dann doch wieder so ausdifferenziert ist. Und ich glaube, das macht es so schwierig, das auch so im Großen und Ganzen zu politisieren. Denn eigentlich müsste man ja sofort mit einem Aufruf, Millionen auf die Straße bringen.
Ja, also die Dimensionen sind so riesig, sie könnten uns wirklich übermannen. Und sie sind ja auch für die Betroffenen selbst so groß, dass man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, dass man noch mit zehn Millionen anderen Menschen in derselben Schicksalsgemeinschaft ist.
Das wäre ja irre.
Also das würde ja alles...
Ja, es müsste so eine Vernetzung geben. Ich habe gestern eine sehr schöne Sache über Vernetzung gehört. Ich weiß, das wird jetzt viele verärgern, aber ich verwende das ja nicht, dass ich ja bekanntermaßen kein Smartphone habe. Also, es gibt ja Apps, oder ich glaube, ein, zwei sind besonders beliebt, die einen davor warnen, wenn irgendwo geblitzt wird. Diese zu verwenden, ist verboten. Es gibt verschiedene Urteile, aber ja, manche machen dann so eine Rechnung, wem wird es auffallen? Und bevor ich den Führerschein verliere, lieber irgendwie eine Strafe zahlen für die App, irgendwelche Dinge, will ich hier gar nicht beurteilen. Mir geht es um was anderes, weil wir gerade über dieses Individualistische gesprochen haben. Du hast ja auch geschildert, man fährt mit seinem eigenen Auto rum. Interessanterweise, diese Apps funktionieren ja ganz einfach durch Solidarität. Das heißt, weil ich dann sagte, aber wie werden die denn so schnell aktualisiert? Naja, ganz viele Menschen haben diese Apps runtergeladen. Dann fahren die los, bin heute Morgen hierher gefahren und sahen, wie da gerade so ein Radargerät aufgebaut wurde. Und wenn man jetzt so eine App hat, dann drückt man da irgendetwas und dann wird das sofort verzeichnet. Und dadurch sind die vollkommen individualisierten Autofahrer plötzlich solidarisch miteinander, ohne einander zu kennen, weil jeder davon profitiert, dass der andere ein Auge drauf hat und warnt. Und das finde ich interessant und habe darüber nachgedacht, wie man aus so einer App-Idee, und ich betone nochmal hier, dass es nicht erlaubt, wie man daraus vielleicht auch was Politisches machen könnte. Also wie man eigentlich Individualisierte, und das ist ja eine atomisierte Gesellschaft, sagt man oft, ja, wie man die eigentlich zusammenbringen kann, ohne dass man sagt, ja, das müsste über Gewerkschaft und so laufen, weil vieles kann man über diese Art des gemeinschaftlichen, wie das in den 70er Jahren mal möglich war, nicht mehr organisieren. Nur mal so in den Raum gestellt.
Cancer-Culture.
Du willst hier Leute zum Mob organisieren?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich finde eher, dass man sagen kann...
Ich verstehe den Gedanken und er ist ja auch gut.
Also zum Beispiel gibt es, wo kann man zum Beispiel, wo Arbeitsunrecht passiert oder so, wo kann man gemeinschaftlich darüber etwas organisieren? Weil an sich ist der Einzelne ziemlich machtlos gegenüber Dingen. Ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt von jemandem gehört, der plötzlich aus der Wohnung aussieht und ganz viel zahlen soll für Renovierung, was gar nicht vertraglich vorgesehen ist. Der als Einzelner, sich zu werden, ist schwierig. Wie soll der jetzt, weil das ganz viele Mieter sind, Kontakt zu Leuten aufnehmen, die ähnlich waren? Und da, glaube ich, gibt es über diese Komponente, die ja immer auch impliziert, es hilft allen. Also du hast auch einen Nutzen davon, wenn du da mitmachst. Glaub ich, gäbe es da nochmal gewisse Möglichkeiten. Ich will jetzt hier nicht so ein Propagandist von Smart Revolution sein, aber ein bisschen was hängt da schon auch, ist schon möglich.
Wir behalten den Gedanken fürs Wohnen spezifisch im Hintergrund und kommen nachher nochmal kurz drauf. Ansonsten würde ich sagen, Google Maps und dieses ganze Jahr Meda, ich bewerte meinen Arzt, meinen Lehrer und so. Es gibt schon genug Denunzierungsplattformen.
Ich meine nicht Denunzierungsplattformen. Ich meine wirklich, wie könnten Leute gemeinsam etwas auf die Beine bringen?
Vielleicht sollten wir das heute als Idee, wenn jemand aufgrund, und wir haben nachher nochmal eine Zuspitzung zu dieser Frage, dann kann man ja gerne mal was entwickeln. Wir propagieren das dann.
Ja, ja, ich meine nicht einen Pranger bauen.
Also ich bin hier nicht nur für Pranger, sondern auch für Galgen, ehrlich gesagt.
Gott, bitte nicht, das wissen wir sofort. Das ist natürlich von Stefan ganz ironisch gemeint.
Wir hören noch mal die Dimensionen. Also niemand, der irgendwie denkt, ich bin doch so fleißig, ich bin doch ein ehrbarer Mann. Der Kanzler hat mir Respekt versprochen, trotzdem kriege ich keine Wohnung. Liegt es an mir? Nein, es liegt nicht an dir. Hier kriegst du Aufklärung. Es ist ein volkswirtschaftliches Versagen. Die Branche, die hier gerade vor die Hunde geht und dir deine Lebenschancen raubt, ist so groß.
Wir haben hier mal versucht, die Steuereffekte des Wohnungsbaus zu berechnen. Insbesondere die Umweltssteuer und die Lohnsteuer spielen hier eine große Rolle, wo durch die Produktion von Wohnbauten, durch die Modernisierung, Instandhaltung und den Neubau entsprechende Steuereinnahmen generiert werden. Insgesamt sind das 140 Milliarden Euro. Auch wieder eine große Summe. Der Anteil einer Gesamtsteueraufkommen sind 17 Prozent. Also wir sehen, wie wichtig das Bauen auch für die Steuereinnahmen ist.
Das heißt also, ein Bundeshaushalt ist größer, wenn es der Bauwirtschaft gut geht?
Also wir könnten uns ganz viele Diskussionen sparen, wo wir wo sparen, wenn wir hier dem Bedarf und der Nachfrage, die wir haben, einfach mal nachkämmen mit einer klugen Wirtschaftspolitik. Weil derzeit 140 Milliarden Steueraufkommen Bund, Länder und Gemeinden in diesem Thema. Also hier könnten wir auf jeden Fall uns Spielräume erarbeiten und Lebensträume erfüllen. Es wäre Win-Win. Also wirklich dramatisch, mit was wir es hier zu tun haben. Derzeitige Entwicklung. Hier wird mal gegenübergestellt Bevölkerungsgröße und Neubau.
Wohnungsbau bedarf und da nochmal auch deutlich eine Warnung an die Frage, dass man das nicht mit der Nachfrage verwechseln darf. Eine Nachfrage ist Kaufkraft. Nachfrage ist das Leistungsvermögen von Käuferinnen und Käufern und Mietern, sich eine Wohnung zu leisten. Und Bedarf ist das, was wir brauchen, um in Deutschland die Menschen, die Haushalte mit einer angemessenen Zahl von guten und standardmäßig zukunftsfähigen Wohnungen auszustatten. Und dieser Bedarf wird von Bevölkerungsentwicklung eben charakterisiert. Und das ist zum einen Demografie, die schon seit langer Zeit Deutschland nicht mehr wachsen lässt, sondern Sterbefälle und Geburten sind eher negativ. Aber der Zuwanderung, die Zuwanderungsrate, das Wanderungssaldo, ist das, was Deutschland auszeichnet. Über die letzten Jahrzehnte etwa 330.000 Menschen bis zu 375.000 Menschen zuletzt im Durchschnitt im ersten Jahrzehnt dieses Jahrhunderts 115.000 und im letzten über 550.000 Menschen. Und wenn man sieht, wie die Bevölkerung entwickelt, sieht man eben, die rote Kurve ist der Wohnungszuwachs in Deutschland, die Bevölkerungszuwachs, die Balken sind der Wohnungsbau zur jeweiligen Zeit, wie weit das mittlerweile auseinandergeht. Und am Anfang der Betrachtung da links, 1990, waren es noch 34 Millionen Haushalte in Deutschland. Und jetzt sind wir mittlerweile auf deutlich über 42 Millionen Haushalten angewachsen.
Ja, also wir sehen hier zwei Linien.
Bevölkerung steil nach oben.
Bau pro Jahr rückläufig.
Also immer mehr Menschen. Und nee, dieses Jahr baut man noch weniger als letztes Jahr. Und dann dieses Jahr nochmal weniger. Also wir haben hier fünf Jahre in Folge, die es rückläufig ist. Die Leute wollen Milch im Supermarkt? Nee, heute verkaufen wir nur noch drei Liter. Jetzt verkaufen wir nur noch anderthalb. Jetzt gibt es nicht mal mehr einen. Aber es kommen doch vier Leute mehr an, die wollen Milch kaufen. Nee, ist egal. Also das mal übertragen, man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen, in welchen Turbulenzen das hier ist. Das sind ja gesamtdeutsche Zahlen. Und wir haben hier im Hinterkopf, im Osten, in der Eifel, wo auch immer wird jetzt Höfeweise werden Straßenzüge verkauft für den symbolischen Euro, damit dann nochmal was passiert. Wir haben also in Deutschland zwei Millionen freie Wohnungen. Selbst die eingepreist, solche Skiflagen. Was bedeutet das jetzt für diese regionalen Sonderzentren, die wir als urbane Zentren mit Trupp holen, da wo die Zuwanderung nicht nur aus dem Ausland, sondern auch aus den Familien hin, also wo wollen 22-jährige Leute hinziehen? So, jetzt haben wir hier gesehen, die Linien aufeinander, kann man das beziffern.
Und das bedeutet eben jetzt schon, wir haben einen komplett heterogenen Wohnungsmarkt, wo wir diese blauen Flächen, das sind die Bereiche in Deutschland, wo wir eher entspanntere Märkte haben, Überschuss. Aber der größte Teil Deutschlands ist eben gekennzeichnet durch eine deutliche Knappheit, bis hin zu einer kompletten Überlastung von Wohnungsmärkten. Und das sieht man eben an mehreren Zahlen. Hier mal 39 Regionen in Deutschland rausgegriffen, in denen man vergleichen kann, wie die Bevölkerung sich entwickelt hat und wie gleichzeitig der Wohnungsbau gewachsen ist. Und das Verhältnis dazwischen ist zwischen anderthalb bis zum zwanzigfachen. Aber das Produkt, und das ist eben viel entscheidender, am Ende ist, dass die Menschen sich eben zusammen ruckeln und dann eben in den Wohnungen wohnen, die ihnen zur Verfügung stehen. Und die sind nicht mehr angemessen.
20 Leute mit dir. Und einer kriegt die eine Packung, die da liegt. Das ist der Wohnungsbaumarkt in Deutschland.
Na, du siehst es doch in den Großstädten schon sehr stark, dass da der beengte Wohnraum sich auch so ausdrückt, dass die Leute versuchen, möglichst viel Zeit draußen zu verbringen, weil sie einfach dauerhaft in beengten Verhältnissen leben. Das war ja auch so was, was während der ganzen Lockdowns weitgehend ignoriert wurde, dass man mit vier Leuten auf 50 Quadratmetern halt nicht so gerne ruft, wir bleiben zu Hause, sondern eher gerne raus möchte. Und das ist etwas, was, glaube ich, jetzt immer stärker zu beobachten ist, einfach ums Stadtbild, deshalb hat die Leute mehr draußen leben, weil drinnen nicht mehr viel ist.
Genau, dem gehen wir jetzt mal nach. Wir haben ja junge Zuhörer in urbanen Zentren gerade hingezogen, also diesen Wohnungsmarkt, der die letzten fünf bis zehn Jahre so mitgekriegt. Die denken sich jetzt, ja, 40 Quadratmeter für meine Freundin, die schon zwei Kinder hat und so weiter, das ist ganz schön eng. Wir leben hier, glaube ich, nennt man das, in überbelebten Wohnungen. Betrifft nur uns, hoffentlich gibt es da bald Abhilfe. Und jetzt kriegen wir Zahlen, wie viele Menschen das betrifft.
9,3 Millionen Menschen im letzten Jahr lebten in überbelegten Wohnungen in Deutschland.
Falls ihr es nicht richtig sagt, nicht 0,3, sondern 9,3 Millionen Menschen gesagt.
Die europäische Sozialstatistik, die Zahl ist mittlerweile abgedatet worden, weil die Folie eine Woche alt ist. Das ist eine Anfrage aus dem Bundestag. 9,5 Millionen sind es mittlerweile. Das heißt, innerhalb von drei Jahren allein, denn wir haben 2020 die Zahl zum letzten Mal auch hier auf dem Wohnungsbautag erhoben, ist die Zahl der Menschen, die in Deutschland in überbelegten Wohnungen leben, um gut eine Million angewachsen. Das heißt, die Wohnungsmärkte sind überlastet.
Das heißt eigentlich, wenn Pistorius jetzt mehr Leute in die Kaserne holen will, muss man sagen, ganz viele sind jetzt schon in so einer Kaserne.
So, was heißt überbelegte Wohnung? Wir haben hier reportagige Einblicke über hart aber fair bekommen, die wirklich gruselig sind. Und gerade mit dieser Zahl, es betrifft einfach 10 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland.
Wir sind Familie Lever, sind jetzt zu viert und seit vier Jahren auf der Suche einer größeren Wohnung. Momentan wohnen wir auf 65 Quadratmetern. Das verteilt sich auf zwei Räume. Von der Miete liegen wir so bei 900 Euro kalt, sind also bei 1100 warm. Das ist dann unser Schlafzimmer für uns alle vier. Also in dem Sinn hat es ein bisschen Hostel-Charakter. Die Kinder hier im Doppelstockbett, wir direkt daneben. Und der Platz irgendwie ideal genutzt. Zumindest mehr Platz haben wir nicht. Bei vier Leuten gibt es immer andere Schlafrhythmen. Und das natürlich für die Situationen allgemein belastend.
Der größte Störfaktor ist gerade, dass wir einfach keine Rückzugsorte haben.
Und dass es auch gerade, wenn jemand krank ist, echt schwierig ist.
Das sogenannte Wohnzimmer, was eigentlich der Aufenthaltsraum für uns alle vier ist, wo irgendwie der Platz maximal genutzt ist. Das heißt, wir alle vier verbringen hier unsere Freizeit auf diesen 15-Kornat-Mitteln.
Sie finden schon gar keine Worte mehr dafür. Der ganze Körper redet in dem Moment schwierig. Also das ist wirklich dramatisch. Wie viele Versuche haben die jetzt unternommen, in diesen vier Jahren da mal auszuziehen?
Wir suchen seit vier Jahren, über 300 Anfragen bei einem Portal. Maximal zehn Prozent kriegt man eine Antwort. Vielleicht dann bei drei Prozent kriegt man einen Besichtigungstermin. Wir werden bereit, eine relativ hohe Miete zu bezahlen. Aber die Wohnungen, die wir suchen, sind halt nicht auf dem Markt. Oder stehen aus irgendwelchen Gründen dem Markt nicht zur Verfügung.
Also sie sind sogar bereit, 1700 Euro zu zahlen, was ja richtig viel ist.
300 Anfragen in vier Jahren, ein Jahr hat 365 Tage. Jede Woche befassen die sich ein- oder zweimal damit, eine neue Wohnung zu suchen. Durchforsten das Internet, gehen dann dahin, schreiben die an. Das ist quasi der Nebenberuf, solche Sachen zu machen. Eine Frau saß im Studio beim Klamrod. Und dann kam die Frage auf, die du eben auch schon aufgeworfen hast.
Was machen Sie dann, wenn Besuch kommt?
Wir haben keinen Besuch. Also wenn nur eine Person, das war's.
Und wenn Sie Freunde sehen wollen, mehr Freunde? Was machen Sie dann?
Wir treffen uns draußen, woanders.
Wir haben keinen Besuch. Zehn Millionen Deutsche sagen, wir haben keinen Besuch. So in den Hinsetzen, passt nicht mal ein Stuhl in die Ecke. Jetzt dieses große Problem. Du hast ja eben diese Apps angesprochen. Angenommen, du kommst in eine Verkehrskontrolle und der Polizist sieht diese App. Was passiert dann?
Kriegst du Anleitungen?
Erspricht irgendwelche Fraggelder aus?
Ich bin da jetzt kein Experte, aber was man mir sagte, ist, dass die offenbar das Recht haben, das Gerät auch einzuziehen. Das scheint aber noch nicht vorgekommen zu sein. Man bekommt eine Strafe, möglicherweise auch einen Punkt. Aber frag mich jetzt nicht nach den Details. Ich hab ja nicht mal ein Gerät, womit man das machen kann.
Aber selbst wenn wir jetzt nicht wissen, was passiert, ist es denkbar, dass ein Polizist an der Straße steht und sagt, halt sie mal kurz an, ich will mir mal was angucken. Egal, was du jetzt machst, eine Verkehrskontrolle ist immer möglich.
Eine Verkehrskontrolle ist sowieso immer möglich.
Verkehrskontrollen sind also immer möglich. Du bist im Freibad und machst irgendwas. Was macht der Bademeister? Er pfeift dich an und ruft dich zur Fasson oder wie das auch immer heißt. Ich würde jetzt gerne noch so zehn andere Beispiele, promptet sie euch bitte selber. Man darf nicht machen, was man will. Es gibt Verkehrspolizisten, Stadtpolizei, Landespolizei, Bundeskriminalamt. Das Finanzamt hat irgendwelche Ansprüche. Die ganze Zeit, irgendwer will was von einem.
So, wie ist das jetzt beim Wohnen?
Kommt da irgendwann die Polizei vorbei und fragt, du siehst aber klein aus, soll ich den Vermieter mal eine Notiz stecken? Soll ich in mein Gerät einziehen? Soll ich mal eine Strafe aussprechen?
Irgendwie nicht so, ne?
Beim Wohnen ist irgendwie alles möglich. Du sagst als Vermieter, das ist die Wohnung, das ist der Preis. Ob das dann gegen irgendwelche Gesetze verstößt oder Mietpreisbremsen oder was auch immer. Da kommt niemals die Polizei von sich und sagt, wir machen mal eine allgemeine Verkehrskontrolle.
Nein, du hast die Möglichkeit. Ich hab ja eben gesagt, ich kenne da jemand, der jetzt da ein paar Tausend Euro für Renovierung zahlen muss, für die er gar nicht zuständig ist. Er hat nur die Möglichkeit, jetzt zum Anwalt zu gehen. Das heißt, er braucht schon mal eine Rechtsschutzversicherung, um sich das leisten zu können. Die deckt auch nicht alles ab. Und dann kann er überlegen, gehe ich dieses Risiko ein, könnte ich aber dann auf 2000 Euro Anwaltskosten sitzen bleiben oder sage ich, okay, ich zahle einfach das Geld, zahle diese 2000 Euro, habe dann meine Ruhe, bin ja eh jetzt aus der Wohnung raus. Das ist die Situation, in der man sich befindet. Das heißt, man ist freiwillig für den Vermieter. Deswegen glaube ich, ist es schon sehr ratsam, in den Mieterbund zu gehen, um dort ein bisschen mehr Handarbeit zu haben. Aber auch da wird es nicht so einfach sein.
Nehmen wir mal den Vater von eben, also der sucht seit vier Jahren eine Wohnung. Hat sich schon 300 angeschaut. Er hat ein Budget von 1700 Euro. Dann kommt einer und sagt, ich bitte dir ein Kinderzimmer. Also statt 65 dann einfach 80 Quadratmeter, 15 Quadratmeter mehr. Bedingung ist, kein Mieterbund.
Mietpreisbremse gilt hier nicht.
Und es ist ein bisschen laut. Was macht man dann? Geht man dann zur Polizei und sagt irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Ne, man zieht dann erstmal da ein und denkt sich, ich muss jetzt nicht mehr drei Tage die Woche abends noch zwei Stunden arbeiten, daran eine neue Wohnung zu finden, sondern man hat dann irgendwie eine gefunden. Dieser Anlagenschützer oder wie auch immer heißt Tenhaus, der auch diese ganzen Beratungs-Sachen, also der immer mal so, ich kenne jetzt seinen Namen leider nicht in voller Länge, aber der saß hier mit in der Hardware-Fair-Sendung.
Wenn sich Leute nicht ans Gesetz halten, dann geht der Staat irgendwie vor. Das ist so wie der Verkehrspolizist, wenn ich bei Tempo 30 mit Tempo 50 durchrausche, dann kriege ich ein Knöllchen. Das ist in dem Fall nicht so, ich muss mich als Person darum kümmern, dass sich andere an geltende Gesetze halten. Und das bei dem Thema Wohnraum.
Das ist wie beim Mietwucher Paragraphen übrigens auch.
So, das ist eins der größten Probleme überhaupt, finde ich. Und wäre doch cool, wenn wir hier eine Ministerin hätten, die sich mal darum kümmert. Bauminister, wie wird gebaut, das ist alles eine Regel, dass man nicht da die ganze Zeit selber seine Schicksalsgemeinschaft finden muss und dann noch einen Anwalt und das ist alles Arbeit. Und wir wissen, das schützt im Grunde das Kapital. So, jetzt kriegt, es ist ein Einblick in eine Reportage, die mit dieser Sendung weniger zu tun hatte, die gucken das da auch nur als Clip. Clara Gajwitz, als Bauministerin, mal diese Frage vorgelegt. Könnten sie da nicht mal und so weiter. Sie äußert sich wie folgt.
Interessante Stelle, da fragt meine Kollegin, die Bauministerin Gajwitz, nach genau diesem Problem. Und die Stelle können wir uns noch mal angucken.
Also in einem Rechtsstaat setzt der Gesetzgeber die Rahmenbedingungen, indem er die Gesetze erlässt. Wir haben den Rechtsstaat, das heißt, man kann vor Gericht gehen, wenn diese Gesetze verletzt sind. Aber wir haben natürlich keinen Babysitter-Nanny-Staat, der sich in Vertragsbeziehungen zwischen zwei Privatpersonen mischt.
Herr Künert, würden Sie das auch als Babysitter-Nanny-Staat bezeichnen, wenn der Staat darauf achtet, dass der Vermieter nicht gegen die Mietpreisbremse verstößt?
Nein, das würde ich nicht so bezeichnen.
Ja, ich kann sagen, das ist eine gute Argumentation. Also bei der nächsten Verkehrskontrolle haben Sie Alkohol getrunken, sind Sie zu schnell gefahren, haben Sie dann Warentreieck dabei. Dann sag ich, sind Sie mein Babysitter oder was? Wird dann noch selbst wissen, ob ich Auto fahren kann.
Also man kann es nicht glauben, wie dumm das ist, das sozusagen. Vor allem als Zuständige in diesem Metier. Das ist so unfassbar.
Ich mein, Geibitz hat mir das ja extra so geschaffen, dass sie da irgendwas machen kann. Also das ist ja eine solche Fehlbesetzung. Und hier muss man auch wirklich mal ganz gern sagen, weil wir so oft gegen FDP und alles wettern. Und das ist ja auch alles richtig. Aber genau so etwas kostet kein Geld, das zu verändern. Das könnte Geibitz angehen, statt in der Welt rumzufahren und sich mal schöne Bauprojekte anzusehen. Das könnte sie alles machen. Da ist jetzt nicht der böse Christian Lindner, der das der SPD verhindert. Und dass die anderen SPD-Abgeordneten auch nicht den entsprechenden Druck ausüben. Ja, das ist nicht die Schuld der FDP.
Also Clara Geibitz ist ein echtes Problem.
Ich hoffe, wenn sie nicht da wäre, wäre es besser.
Also es ist wirklich ganz dramatisch.
Wenn das Amt nicht besetzt wäre, könnte man davon ausgehen, dass es besser liefe.
Zurück zum Wohnbautag. Einer nach dem anderen erklärt uns hier, dass der Kipppunkt hinter uns liegt.
An der Stelle, wo wir jetzt im letzten Januar sagen mussten, wir standen vor einem Kipppunkt, ist es jetzt eben tatsächlich ein Kipppunkt, der überschritten ist. Und deswegen ist es nachgeraden notwendig, dass wir jetzt tatsächlich ernsthaft reflektieren, was können wir eigentlich überhaupt noch bauen und was ist eben für die Menschen noch angemessen zu bauen?
Ja, was können wir überhaupt noch bauen?
An das letzte Jahr, da haben wir ausgerechnet, was es eben bedeutet, wenn man Wohnraum, der über 5000 Euro kostet, dann eben runtersubventioniert auf eine Bezahlbarkeit in der Größe auch in sozialer Wohnraumförderung, die irgendwo sich unterhalb von 7 Euro Kaltmeter abspielt. Und das bedeutet, wir reden über einen Subventionsbarwert von gut 2.900 Euro pro Quadratmeter, der eben notwendig ist, das schaffen nur noch wirklich super gut ausgestattete Wohnraumförder pro Kammel der Länder, aber nur noch wenige. Und was sie eben vor allem nicht tun können, den ganzen Markt abfedern.
Ja, man muss für 5000 Euro bauen und bräuchte 2.900 Euro Subventionen, also pro Quadratmeter, um das dann für den Markt, wie wir ihn, und man kann halt nur so viel bezahlen, wie man halt Miete bezahlen kann, um das dann zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das ist kein gesundes Gefüge.
Also hier, äh, ja.
Es ist, ja, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Das ist alles ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schräg.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt eigentlich an so einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann, das ist jetzt einfach so, das wird sich jetzt weiter verschärfen. Möglicherweise wird irgendwann die Wirtschaft einen solchen Aufschwung erleben, dass die Bauwirtschaft davon mitgerissen wird. Dann ist das aber nicht Verdienst von Clara Geivitz, sondern dann ist das so ein gesamtwirtschaftlicher Aufschwung, der sich einstellt, aber das sind ja solche Lücken, da sind solch große Bedarfe inzwischen da, dass das überhaupt nicht mehr aufzufangen ist. Das heißt, man kann sich eigentlich jetzt für dieses ganze Jahrzehnt und darüber hinaus darauf einstellen, dass Wohnungsnotüberbelegung dauerhaft 5, 10, 15 Millionen Menschen betreffen wird.
Ja, so starten wir jetzt in die Altenrepublik, bei der wir auch neuen Wohnbedarf haben. Also nicht nur in der Masse, sondern auch anders wohnen und so.
Also es ist wirklich alles grotesk.
Zurück zu diesem Gespräch, diesem Verfassungsgespräch hat da Deublerg Melin, war ja auch mal Justizministerin, also ist mit Buschmann da schon auf Augenhöhe und so.
Sollte doch auch da beim Mieten, bei der bei Deutsche Wohnen enteignen war sie doch da tätig. Hat es aber glaube ich eigentlich nur verschleppt, das ganze Verfahren.
Ja, das ganze Ding hat sich ja dadurch verschleppt, dass man jetzt es nochmal, genau so nochmal machen muss, aber mit einem konkreten Gesetzestext. Hatte man vorher irgendwie übersehen, dass es da zwei, drei Leute in der Politik ausreichend sind, um einfach so ein ganzes Volksbegehren zu blockieren. Und jetzt braucht man nochmal, wir haben es ernst gemeint, allein für diesen Nachsatz muss man jetzt nochmal ein eigenes Verfahren anstoßen, also skrotest. Sie erklärt uns jetzt aber mal 5000 Euro pro Quadratmeter fürs Bauen. Was ist denn das für ein Quatsch, wo kommen denn diese Preise her?
Ich will es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben, aber es gibt eine Vielzahl von Möglichkeiten, die alle gemacht werden müssen. Mir ist am allerwichtigsten, dass wir auch diejenigen sehen, die als Normalverdienende in Ballungsstädten arbeiten, tagtäglich, und die sich die Wohnungen einfach nicht mehr leisten können. Warum? Weil eine Wohnung in Berlin, ich weiß das auch aus eigener Anschauung, die man Mitte der 90er Jahre gekauft hat, heute das drei- bis vierfache kostet. Und das liegt nicht an den Zinken. Es liegt auch nicht an den Kosten, sondern das sind die Bodenwertsteigerungen, die aus der Organisation und der Behandlung von Wohnungen als Marktgut allein betrachten.
Organisation und Behandlung, finde ich, das klingt so aus Verlegenheit, hat sie wahrscheinlich auch so einfach. Sie wollte irgendwie den Satz zu Ende bringen. Aber das sind im Grunde Grundbegriffe für diesen ganzen Wohnungsmarkt. Organisation und Behandlung. Es sind so viele Vorschriften, es sind so viele Subventionsmöglichkeiten, es sind so viele, und da noch mal eine Abgabe, da noch mal eine Steuer und dann noch mal eine Grundsteuer und hier und da alles miteinander verrechnet und so. Es gibt eigentlich keinen mehr gestalteten Markt als diesen, wo der Staat wirklich überall drin hängt. Und dann ist aber einfach unter dem ganzen Ding der Bodenwert so explodiert. Faktor 7000 in 50 Jahren in München oder sowas. Also das versteht man auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum da, obwohl in der bayerischen Landesverfassung Grund und Boden nochmal extra hervorgehoben wird, explizit als Eigentum verpflichtet und so. Warum das dann trotzdem passierte. Also das kann einfach nur durch Lobbyismus oder wie auch immer erklärbar sein. Das macht sonst keinen Sinn. Also hier wurde ein Markt einfach so richtig zerstört. Dann sagte ich, ja, das sollte man mal einfach des Handlungsvermögen mal wieder nehmen. Jörg Schönborn, das haben wir auch als Hinweis bekommen aus der Hörerschaft. Das ist natürlich gut, wenn jetzt alle sensibilisiert sind. Stellt mal im Grunde unsere Frage.
Ich will einfach aus der Vorbereitung, ich will zwei Zahlen zitieren, Frau Wager. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben Sie eine Idee dazu. Der deutsche Staat gibt etwa 20 Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr aus, um Menschen zu helfen, ihre Miete bezahlen zu können. Über Wohngeld, Grundsicherung und andere Dinge. Im Verhältnis dazu, die Angaben sind unterschiedlich, was so im sozialen Wohnungsbau fließt, Bund, Länder, ist auch von Jahr zu Jahr unterschiedlich, aber da ist man irgendwo bei drei, vier, vielleicht fünf Milliarden. Also das heißt, wir geben ein Vielfaches dafür aus, Menschen zu helfen, teure Mieten zu bezahlen, womit sie am Markt eine Nachfrage erzeugen, die Mieten steigen. Aber wir geben nur einen kleinen Teil dafür aus, das zu tun, was gerade hier mehrfach gefordert worden ist.
Ja, genau die richtige Frage.
Der Vermieter will Geld, wir geben es ihm. Der Mieter will eine kostengünstige Wohnung. Nee, also wer soll das hier machen? Wir sind doch kein Annie-Staat.
Ich war ja bei Jacobean mit Patrick Schreiner, der über den Sozialstaat ein Buch geschrieben hat. Und du hast es vorwärtig geschrieben. Und der sagte auch, es gibt einen einzigen Aspekt am Sozialstaat, den die FDP liebt. Und das ist natürlich das Wohngeld.
Ja, das Wohngeld, diese Dienstwagensachen, dieser ganze Kram.
Aber bei Wohngeld ist es ja tatsächlich Sozialstaat. Und dass man da sagt, das ist schon sinnvoll, dass es das gibt.
Es ist nicht nur für die Leute, die diese durch Geburten-Lotterie einfach übernehmen. Nicht nur ist es ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, sondern es hat auch eine garantierte Höhe. Du siehst einfach so einen Mietspiegel und weißt, die Leute, die sich das nicht leisten können, stellen für mich einen Wohngeld-Antrag. Das ist einfach genial. Das gibt es wahrscheinlich weltweit, wenn nur vergleichbar in Amerika oder so, dass man solche Arten von Ausbeutung da irgendwie institutionalisiert und überall absichert. Na ja, Buschmann macht jetzt hier mal so einen Satz, wo ich sage, das ist sehr weitsichtig, das ist sehr klug und daran sind sie schuld.
Aber ich will Folgendes dazu sagen. Natürlich haben wir in Deutschland generell ein Problem, jetzt sage ich es auch mal ein bisschen theoretisch, dass wir Geld nicht mehr beliebig in Fähigkeiten oder Zustände konvertieren können. Warum? Weil viel Geld, das die Politik zur Verfügung stellt, fließt gar nicht ab. Das hat ein bisschen was mit dem zu tun, was Frau Deubler-Gemminlin gerade gesagt hat, dass wir uns selber auch so ein bisschen verbürokratisiert haben.
So, das ist eine Lüge. Die Bürokratie ist nicht das Problem. Die könnten wir von heute auf morgen einfach, das ist ja Mark Schiritz, Mengen stell schrauben. Man macht mal keine Bürokratie. Aber dieses, wir können in Deutschland nicht mehr beliebig, Geld in Zustände transferieren. Ja, weil wir eine demografische Lage haben, der man einfach Rechnung tragen muss. Ansonsten ist egal, wenn du 75 Jahre alt bist und fünffacher Millionär, kommt trotzdem kein Pflegedienst. Und die nächste Apotheke ist trotzdem 17 Kilometer weit entfernt. Und das nächste Krankenhaus, für deine Notfälle, das wirst du in der Notfallzeit nicht erreichen. Entweder du kriegst halt rechtzeitig eine Diagnose, oder sonst ist es zu spät. Also da funktioniert einfach Geld nicht mehr. Und das sind dann auch echte Wirtschaftskrisen. Es gibt ja so halbechte Wirtschaftskrisen. Also wenn, keine Ahnung, die im Tagesthema und heute schon von Wirtschaftskrise reden, dann meinen die ja immer zu wenig Geld. Und eine echte Wirtschaftskrise ist, wenn auch zu viel Geld es nicht mehr regelt. Wenn es als Medium einfach ausfällt. Und dass er das anerkennt und hier aber noch mal versucht, wieder Bürokratie-Monster-Argument zu machen. Nee, es ist nicht die Bürokratie, sondern hier sind es einfach andere Mechanismen. Naja, Marktmechanismen und ihre Zerstörung, also zurück zum Wohnbautag.
Um nochmal beim Kippungen zu bleiben, haben wir eben festzustellen, dass wir drohen, in so eine abrutschende, abrutschende System abgebauter Kapazitäten im Rhein zu kommen und dass wir die 400.000 Wohnungen, die wir im letzten Jahr noch durchaus hätten errichten können, weil Menschenmaschinenmaterial in Deutschland noch ausreichend vorhanden war, die eben demnächst nicht mehr da sein wird und wir in eine Richtung gehen können, dass überhaupt nur noch 200.000 Wohnungen bauen. Und das ist eben tatsächlich eine fatale Entwicklung. Wir müssen also etwas anders machen. Wir müssen im Grunde alles anders machen.
Menschenmaschinenmaterial, nicht Bürokratie. Die auch, aber die könne man im Federstrich. Das könne Buschmann einfach hier eine vernünftige Bundestagsentscheidung weg damit. Aber dass man Menschenmaschinen und Material noch kaufen kann, man markiert jetzt schon. Im letzten Jahr hätten wir noch 400.000 Wohnungen mit dem Geld, das wir haben. Jetzt würde das Geld alleine schon nicht mehr reichen. Also hier werden wirklich Märkte abgebaut. Man kann es gar nicht in der Drastik, in der man es betont möchte, sagen.
Und ich meine, diese Leute gehen weg oder beziehungsweise sehen die Baubranche nicht mehr als ein Feld, wo man in Zukunft arbeiten will. Und ich würde schon nochmal hier stark machen wollen, dass durch jetzt diese Aufrüstung wir auch dahin kommen, dass es ein Ringen um diese Art der Arbeitskräfte geht. Und beim Material ja auch. Das heißt, natürlich geht nicht jemand, der eben noch Maurer war, bald Panzer zusammenschrauben. Da braucht man natürlich Fachausbildung. Aber wenn man sich generell Gedanken darüber macht, wie sind menschliche Ressourcen in Deutschland verteilt, wie viele Leute gibt es, wo sollen die arbeiten, gibt es genug davon überhaupt, dann ist natürlich immer die Frage, welche Industrie fördert man gerade und welche nicht. Und was ich hier sehe, ist, dass wir das Bauen verkümmern lassen und damit die Misere mal größer machen. Und man dann auch noch der Baubranche bald Personal entzieht, indem einfach andere Arbeitgeber, zum Beispiel aus der Rüstungsindustrie, die attraktiveren wären. Durch diese Industriepolitik, die ja da betrieben werden soll.
Also ich glaube, in der Baubranche, du könnt ja mal so einen Clip zwischendurch spielen, hier aus der Pflegebranche. Bei der Frage, ab wann hat man eigentlich als Branche den zur Verfügung stehenden neuen Jahrgang ausreichend auf seine Seite gezogen? Da nennt uns hier Friederike Glauscher, Vorsitzender vom Frankfurter Verband für Alten und Behindertenhilfe. Also der war hier beim HR zu Gast. Mal zahlen.
Wir haben halt einfach zu wenig junge Menschen, die einen Schulabschluss in Deutschland machen. 800.000 Menschen verlassen in Deutschland die Schule. Über 50.000 davon wählen den Pflegeberuf. Das ist eine sensationelle Quote. Und man braucht auch Buchhalter, man braucht Journalistinnen und so weiter und so fort. Womit wir sehr gute Erfahrungen machen, ist Auszubildende aus dem Ausland holen, die extrem motiviert sind. Aber Deutschland lässt sich schwer verkaufen im Ausland. Das muss man auch sagen. Da stehen wir in Konkurrenz mit anderen. Und das Thema Fremdenfeindlichkeit, das Thema Bürokratie, das spricht sich durchaus rum. Und da sind wir nicht die erste Wahl, wenn es darum geht zu sagen, wollt ihr nicht zur Ausbildung nach Deutschland kommen?
Das betrifft jetzt alle Branchen, auch die Bundeswehr. Die Pflege hat von 700.000 zur Verfügung stehenden, 700.000, 800.000 zur Verfügung stehenden jungen Menschen. Kriegen die gerade jedes Jahr 50.000. Und er sagt völlig zurecht, damit ist es ausgebeutet. Mehr können wir uns gar nicht versprechen. Und trotzdem fehlen Hunderttausende. Also hier sind wir eigentlich wirklich in einem Defizit. Hier kommt man einfach nicht weiter. Und das, was er im Nachsatz sagte, gilt ja für die Baubranche insbesondere. Wir sind einfach ein krass ausländerfeindliches Land. Wir kommen hier nicht besonders weit. Wir müssen sehr gezielt ansprechen. Und das war ja letztes Jahr ein Thema, als ich da bei dieser einen Veranstaltung war, wo es dann hieß, ja, also wir haben jetzt einen Bauüberhang. Und wir wissen, wenn wir den ausleben und keine neuen Aufträge kommen, dann sind diese Arbeiter weg. Die haben keinen Bezug zu Deutschland. Die arbeiten dann sofort woanders. Also es ist nicht wie in der Gastro, dass dann einfach ja, die Studenten kriegen wir schon mal wieder irgendwie mit dem Fahrrad kurz ins Restaurant zu fahren, um da zwei Stunden zu arbeiten. Das ist ja hier nicht so. Also fehlen hier dann einfach alle. Das sind einfach Branchen. Also hier wird einfach mal richtig so eine Branche richtig abgeweckelt. Und dazu aber dieser Sinnspruch, was diesen Bedarf nochmal widerspiegelt.
Weil Wohnen ist eben, wie der Ökonom das Nüchtern sagt, eben nicht nur ein Konsumgut, es ist ein Sozialgut. Und nicht wohnen, nicht wohnen können wir nicht.
Wir können uns diese Branchen-Abrisse da gar nicht erlauben. So, jetzt haben wir verschiedene Branchenvertreter gehört. Also diese Baustoffbranche sagt, das ist Kipppunkt. Wir sehen ja auch nichts am Ende des Tunnels. Mieter bei uns sagen, es ist alles total grotesk. Axel Gadeschko hören wir jetzt vom Verband der Wohnungs- und Immobilienunternehmer.
Herr Gadeschko und Herr Dr. Zapf, wenn Sie das jetzt gehört haben, diese Studien, die ja noch mal zeigen, dass es durchaus Möglichkeiten gibt, etwas zu ändern. Herr Gadeschko, wo gäb's denn für Sie so einen Punkt, wo man sagte, da müsste man jetzt das Wehrgute anzusetzen?
Ja, man muss das Ruder ansetzen, denn wir haben gehört, der Wohnungsbau ist mit das wichtigste Ding in Deutschland. Und dieses Ding ist im freien Fall. Unsere Unternehmen investieren in diesen und im letzten Jahr zusammengenommen minus 50 Prozent. Das heißt nur noch die Hälfte von dem, was vorher investiert wurde. Und das war nicht das, was dazu reichen würde, 400.000 Wohnungen zu bauen. Es reicht nicht.
Eine Branche, die 140 Milliarden Steueraufkommen generiert, 17 Prozent des ganzen Staatshaushalts, sagt jetzt von Jahr auf Jahr minus 50 Prozent.
Naja, es kam doch jetzt schon die Meldung, überraschend werden die Staatseinnahmen niedriger sein.
Ja, ganz überraschend.
Wo könnte denn das herkommen?
Wie kann das nur passieren? Sieht der Licht am Ende des Tunnels?
Die Situation wird sich im Grunde auch nicht bessern. Wenn gesagt wird, wir sehen Licht am Horizont, dann muss ich feststellen, wir sehen dieses Licht am Horizont nicht. Das heißt, die Investitionszahlen unserer Unternehmen gehen weiter zurück.
Mensch, das scheint ja dann ein lustiger Nachmittag gewesen zu sein.
Da kann Manfred Lehmann noch so ein bisschen für Zugsugen sorgen, aber ansonsten...
Den kann man sich aber auch wahrscheinlich in diesem Jahr das letzte Mal leisten.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Nächstes Jahr ist er einfach, vielleicht gar nicht mehr starten.
Nächstes Jahr macht das so eine KI.
Das stimmt.
Siri liest das einfach vor.
Der nächste Verbandsvertreter, deutsches Baugewerbe, ZDB, Wolfgang Schubert-Rab.
Ich möchte nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir derzeit von den Zahlen und den wahrgenommenen Baustellen bei uns in der Republik ein bisschen den Blick verstellt bekommen für die Situation, die uns jetzt in den nächsten Zeiten erwarten wird. Denn das, was wir jetzt in der Vergangenheit gebaut haben, im letzten Jahr, im vorletzten Jahr, das waren ja Aufträge, die wir vier Jahre lang in die Auftragsbücher hineinnehmen konnten, die wir jetzt noch abgearbeitet haben. Es kam aber deutlich weniger nach. Und wenn Sie sich den Ablauf einer Bausituation vorstellen, dann müssen Sie sich das wie eine lange Leitung vorstellen mit zwei Jahren. Das, was Sie vorne reingeben, läuft in dieser Leitung zwei Jahre lang, bis es hinten rausdröpfelt und dementsprechend wird klar, in welche Situation wir in den nächsten Monaten und in den nächsten Jahren sein werden. Wir werden die Zahlen, die wir alle miteinander anvisiert haben, mit den 400.000 über längere Jahre gar nicht erreichen können.
Ja, Mörschheimer hat eben gesagt, der Herr Zenders unterstützt wegen des Nation Buildings. Ja, und dieses Bauen muss man hier ganz wörtlich nehmen. Wo war denn eigentlich der Wirtschaftsminister? Baute der in der Zeit gerade die Ukraine wieder auf oder wo war der? Ja, der war doch da das letzte Mal.
Warum ist der jetzt nicht da? Also bei der Pressekonferenz jedenfalls nicht. Vielleicht hat er einen Termin auf der Bühne gehabt oder so. Siebenkotten versucht jetzt auch mal das große politische Bild.
Wir sagen uns, es gibt Themen wie Verteidigung, wie Klimaschutz, die große Priorität genießen. Müsste nicht das Bauen eine genauso große Priorität bekommen.
So, also Verteidigung, Klima, Wohnen. Ich würde sagen, damit es was zu verteidigen gibt, sollte man wohnen. Ja, weil die Vorwürfe an die jungen Leute, verteidigen wir mal bitte das Land. Und man denkt sich so, der ist gerade nach Stuttgart gezogen. Der sucht seit drei Jahren eine Wohnung. Wieso soll der jetzt nach Sachsen fahren, um da Deutschland zu verteidigen? Also das macht auch überhaupt nichts.
Der kann dann seinen potenziellen Vermieter in Stuttgart verteidigen.
So, wir haben jetzt einige Zahlen gehört. In Ballungsgebieten Faktor 20 unterhalb des Bedarfes ist das Angebot. Wir haben minus 50 Prozent bei 140 Milliarden Steueraufkommen. 70 Milliarden minus heißt das bei diesem Betrag. Aus allen Richtungen, die Kipppunkte sind überschritten. Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Wir gucken jetzt ganz kurz nur bei Hart aber fair. Es ist jetzt mehr so stimmungsmäßig. Man hat so eine dieser Regionen mal angesprochen.
Da sieht man, wie die Mieten in den letzten Jahren gestiegen sind. Sie haben lange in Hamburg gelebt, wo der Wohnungsmarkt auch ziemlich angespannt ist.
Das ist sehr freundlich ausgedrückt.
So, Hamburg. Das ist aber sehr freundlich ausgedrückt, dass Sie da einen angespannten Wohnungsmarkt sehen. Ich habe ihn erlebt. Er sagt, er verdient sehr viel Geld im Fernsehen. Und trotzdem, es geht da niemandem vorbei. Es ist schlimm in Hamburg. Jetzt hören wir beim Wohnbautag auch so eine kleine Zahl aus Hamburg, von der wir wissen, es ist jetzt schon schlimm in Hamburg. Jetzt kommt die kleine Projektion in die nächste Zukunft.
Herr Salewski noch dazu und dann habe ich hier noch ein paar Fragen.
Ich möchte auch noch eine relativ aktuelle Zahl beitragen. Ich war vor wenigen Wochen bei unserem Landesverband Nord. In der Freien und Hansestadt Hamburg sind die Projektbeginne im letzten Jahr bei unseren Mitgliedsunternehmen um 80 Prozent zurückgegangen.
80 Prozent? Da stehen 400 Leute an, die jede Woche gemeinsam zu einer anderen Wohnung gehen, um sich die anzuschauen. Und die kriegen jetzt gesagt, übrigens das Angebot schwindet um 80 Prozent.
Als es der Autowirtschaft in Deutschland mal etwas schlecht zu gehen droht, hat man die Abwrackprämie gemacht. Eine unglaublich teure, schwachsinnige Autoindustrie-Subvention. Hier ist wirklich Notermann und man geht einfach nur über den Weg.
Also liebe Hörer, wenn ihr gerade einen Mietvertrag habt, der läuft, niemals kündigen. Die nächsten zehn Jahre werden keine Wohnungen gekündigt. Ihr findet keine neue. Ihr denkt, ihr könnt noch irgendwie umziehen. Ihr habt ein Jobangebot in Berlin oder so. Ist nicht.
Ja, in Berlin ist es ja ganz interessant. Ich kenne ja Leute, die haben einen alten Mietvertrag. Ich kenne Leute, die haben einen neuen Mietvertrag. Und es ist einfach so eine Zweiklassengesellschaft. Also ich bin noch jemand, der einen alten hat. Und dann und die anderen sagen, ja, ich habe einen neuen. Und dann können die sofort sagen, ah ja, dann hast du also nur halb so viel Geld zur Verfügung wie ich, weil du einfach 50 Prozent mehr zahlst.
Ja, wir wollen hier nur andeuten, wie sehr dieses minus 80 Prozent in Hamburg, Faktor 20 in den Ballungsräumen, die Leute unter 30 betrifft. Die Leute über 50 betrifft das nicht. Die wohnen in den Dingern.
Ja, manche, also in den Städten, also man sieht, also ich finde schon, dass man jetzt gerade ja etwas beobachten kann, wenn man hier durch die Städte geht. Ob es Köln ist, wo ich jetzt viel gesehen habe, Frankfurt auch. Man sieht, man sah früher sehr viele Obdachlose, die Flaschen gesammelt haben. Und jetzt kann man mich natürlich fragen, woher weißt du, dass die Obdachlosen, weil sie aussahen wie Obdachlose. Ich will jetzt hier nicht in den Diskurs da eintreten. Na ja, kann man das denn sehen? Stigmatisierung und so. Aber was ich jetzt feststellen kann ist, dass sehr viele Menschen zu sehen sind, die so um die 60 oder um die 70 sind, die nicht obdachlos zu sein scheinen, die auch noch Klamotten haben, vielleicht aus ihrer Arbeitszeit, aus einer Zeit, wo es ihnen ein bisschen besser ging, und die Flaschen sammeln. Und man fragt sich, was ist denn da jetzt los? Ich hatte jetzt in Koblenz kürzlich eine Frau gesehen, die da so ein bisschen Musik machte auf der Straße. Und es sah mir auch eher aus, dass das für sie jetzt nochmal so eine Möglichkeit ist, ein paar Euro zu machen. Auch sie sah aus wie ja eine Seniorin, aber offenbar reicht die Rente nicht. Und ich würde mal hinzufügen, um in der Wohnung bleiben zu können. Und ich glaube, dass sehr viel jetzt stattfindet in diese Richtung. Dass also diese Altersarmut so aussieht, dass die auch nicht sagen können, na, ich verkleiner mich. Es ist ja einfach nichts da. Und sie leben auch oft gar nicht in großen Wohnungen. Und wenn sie ja in städtischen Räumen leben, dann können sie sich das immer schwerer leisten. Dann kommt die Inflation und sowas noch hinzu. Dann haben sie vielleicht diese Mietverträge, die indexgebunden sind, also an die Inflation gebunden sind. Und die fangen jetzt an, Flaschen zu sammeln. Das ist die Realität, die auf den Straßen jetzt sehr, sehr sichtbar geworden ist. Und klar, die jungen Leute sowieso bei jeder Veranstaltung bekommt man das natürlich erzählt. Und vielleicht ist das aber jetzt ein gutes Fundament, um nochmal über Menschenrechte zu reden. Ich will nur ein paar Clips spielen. Und zwar bin ich gespannt, was du davon hältst. Und zwar in der Evangelischen Akademie. In der Evangelischen Akademie zu Berlin gab es eine Diskussion zwischen Omri Böhm, uns wohl bekannt, Philosoph, Kantianer, hat über den Universalismus ein sehr gutes Buch geschrieben.
Buchtreisgewinner?
Salon habe ich es mal lange vorgestellt. Wir hatten auch schon mal sonst Clips von ihm. Deshalb überspringe ich jetzt die Rede von Omri Böhm, die er den Universalismus begründet. Er macht das mit Kant und wir kennen so in etwa die Argumente und können das ja auch sonst noch mal schnell nachlesen. Und ich würde jetzt gerne zu seinem Counterpart gehen, nämlich Christoph Möllers. Den haben wir eben schon mal gehört mit seinen Bemerkungen. Naja, bemerkenswert ist ja schon, die AfD glaubt noch an die Politik. Und er ist ein Mann, der Staatsrechtler ist, der aber auch ein Buch über Normen geschrieben hat und sagt, naja, Normen, da denken wir immer, die müssen wir so ganz groß begründen. Das ist eher so eine Praxis. Er ist eigentlich kein Soziologe, aber ich hab so den Eindruck, wenn ich ihn so reden höre, dass es doch soziologische Aspekte bei ihm gibt. So, und er fängt jetzt an, auch über die Menschenrechte zu reden. Und wir hören da jetzt erst mal rein, bei der Evangelischen Akademie, was da gesagt wird.
Als Rechtswissenschaftler irgendwie auf diesen ganzen Menschenrechtsdiskurs zu schauen. Und das, wenn man so will, gar nicht zynisch, gar nicht irgendwie jetzt in dem Sinne abwerten oder so, aber doch mit einer gewissen, vielleicht sogar Verzweiflung darüber, dass ich glaube, dass es eigentlich mit diesem Diskurs so in der Praxis vorbei ist. Und dass ich glaube, dass wir eigentlich diese Menschenrechtsdiskurs irgendwie gerade eher abwickeln.
Also er ist jetzt nicht jemand, der sagt, jetzt kommt die große Stunde der Menschenrechte. Das ist also nicht wie der Gast dabei, Richard David Precht, sondern er sieht das sehr skeptisch mit einem Bedauern. Er sagt Folgendes auch.
Da würde man sagen, na ja, wir haben diesen semantischen Konsens, aber wir haben natürlich auch durchaus relevante Praktiken, die diesem Konsens in gewisser Weise doch erstaunlich weitgehend gerecht geworden sind. Wir haben Emanzipationsgeschichten, wir haben Demokratisierungsgeschichten, wir haben sozusagen eine Vielzahl von politischen Gemeinschaften. Wir können eine Vielzahl von politischen Gemeinschaften beobachten, in denen die Menschenrechte, die sich bahn gebrochen hat und dazu beigetragen hat, dass Menschen befreit werden aus Abhängigkeiten, aus staatlichem Unrecht, aus auch privaten Verhältnissen, aus feudalen Strukturen und so weiter und so fort.
Historisch draufgeblickt war das ein sehr erfolgreicher Diskurs.
Man kann sich ja erstmal umgekehrt fragen, gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Diskurs, der sozusagen so erfolgreich war wie der Menschenrechtsdiskurs? Sei es seit 1800, seit Thomas Bain, oder sei es seit 1945 mit Blick auf die allgemeine Deklaration der Menschenrechte, in der wir ja doch einen gewaltigen, erst einmal vielleicht semantischen Konsens darüber gegründet haben, dass Menschenrechte eine wichtige oder vielleicht sogar die zentrale normative Referenz zur Organisation von Gesellschaften sind.
Aber es ist auch daraus die eine oder andere Schwierigkeit entstanden?
Man wird dann auch gleich glaube ich dazu sagen, dass diese Befreiungsgeschichten als solche natürlich, und das ist ja klar, das ist eine Trivialität, man muss es dann doch nochmal sagen, natürlich nicht universal funktioniert haben, sondern immer nur unter sehr, sehr spezifischen politischen Gelingensbedingungen. Sie haben meistens in demokratischen Nationalstaaten funktioniert, seltener in regionalen Kontexten von Menschenrechtsverbindungen, Menschenrechtspakten, wie wir das vielleicht in Lateinamerika heute auch sehen, im europäischen Kontext sehen, und eigentlich nie universell. Man kann sagen, der faktische Übergang vom demokratischen, nationalen, erfolgreichen, menschenrechtsschützenden Nationalstaat zur regionalen Integration, zu internationalen, universalen Menschenrechtsschutz war fast immer auch ein Umschlag einer benevolenten, freiheitseinmöglichen Praxis zu institutioneller Heuchelei. Der institutionelle Heuchelei, die dafür sorgt, dass Saudi-Arabien heute dem Rat für Frauenrechte der Vereinten Nationen vorsetzt. Also, da können wir jetzt auch tausend andere Beispiele für geben.
Ja, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Also, diese Heuchelei sehen wir ja überall. Gerade jetzt, wo Steffen Habart als Verfassungsgerichtsvorsitzender ganz viele Interviews gegeben hat, um noch mal das Grundgesetz abzufeiern, was er ja sehr klug macht, weil er dann immer wieder auf die Praxis des Gerichts zu sprechen kommt und darüber hinaus einfach das Gerede dem Politikanten, den er nicht mehr angehört hat, lässt. Und dann war aber auch die Frage im Raum, ob sich das Verfassungsgericht zu sehr einmischt. Und dann gab es eine Stelle in einem dieser Interviews, wo er so meinte, ne, wenn das Gericht gefragt wird, wie hoch der Mindestbedarf ist, damit irgendwelche Armutsschwellen usw. beim Bürgergeld greifen, dann nimmt man sich Artikel 1, die Menschenwürde, und rechnet dann in Zahlen aus, was das bedeutet. Und dann hat man eine politische Vorgabe, dieser Wert darf nicht unterschritten werden. Und wenn dann die CDU kommt und sagt, ne, wir würden aber gerne weniger Bürgergeld zahlen, dann ist das nicht vereinbar und auch im Grunde nicht möglich, weil man hinter diese Gerichtsentscheidung einfach auch nicht mit politischer Mehrheit dahinter kommt. So, und da an solchen Sachen muss man sagen, wird es dann doch mal wieder konkretisiert, obwohl man immer den Verdacht hat, naja, diese Heuchelei ist halt überall. Da muss man nicht erst mit Saudi-Arabien und dem Menschenrechtsrat der UN oder so, sondern flächendeckend.
Ja, Böhm kommt jetzt doch mal hier zu Wort und sagt, wie er die Situation jetzt so gerade auffasst, er hatte dann auch schon zuvor davon erzählt, dass seine Studenten zunächst einmal dem Universalismus doch zugeneigt erscheinen, denn sie sind doch auch für Freiheit und Gleichheit und so, und dann aber bringen sie ihre Identitätspolitik mit hinein. Er sagt nun... Also er redet jetzt von den Kritikern der Identitätspolitik. Die sagen ja jetzt eigentlich auch immer, wir sind Universalisten. Wir sehen aber jetzt, das kann man besonders gut in Deutschland jetzt am Nahos-Konflikt ablesen, dass also die, die sich über Identitätspolitik die ganze Zeit lustig gemacht haben, betreiben jetzt ihre Identitätspolitik. Also Weltredakteure betreiben ihre Identitätspolitik. Und Borstadt macht jetzt seine Identitätspolitik. Und weiter sagt er...
Wo du siehst, wir müssen nicht unbedingt da hin, aber du siehst die Grenzen, die erhebliche Universalisten plötzlich entdecken, ihre eigenen Identitäten in Spiel. Also ich denke, das sind die Re den Verlust dieser Gespräche.
Ja, Identitätspolitik. Gib mir doch einen kleinen Exkurs, einen Clip. Denn wir haben jetzt, auch wenn er sagt, in die Richtung muss man jetzt nicht gehen, weil kontroverses Thema, aber dieses ganze Israel-Fragen und so. Wir hatten jetzt in Deutschland diese Sylt-Sache. Und das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, inwieweit jetzt dieses, naja, solange es die Identitätskämpfe der anderen und so weiter, deren Selbstbehauptung, dann stehen wir da und machen uns drüber lustig. Nur jetzt sind es ja nicht irgendwelche jungen amerikanische Studenten mit Einwanderungsgeschichte oder was auch immer, die sich zur Hamas so bekennen, dass wir von hier aus sagen, ne, das geht aber nicht, das ist ja völlig überdadet, was machen die denn da? Sondern wir haben plötzlich unser eins, also nicht importierter Antisemitismus im Sinne von, mit Ausländern habe ich nichts zu tun, ich werde ja nie einer sein. Ach so, die Superreichen sind jetzt auch Antisemiten. Ich wollte ja eigentlich auch mal Superreich sein, so ungefähr. Also man hat eh schon so ein völlig falsches Bild da von den Leuten in Sylt. Man stellt dann fest, ach so, doch keine Superreichen, die arbeiten als Handlanger für irgendwelche Influencer oder sowas. Also ich habe es nicht genau verfolgt, aber das waren ja dann so die Geschichten. Und Dagmar Rosenfeld macht dann in ihrem Podcast Machtwechsel, also steigert sich da so rein in folgende Fragestellung.
Also diese grölende Menge mit Nazis gleichzusetzen, ist doch eigentlich auch eine Relativierung dessen, was ein Nazi ist. Na ja, die Frage ist doch, ist das, was auf Sylt geschehen ist, Ausdruck einer rechtsextremen Gesinnung, die es in die bürgerliche Mitte und zu den ganz Wohlhabenden geschafft hat?
Also, jetzt kommen wirklich alle Identitätsparadoxien auf einmal. Ich bin ja auch deutsch, also ich bin deutsch, aber kein Nazi. Das haben wir ja schon mal jetzt historisch geklärt.
Und mit Christian war ich doch auch immer auf Sylt. Was ist da los?
Genau, so, so, aber dann auch dieses... Hat es diese Ideologie jetzt zu den Reichen in Deutschland geschafft?
Denn wir wissen ja, sonst war ja Rechteideologie immer nur eine Sache für arme Leute.
Ich meine, der ganze Neonazismus 1.0 war der übrig gebliebene Adel und so weiter, dient sich da an, die ganzen Industriellen brauchen. Und dann haben wir ein Zwangsarbeitermuseum, das das Schicksal von 20 Millionen Menschen uns in Weimar erklärt. Und wir eröffnen es, nee, nicht 1954, sondern 2024. So lange hat es gebraucht, bis wir dann irgendwann mal so Eier haben.
Wir können ja auch mal bei unseren deutschen Konzernen auf den Homepage nachgucken, wie die mit dieser dunklen Zeit umgehen. Das ist wirklich fahrschreubend.
Aber da verirrt sich halt überall so dieses, nee, eigentlich bin ich voll der Universalist, der deutsche Nicht-Nazi und meine Familie war auch immer Widerstand und so weiter und so fort. Und ich habe mir dann noch mal so eine Notiz von Greta, weil es ja auch wieder so in der Morgenpost, keine Ahnung, dass Greta jetzt droht, ihr ganzes Erbe aufs Spiel zu setzen, weil sie jetzt vom Klima auf Gaza umgeschwenkt ist. Da dachte ich auch wieder, naja, beim Thema Klima wurde ihr ja immer angedichtet. Greta kämpft nicht für sich, sondern stellvertretend für uns alle. Sie möchte uns im Grunde von unserem blöden Verhalten so ein bisschen, also da steckt ja das Ur-universalistische, ich opfere mich für die Gemeinschaft. Klima geht uns alle an. So, für mich ist das funktional betrachtet ein ganz kurzer Weg zu sagen, ich möchte alle Menschen vor Klimaerwärmung schützen, zu ich möchte alle Menschen vor Gewalt schützen und dann eben nicht mit dieser deutschen Schuldfrage belastet und überhaupt, weil sie ja U20 ist in Schweden, ja da kann man halt schon mal ein bisschen lockerer, aber sag mal mal, über, keine Ahnung, hier liegt so ein Mutkrake auf meiner Dings oder wie auch immer.
Gut, das war ja eh aufgeklärt, aber ich würde...
Aber dass das jetzt überhaupt als Frage, also dass da gar nicht die Kontinuität des Universalismus in diesem Denken und Verhalten einer jungen Frau drinne steckt, sondern dass man jetzt plötzlich sagt, nee, für die Menschheit wegen Klima ist okay, aber dann Gaza, nee, dann ist sie ja voll Hamas und so weiter und voll die Antisemitin. Also dann ist sie ja nicht mehr universalistisch für die Opfer, denen wirklich die ganze Lebensgrundlage in Gaza weggebombt wurde, sondern dann müssen wir unbedingt das ganze Vorzeichen umdrehen. Und dass die jungen Leute nicht verstehen, was der Vorwurf ist, verstehe ich wieder total. Also es ist einfach, hier kommt dieser Universalismus.
Ich habe meine Schwierigkeiten, deshalb damit, weil ich hier so weit gehen würde und das sind natürlich Unterstellungen, aber naja, nicht nur Unterstellungen, sondern man hat ja auch einige Aussagen von Greta Thunberg gehabt, die jetzt mehr sind als einfach nur ich nehme an einem Protestteil, dass ich glaube, dass dieser antikolonialistische Impetus aus dem heraus, das entsteht, Doppelstandards setzt und am Ende nicht universalistisch ist. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Greta Thunberg in der gleichen Weise für einen Universalismus eintritt, wie jetzt Omri Böhm, der ja auch ein scharfer Kritiker der israelischen Regierung ist, es tut, sondern ich habe, und da kommt jetzt auch gleich noch was zu, ich habe den Verdacht, dass wir so eine neue Art des antikolonialistischen Kampfes erleben, der nicht universalistisch ist, sondern der sagt, antikolonialistisch, also Kampf gegen Unterdrückung irgendwie ist generell gut, aber das muss nicht bedeuten, dass man daraus etwas Universalistisches ableitet. Und ich glaube, wir haben ja auch das Buch von Veit Selk ausführlich besprochen im Salon. Und er sagt ja auch am Ende, ja wohin wird sich das so alles bewegen? Er weiß es nicht. Demokratie, Dämmerung. Aber da ist noch diese postkoloniale Theorie, die gar nicht demokratisch zum Teil ist. Was sagt die genau? Die dann durchaus eine Affinität haben kann zu autoritären Regimen. Ich mach, wir springen. Okay, weil du das hast jetzt, jetzt hast du mich... Wir springen gerade mal zu diesem Artebeitrag. Alle werden ja in diesem Monat nach Neu-Caledonien gepflegt haben. Nein, natürlich niemand. Neu-Caledonien, wo liegt das? Ja, das ist, wenn du so ein Dreieck bildest zwischen Australien, Neuseeland, Australien, Fitchy. So da in diesem Bereich ist Neu-Caledonien, gehört zu Frankreich. Dort ist Macron hingereist, eiligst, weil dort Aufstände turben. Und wir hören jetzt mal gerade in diesen Beitrag rein, was da eigentlich Neu-Caledonien so abgeht.
Herzlich willkommen. Heute richten wir den Blick erneut auf Neu-Caledonien nach den gewalttätigen Unruhen in dem französischen Überseegebiet im Pazifik. Frankreichs Staatspräsident ist doch nach einer Reise von 17.000 km eingetroffen. An einer geplanten Verfassungsreform hatten sich die Krawalle entzündet. Bei Provinzwahlen sollen all jene stimmberechtigt sein, die in Neu-Caledonien geboren sind oder seit mindestens zehn Jahren dort leben.
Also 17.000 km ist das weit weg.
Naja, das liegt zwischen Fitchy und Australien. Da muss man schon weit weg.
Hat man da keinen Stadthalter oder so?
Der musste dahin. Der hat auch einen wichtigen Termin abgesagt, weil es da um etwas geht. Und zwar folgendes.
Die Gegner der Reform sehen darin eine Maßnahme zur Beschränkung des politischen Einflusses der Seele.
Ach ja, das müsste ich vielleicht kurz aufklären. Also es gibt eine indigene Bevölkerung, die zum Teil autonom sein will, also sich loslösen will von dem, von Frankreich. Frankreich braucht aber diesen Ort natürlich, will diesen Ort haben. Und auch eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung, es gab also mehrere Referenten inzwischen, ist dafür, dass man dabei bleibt. Aber jetzt ist dieser Konflikt erneut ausgebrochen, weil man nun eine neue Wahlrechtsreform hat. Und die führt dazu, dass Zugezogene, die erst zehn Jahre dort leben, auch wählen dürfen. Eigentlich was ganz Modernes. Dadurch aber dürfen viel mehr wählen, womit die Stimme der Indigenen natürlich dann im Verhältnis abgeschwächt wird. Und das ist der Protest.
Paratisten. Dabei wurden bereits drei Referenden zum Verbleib der Inselgruppe bei Frankreich abgehalten und jedes Mal stimmte eine Mehrheit dafür.
Nun ist es so, dass also bislang vielen Bürgern das Wahlrecht gar nicht ermöglicht wurde. Das wird jetzt damit ermöglicht. Die Indigenen sind aber sehr sauer jetzt darüber, dass natürlich ihre eigene Position, ihre eigene Stimme schwächt. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht in allen Einzelheiten beurteilen. Das ist etwas, wo ich jetzt nur deletieren müsste. Aber wir hören uns jetzt mal noch an, warum eigentlich diese Insel wichtig ist.
Der Wohlstand des Gebietes beruht zum großen Teil auf der Förderung von Nickel. Weltweit hat Neu-Caledonien die drittgrößte Fördermenge und die fünfgrößten Reserven. Aber es geht auch um Frankreichs Stellung im Pazifik und um die Verteidigung seiner Interessen. Etwa 560.000 Menschen leben in den drei französischen Außengebieten im Pazifik.
Also 250.000, 270.000, das ist nicht besonders viel. Aber wir haben es hier mit einer Bevölkerung zu tun, die sehr viel Alkohol zu sich nimmt, sehr viel Cannabis. Also es ist ein großes Problem, sehr viele Straftaten stehen auch in diesem Zusammenhang. Arbeitslosenquote, das sind jetzt Zahlen von 2018 bei etwa 12%. Das Leben ist sehr viel teurer, es ist 33% teurer als in Frankreich. Lebensmittel 73% teurer als in Frankreich. Mindestlohn und Durchschnittseinkommen sind aber 20% geringer als in Frankreich. Das heißt, es ist eine Bevölkerung, der es nicht besonders gut geht. Nickel ist natürlich wichtig für sie, zerstört aber auch einiges. Und wir hören weiter.
Seinen Überseegebieten verdankt Frankreich eine ausschließlich Wirtschaftszone von insgesamt über 10 Millionen Quadratkilometern, davon entfallen 1,7 Millionen auf Neukaledonien. Damit verfügt Frankreich nach den USA über das zweitgrößte Seegebiet der Welt. Außerdem verfügt Frankreich im südlichen Pazifik über eine beachtliche Militärpräsenz mit 3.000 Soldaten in Numéa und 3.000 in Papete.
So, und China ist natürlich auch sehr interessiert an dieser Region.
Sowohl in Neukaledonien als auch in Französisch-Polinesien leben viele Chinesinnen und Chinesen, und Pekings anti-westlicher Diskurs kommt bei einem Teil der indigenen Bevölkerung gut an. Sie meinen immer noch, in einer Kolonie zu leben.
Das heißt also, dieser Antikolonialismus kann sich sehr gut auch mit einem chinesischen Autoritarismus verbinden. Und jetzt kommt noch ein Fun-Fact, und ich empfehle diesen Artikel von Sylvia Stöber auf tagesschau.de sehr lang, sehr ausführlich, wie Aserbaidschan sich gerade einmischt und die Indigenen dort unterstützt und man überlegt, hä, was hat denn das jetzt damit zu tun? Also, 3600 Kilometer sitzt der Ali jetzt weg und was macht der da? Ja, diese 13.600 Kilometer mögen zwar weit entfernt sein, aber man kann hier über Bande spielen, nämlich Frankreich ist ja durchaus den Armeniern zugeneigt, was in Aserbaidschan auf Unmut stößt und jetzt rächt man sich auf diese Weise, verkauft das aber so, dass es einem wichtig ist, dass Menschen dort ihren Befreiungskampf führen dürfen. Und so unterstützt man also die Indigenen dort. Ich kenne mich zu wenig da aus, um jetzt diesen Konflikt an sich beurteilen zu können, inwieweit die anliegende Indigenen richtig sind oder falsch sind. Ich will nur sagen, diese Seite gibt es, wo also da nicht etwas Universalistisches unbedingt in Anschlag gebracht werden kann. Und weil ich jetzt eben so sagte, da gibt es aber ökonomisch einige Verwerfungen und große Ungleichheit und große Armut, können wir also hier eigentlich jetzt wieder anknüpfen an diese Debatte Omri Böhm-Möllers, nämlich diese Frage, wie begründe ich jetzt den Universalismus? Ich kann das mit Kant prima machen und Omri Böhm beherrscht das perfekt. Reicht das aus oder müsste man nicht eine andere Begründung haben? Du bist ja auch jemand, der sagt, jetzt komme ich noch mal mit dem alten Königsberger an. Ich bin jetzt strukturell. Wir leben jetzt 2024, mir egal, was der da gesagt hat in Königsberg.
Naja, er hat ja in Tweet-Länge kommuniziert, was zumindest bei uns heute noch bleibt. Man muss ja nicht das ganze Buch lesen, um alles zu verstecken.
Aber ganz schlecht ist auch nicht, aber gut. Wir hören jetzt uns an, was Möllers jetzt also antwortet, nachdem ihr das gehört habt. Also Möllers knüpft jetzt an Böhm's Kritik der Identitätspolitik erst mal an.
Und warum ist Ihnen in gewisser Weise diese Selbstverständlichkeit verloren gegangen? Das hat natürlich erst mal, glaube ich, tatsächlich so ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass der Menschenrechtsdiskurs sehr lange Zeit mit einer gewissen Selbstverständlichkeit auf erstens mal seine eigene Referenz operieren konnte. Was meine ich damit? Man konnte sich relativ sicher sein, was eigentlich von Menschenrechten schwer für Menschenrechte geschützt sind, nämlich Menschen. Und diese Referenz ist in eine massive Krise geraten im Moment, dadurch dass wir im Grunde ein und ich will das gar nicht kritisch sagen, aber ich glaube, da liegt trotzdem ein funktionales Problem, ein komplett entgrenztes Menschenrechtsdiskurs haben, das angefängt mit Naturereignissen, mit Tieren, mit anderen Objekten, mit zukünftigen Generationen. In gewisser Weise die sagen, die gute normative Botschaft auf menschenbezogene Menschenrechts im Grunde zu sagen, auch in ihrer Subjektivität das Adressaten zu verallgemeinern. So noch der Motto, was für Menschen hilft, hilft auch für andere. Zum Beispiel für zukünftige Generationen, die ja keine Menschen sind, sondern erstmal eine demografische Fiktion.
Ja, also diese Ausweitung der Menschenrechte, glaube ich, ist schon etwas, was wir leben können und was man ja auch da beobachten kann, dass plötzlich Autokraten sich gerne auf die Menschenrechte anfangen zu beziehen.
Ja, aber nicht nur die Autokraten. Es ist auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht, da sagt der Bumer, darf sich nicht auf sein Menschenrecht auf Urlaub beziehen, wenn danach alle ab 2035 nicht mehr in den Urlaub dürfen. Die haben auch noch Freiheitsrechte.
Okay, aber wir haben…
Das ist noch nicht long term müssen, gegen den wir uns ja auch gestürzt.
Genau, aber den haben wir ja auch schon gesehen. Der anfängt schon bei D-Growth und dann weitergeht bis, ja, wir brauchen 1000 Mozart's in 1000 Jahren. Dann das Problem der Externalisierung.
Der dritte Punkt, der ein bisschen technischer ist, den ich mal ganz kurz erwähnen will, hängt damit zusammen, und das ist ein eigenes Thema, das ich gar nicht groß ansprechen will, aber das ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, dass mit der ökologischen Krise und gerade auch mit der Klimakrise der Zusammenhang zwischen Handlung und Verantwortung verloren gegangen ist. Weil wir im Grunde mittlerweile bei sehr vielen Handlungen, die wir machen, die auch legal sind und die auch geschützt sind, Externalitäten produzieren, Vulgo-CO2, die wir im Grunde selber nicht mehr irgendwie einfangen können. Und das scheint mir eine sehr wichtige Voraussetzung, jeder Form von subjektivem Rechtsschutz ist, aber auch individual. Jedes Form von individualer Rechtsschutz, aber auch von Menschenrechtsschutz zu sein, dass irgendwie Handlungen geschützt sind, deren Folgen irgendwie von denen, die handeln, eingefangen werden können und die sagen anderen nicht.
Ich meine, der Versuch wird unternommen, aber wir können es ganz konkret machen. Wenn der Netanyahu jetzt ein Zelt zerbombt, dann kann man den dafür zur Verantwortung ziehen. Wenn ich jetzt mit meinem Privatjet durch die Gegend fahre oder einfach mit meinem Linienflugzeug hin und her fliege, wenn ich die Heizung aufdrehe und das Fenster öffne, ich bekomme keine Strafen. Es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Es wird nicht geahndet, kann nicht geahndet werden. Ich verursache aber in anderen Teilen der Welt ein Desaster. Er beschreibt ja nur, dass es das schwierig macht. Dann sagt er auch, diese Überhöhung der Menschenrechte in Verbindung mit dem Grundgesetz ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Wir reden natürlich jetzt, wie wir heute über Menschenrechte reden, reden wir natürlich noch nicht so lange. Wir reden, weil wir sozusagen, wenn ich mal die bundesrepublikanische Gesellschaft reden darf, natürlich uns eine gewaltige Selbsterziehung irgendwie, Gott sei Dank, zugemutet hat, die uns sozusagen die Möglichkeit eröffnet, darüber zu reden. Gerade das Beispiel der Menschenwürde in Artikel 1 des Grundgesetzes ist ja ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass das erstmal ja doch ein bisschen was anderes war. Das war ja so ein bisschen säkularisiertes katholisches Naturrecht, das ja auch in den ersten zehn Jahren für manche Schandtat benutzt wurde, von der Penalisierung von Homosexualität bis sonst was. Und das ja sozusagen in seinem emanzipatorischen Glanz vermutlich eine Erfindung der 60er-,
70er-Jahre ist.
Also das ist natürlich gar kein normatives Argument dagegen, aber es zeigt natürlich schon, irgendwie kriegen wir die reine Sache nie, sondern wir kriegen sie halt doch immer nur als irgendwie ein Regime, das gepflegt werden will. Wo redet der da? Das klingt mir auch ein bisschen zu flapsig, ehrlich gesagt.
Der redet aber immer so. Das macht das auch mitunter sehr amüsant, sehr zurückgelehnt.
Das sind alles streitbare Punkte. Entgrenzung des Menschheitsbegriffs oder des Menschenbegriffs. Das sind so Dekos, die man sich in den 70er-Jahren angeheuchelt hat. Ich bin nicht so überzeugt.
Naja, aber es ist doch so, dass das Grundgesellschaft... Er bringt ja gerade das Homosexualität und der Strafbestand. Und dass man dann aber später, dass die Unantastbarkeit der Menschen würde, dass man dies dann zu einem emanzipatorischen Projekt macht oder beziehungsweise damit koppelt, dass das nicht so sein muss.
Vielleicht...
Damit sagt er doch nur, dass auch dies so eine Historicität hat. Und auch deswegen ja heute, also das bestätigt sich ja auch dadurch, dass man jetzt plötzlich das Thema Klima an Artikel 1 bindet. Das wäre ja selbst in den 80er-Jahren noch nicht denkbar gewesen.
Ja. Trotzdem hab ich was dagegen, wenn irgendetwas zu flapsig so abgeräumt wird, im Sinne von, ich sage ihnen nur, was historisch stattfindet, es wurde aussortiert. Und ich sag, nee, die Welt ist im Wandel. Und man kann auch sich ruhig mal den neuen und gegenwärtigen Phänomen zuwenden und erklären, warum etwas so ist, wie es ist. Und nicht, es funktioniert anders als früher. Ja, da sind ein paar Sachen rausgefallen.
Er stellt jetzt fest, es ist voraussetzungsreich. Jetzt haben wir es eben schon gesehen, also dieser antikoloniale Kampf dort in Neukalifornien, das hat auch viel mit Ökonomie zu tun. Und wir können ja auch sagen, dass wir jetzt über gewisse Dinge in Bezug auf Menschenrechte reden, hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass wir andere ökonomische Bedingungen haben. Das heißt, es ist also nicht einfach nur eine philosophische Überlegung und dann eine Begründung, die daraus abzuleiten ist. Und das ist ja sein Kontrapunkt zu Omri Boehm.
Und dann kann man sagen, na ja, okay, also es gibt vielleicht auch andere Rahmen, in denen es immer noch Indikatoren dafür gibt, dass es ein bisschen Freiheitsbedürfnis gibt. Wir können sagen, so lange Diktaturen Zwang anwenden müssen, ist da irgendwie noch was?
Das ist ja dann ein Argument von Fukuyama, dass man sagt, also eigentlich gibt es da schon so einen generellen Freiheitsdrang in den Menschen.
Man kann sich dann aber fragen, vielleicht ist das der Punkt auch irgendwann überschrieben, vielleicht muss man in China irgendwann keinen Zwang mehr ansetzen. Also ich weiß es nicht, aber man muss es jedenfalls beobachten, dass man glaube ich schon sagen kann, es gibt nichts daran ist selbstverständlich, dass sich Gesellschaften auf Menschenrechte berufen. Ich finde es gut, wenn sie es tun. Also ich habe ja keine normative Kritik an der Figur. Ich glaube nur, der Voraussetzungsreichtum ist doch immens. Und der wird sozusagen nicht erfüllt, dadurch, dass man weiß, wie man sie begründet. Das ist glaube ich erst mal nur der zentrale Punkt.
Braucht man die Begründung? Also du hast jetzt schon gesagt, wir können ja so ein paar Tweets von Kant lesen, aber wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht die Bücher.
Nur glaube ich tatsächlich, dass diese Begründung selbst eine freie Option ist und man auch auf die Begründung verzichten können muss. Das scheint mir sehr wichtig zu sein. Ich glaube, es gibt auch eine Freiheit vom Begründen. Und ich glaube, dass Leute sozusagen eine Ordnung beobachten können, sagen, ich will diese Ordnung oder ich will sie nicht. Ich will nicht leben wie in Russland. Und man ihnen sozusagen die Begründung nicht abverlangen muss dafür. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, so synchronistisch funktionieren Funktionale, funktionierende politische Gemeinschaften funktionieren so, dass manche Leute begründen viel, aber auch nicht. Und sich andere und ihre Überzeugung woandersher holen. Und vielleicht nicht unbedingt von Begründung überzeugt sind. Also da kommt halt sehr viel zusammen. Und ich glaube, ein Menschenrechtsdiskurs, der sozusagen sagt, ihr habt jetzt, mein bestes Argument für Menschenrechte ist ein politisches, ist ein moralisches. Ob ihr davon was habt, ob ihr damit ein schöneres Leben führt, ob das euren Interessen entspricht, das vergessen wir mal alles. Das ist halt ein Menschenrechtsdiskurs, der sozusagen die Menschenrechte selber eher in Abgrund führen würde. Da bin ich relativ sicher. Ja, also wir haben hier diese Beobachtung aus China, dass die kommunistische Partei ein klares Ziel hat, erstens an der Macht zu bleiben, zweitens vom Volk nicht bedroht zu werden. Und dann hatten sie ja gedacht, okay, wir nutzen mal Corona und machen ganz harte normative Beschränkungen. Jeder kriegt eine App und dann wird da einfach in rot-gelb-grün angezeigt, in dieser Straße darfst du gehen, in diesem Bus darfst du einsteigen, hier darfst du einkaufen, wie auch immer. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, nee, das funktioniert nicht. Also diese Normative, wir müssen die ganze Zeit begründen, Anweisungen geben, Befehl. Wir müssen so eine Etage weiter intrinsisch in die Menschen reinprogrammieren. Und dann von heute auf morgen Umstellung, nein, wir machen jetzt wieder das Aufstiegsversprechen, wir fördern und du bist bitte fleißig und findest den Weg selber.
Das heißt, es ist in deinem Interesse, dass du Chineser bist?
Genau, es ist einfach in deinem Interesse, du wirst ökonomisch erfolgreicher sein, das was du eigentlich willst. Also dieses Sicherheitsversprechen, du kriegst kein Corona, hat man wieder eingetauscht mit, du kannst dein Leben verwirklichen. Ein bisschen mehr als vorher und wenn man von heute auf morgen so schnell wie das aufgehoben wurde, also einfach mal so ein Tagesvergleich sieht, sieht man, okay, das ist wirklich ein krasser Umbau dieses ganzen Systems, der ja auch in diese Richtung wie er führt. Wenn die Chinesen jetzt dabei geblieben wären, 1 Milliarde Menschen jeden Morgen eine Stunde lang zu begründen, warum sie jetzt und Corona ist ganz gefährlich und dann kommt der nächste Film, der das nochmal zeigt. Wie auch immer, also dieses nordkoreanische Modell, wo alle in so einer Gesamtreligion irgendwie drinstecken, würde ich sagen, ja, aber es wäre doch sehr viel interessanter, wenn man das empirisch auf der Bühne zeigen würde, statt immer nur von der Begründung und wie kannt und hier ist der Untergang und so.
Ich bin ja kein Empiriker selbst und ich brauche nicht immer Empirie, wenn das kluge Argument kann ja da sein. Also was doch erstmal verständlich ist, ist, dass wir doch auch jetzt, nehmen wir mal einen anderen Begriff als die Menschenrechte, wir haben den Begriff der Demokratie. Und man redet jetzt gerade allen Leuten ein, dass sie die Demokratie zu lieben haben. Jetzt sehen wir, dass vierköpfige Familien in zwei Zimmerhausen seit drei Jahren Wohnungen suchen. Und denen kann ich jetzt zurufen, gell, das ist doch schön mit der Demokratie, freust du dich schon, nächsten Monat kannst du wählen gehen.
Herrlich.
Nein, ich kann nur deren Grundlage verbessern. Also das heißt, die Demokratie und die Menschenrechte sind also auch unter gewissen Voraussetzungen nur dann wirklich etwas, was erstrebt wird. Ich kann das immer noch mit Kant dann genau begründen, warum das so richtig ist. Aber es scheint doch sehr stark durch die faktische Realität relativiert zu werden. Und das ist ja etwas, was er hier deutlich macht, wenn er auch sagt, es muss auch um Interessen der Bürger gehen und das darf man nicht ganz ignorieren.
Also sagen, dass die Kontamination des Diskurses mit Bedürfnissen, mit Interessen, mit eigenen Angelegenheiten, die gerade nicht universalisierbar sind, scheint mir zu sagen, eine Bewegung der notwendigen Bedingungen überhaupt einer funktionierenden Menschenrechtspraxis zu sein. Das würde ich sagen, ich habe nichts dagegen, ich unterhalte mich gerne gelehrt über Kanntagsegäse oder über andere Autorinnen, was man Menschenwürde hat. Ich glaube, nur eine politische Ordnung funktioniert so gar nicht. Ja, das finde ich sehr gut. Also es ist sehr gut, dass wir diese Clips als Clips gucken und nicht zusammen still in einem Vortrag sitzen, wo das einfach an uns vorbei rauscht, weil wir jetzt einfach rein plausibilisieren können. Ein Diskurs über 75 Jahre Grundgesetz hat ganz wenig Sinn, wenn Journalisten dastehen und die Gelegenheit nutzen, dass diejenigen, die gerade das Grundgesetz abfeiern, auch nochmals zum Sylt-Video sagen. Und dann sagt der, möchte gern Kanzler Laschet. Sehr gut, die haben alle ihren Job verloren. Die Bundestagspräsidentin sagt, sehr gut, dass wir da Gesetze haben, wir sollten die Höchststrafe anwenden. Fünf Jahre Gefängnis. Das ist ja original Bärbel Bars. Hat sie wirklich gesagt. Laschet und Bars haben genau das gesagt, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Laschet hat sich darüber gefreut, dass alle ihren Job verloren haben. Sehr gut. Und Bärbel Bars hat gesagt, gut, dass wir Gesetze haben, wir sollten die Höchststrafen hier auch mal in Betracht ziehen. Also fünf Jahre Gefängnis.
Sie gibt jetzt auch schon Empfehlungen raus an die Richter.
Und jetzt haben wir im Kontrast seine Aussage. Armin Laschet, Bärbel Bars, alle Bundestagsabgeordneten und Steinmeier, der uns nochmal erklärt, das Grundgesetz ist das Beste, was Deutschland je hervorgebracht hatte. Das sind alles Leute, die haben diese Grundbedürfnisse nicht.
Die sind einfach befriedigt.
Die können reisen, die kriegen immer alle Informationen, die sie brauchen. Also Information, Transportation ist schon mal geregelt. Wenn sie Hunger haben, sagen sie einfach zu, dass sie heute Abend nochmal vorbeikommen, weil es ist ein bewirteter Termin. Es ist immer ein bewirteter Termin, wenn die abends eingeladen sind. Und sie haben jeden Abend eine stehende Einladung, irgendwo, irgendeinem Verband wird sie schon verköstigen.
Irgendwo öffnet sich wieder eine Flasche.
Und ja, darüber muss man mal ernsthaft diskutieren, ob wir nicht das Grundgesetz lieber mit denjenigen, die 10 Millionen Menschen in überbelegten Wohnungen, ob wir es mit denen mal feiern sollten und dann ernsthaft diskutieren, was hat es uns gebracht, müssen wir es weiterentwickeln, worauf können wir stolz sein, was ist scheiße. Kann ja alle Fragen mal offen den Raum stellen. Weil, dass uns die durchbefriedigten Eliten unseres Landes, die von ökonomischer Logik keine Ahnung haben, weil sie sich die ganze Zeit von der Politik institutionell hofieren lassen, dass mit denen kein Staat zu machen ist und auch keine Diskussion über den Staat. Ja, aber ich finde, da sollte man, wenn man auf einer Bühne die Gelegenheit hat, zu diesem Thema zu reden, sollte man es wirklich plausibilisieren an dieser Gegenwärtigkeit.
Gut, es war hier ein philosophischer Diskurs, aber wir hören ihn jetzt noch zum Schluss, weil die Leute ein bisschen irritiert sind jetzt auch im Publikum hier, weil doch universalistisch und das muss doch begründet werden. Und ich bin mir auch noch nicht sicher, ob ich nicht doch auch am Ende ein orthodoxer Kantianer da bin und sage, wir müssen das aber alles ganz klar begründen. Und er sagt jetzt so, naja, das passt.
Du kannst dich doch gerne in die Studierstube zurückziehen und noch mal Kant lesen. Das kann doch jeder machen, jemand, der das recht hat.
Ich hab ja auch Kant-Seminare besucht. Wir hören jetzt aber, warum er so mit Demokratie viel anfangen kann und Menschenrechte.
Also bevor sich jetzt hier alle umfallen, würde ich tatsächlich sagen, für mich persönlich ist, glaube ich, also meine Begründungsperspektive für eine demokratische Ordnung ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich eigentlich eine katholisch-christliche. Ich würde sagen, also aus religiösen Gründen, glaube ich, daran, dass alle Menschen gleich sind und dass diese Gleichbehandlung sich auch, sagen wir, in politischen Realitäten realisieren muss. Das ist eine sehr idiosynkratische Form vom politischen Linkskatholizismus, die ich vertrete, von der um Gottes Willen, die um Gottes Willen niemand anders vertreten soll. Ja, um Gottes Willen. Und die auch gar nicht irgendwie, sozusagen, darauf angewiesen ist, dass andere sich vertreten. Aber das ist sozusagen meine. Und ich glaube, es ist gerade wichtig zu sagen, dass ich mit einem sehr schrägen, persönlichen Weltbild sozusagen vielleicht in der demokratischen Ordnung lande, wo andere Leute mit anderen seltsamen Weltbildern da auch landen. Und wo mich diese Beobachtung halt gegenüber der Formulierung, naja, wir brauchen eben eine Begründung. Und wenn wir eine Begründung haben, brauchen wir eigentlich auch eine gemeinsame Begründung. Trotzdem ein bisschen Misstrau, stimmt. Also, das ist nicht nur schräg, das ist absurd. Er hat zum einen ein universalistisches Weltbild, das aber nicht alle teilen müssen. Es ist ein kleiner Privatspaß. Ich denke mir, ne, man sollte dann doch ein Weltbild finden, gerade ein universalistisches.
Dann bist du jetzt doch der Kantianer.
Ja, da auf jeden Fall, total. Und deswegen auch, und da bin ich auch Kantianer, man kann sich nicht die Religion als Grundlage raussuchen, weil die ist wirklich nicht anschlussfähig.
Er macht das ja nur für sich. Also er will ja keinen Anschluss haben. Er sagt einfach, ich gehe davon aus, aufgrund meiner Religion, dass die Menschen gleich sind, das passt gut zu Demokratie und Menschenrechte.
Jetzt hast du ja vorhin gefragt, hat Putin Tucker Carlson eine halbe Stunde lang verarscht, veralbert, vorgeführt? Jetzt frag ich dich, wenn jemand als Universalismus-Philosoph vor Publikum, also der Mann ist Staatsrechtler, Anschluss suchend, ein Staatsrechtler, der aber an dem Abend einen philosophischen Diskurs auf Anschluss suche mit Publikum. Er redet und dann am Ende aber die Pointe macht, ich machs religiös und ich weiß, nicht alle sind Christen. Übrigens einer der größten Problemherde auf dieser Welt, den wir haben. Und zweitens, und damit sage ich Ihnen nur, wie ich darüber denke, mein Universalismus-Bild muss aber nicht von anderen geteilt werden. Da frag ich dich, hat er die da alle gerade veralbert?
Nein, die Frage ist ja, ob er überhaupt diese Art von Universalismus gut findet, oder ob er also er teilt die Werte der Menschenrechte und der Demokratie. Würde aber sagen, eine universalistische Begründung mit Kant ist nicht notwendig, um Demokrat zu sein und um für die Menschenrechte zu sein. Ja, es führt vielleicht sogar genau in das Gegenteil, bzw. bringt es nicht wirklich weiter, wenn man nicht die Voraussetzungen für Demokratie und Menschenrechte sieht. Das meinen zum Beispiel auch so etwas wie Ökonomie. Und dann kann man sich nochmal selbst fragen, warum sieht man das eigentlich so? Also warum ist man eigentlich Demokrat? Und dann kann man das ja für sich irgendwie begründen. Und das tut er jetzt religiös. Und sagt, deswegen gefällt mir das gut. Und ich glaube, was er da macht, ist wirklich nicht das Publikum einfangen, sondern es maximal provozieren, indem er sagt, der ist bei der Evangelischen Akademie. Der sitzt da und sagt, ja, der Linkskatastrophizismus, der hat mir immer gut gefallen.
Gut, lass mich mal mit einer Poete schließen. Thematisch, wir holen es ganz gegenwärtig. Wir haben auch Fragen bekommen. Ich hatte mir so ein paar E-Mails rausgeschrieben, machen wir dann vor dem Salon nächste Woche. Aber eine Frage war, sollte man echt so viele Biologie-Grundbegriffe ins politische Denken rüberholen? Wie zum Beispiel, warum nicht Regression? Warum verfolgt ihr dem Selk und sagt, Devolution? Also das Gegenteil von Evolution. Denn Evolution ist ja ein biologischer Grundbegriff. Und meine Antwort ist da, naja, weil wir bei der Evolution als biologischen Vorgang es mit einer durchschaubaren Rationalität zu tun haben, die aber keinem Bewusstsein folgt. Wir können mit ihr nicht diskutieren. Wir können sie nur verstehen, aber können nicht mit ihr diskutieren. Und das ist sehr einladend, weil wir in der Soziologie oder in der Gesellschaft selbst sehr viele Vorgänge haben, bei der die einen strukturell realistisch rangehen, der andere liest nochmal Kant und so. Aber der Lauf der Dinge, der ist davon unberührt. Und in diesem Themenkomplex gucken wir jetzt ganz gegenwärtig nach Indien zu einer Sachlage, die so viele Menschen betrifft, wie wir es uns nicht vorstellen können. Das ist nicht nur ganz Europa, sondern das ist ganz Europa mal zwei und noch mehr. Wir reden jetzt hier über Indien, Pakistan. Da leben 1,6 Milliarden Menschen. Das übersteigt alles. Das übersteigt sogar die Einwohnerzahl Afrikas. Also das ist wirklich gigantisch. Und jetzt haben wir es da mit handlungsleitenden Problemen aller Menschen zu tun, die wir nachvollziehen können, die wir verstehen können. Es gibt große Wissenschaft, aber wir können mit der Ursache einfach nicht diskutieren. Das Schicksal stürzt einfach auf diese Menschen herein, auf eine Art und Weise, wie wir es uns, für uns nicht vorstellen können. Also ich weiß nicht, wir sitzen jetzt hier langärmlich und es ist Mai. Sobald die Temperatur über 26 Grad sind, wird es mir zu warm. Wir können uns nicht vorstellen, was hier in Pakistan gerade abläuft.
51 Grad werden für den kommenden Sonntag vorhergesagt in der südpakistanischen Provinz sind mit der 15 Millionen Einwohner Stadt Karachi. Und auch in anderen Regionen von Pakistan könnte es ähnliche Temperaturen geben. Die Behörden bereiten sich nach Berichten pakistanischer Medien auf den Katastrophenfall vor. Sie stellen kühle Räume als Notunterkünfte zur Verfügung, es gibt große Wasservorräte und Krankenhäuser bereiten sich auf Hitzeopfer vor. Alle Schulen sind bis Ende des Monats geschlossen. Die Regierung erklärte, die Temperaturen seien derzeit 4 bis 6 Grad höher als üblich, betroffen seien davon alle flacheren Landesteile. Befürchtet wird auch, dass die große Hitze die Gletscher im Himalaya schneller schmelzen lässt und es in der Folge zu Flutwellen und Überschwemmungen kommen könnte. Pakistan gehört zu den Ländern, die am meisten vom Klimawandel betroffen sind. Vor zwei Jahren waren weite Teile des Landes überflutet worden, zuvor hat es auch eine schwere Hitzewelle gegeben, es folgten heftige Regenfälle und eine massive Gletscherschmelze.
So, 51 Grad heißt Feuchtugeltemperatur. Das haben wir im nomadischen Jahrhundert. Der Schweiß auf der Haut und die Verdunstung reicht nicht mehr, um die Körpertemperatur auf unter 36 oder 36 Grad zu halten. Also es ist eine akut tödliche Temperatur. So, 51 Grad, das war jetzt ein Clip aus der ersten Hälfte des Mai. Und ich wollte ja, habe eben gesagt, ich hole das Ganze ins Gegenwärtige jetzt gerade. Also in Neu-Deli, in Delhi, die jemals krass gemesseste Temperatur, 52,3 Grad. Also wir wissen, ich habe eben gesagt, wie viele Leute da leben. Ich will jetzt mal runterbrechen. Der ORF zum Beispiel informiert, in Pakistan wurde gestern in der Stadt Jakobadab, Jako-da-dab, ne Babat, so Jakobabad, 51 Grad gemessen. Es handelt sich um die bisher höchste Temperatur, die dieses Jahr auf der Erde gemessen wurde. In dieser Stadt leben 191.000 Einwohner. In den 70ern lebten dort weniger als 60.000. Also da können wir schon mal im nomadischen Jahrhundertstile, da leben ganz schön viele Menschen, die sind entweder dahin gezogen oder die sind so jung, also die brechen eh gerade ins Leben auf oder die sind da gar nicht verankert, weil die können auch woanders leben. So, der Stern. Extreme Hitze in Pakistan. Es ist, als würde man buchstäblich in der Hölle leben, sagt dort einer. Man hat das Gefühl, auf brennenden Kohlen zu laufen, wenn man in die Sonne tritt. In dem Falle Zitate von Zeeshan Khan Shani, ein Rikscha-Fahrer in Dadu. Ich gehe also zu Wikipedia, gucke, Dadu. 170.000 Einwohner, in den 70ern 30.000. Also bei der Frage, kann das wirklich stimmen mit dieser These? Ein Grad mehr bedeutet eine Milliarde mehr Menschen in Bewegung. Ja, wo kommen die her? Daher. Warum? Weil die nichts mit Dadu zu tun haben. Da ist nicht irgendwie der Opa hat schon immer hier und so, sondern da leben einfach Menschen, die nichts damit zu tun haben. Dann gibt es hier diese Region, das ist ganz Pakistan, hier unten rot, sind 55 Millionen Einwohner. Das ist mehr als halb Deutschland, da unten mal so an der Ecke, wo man eigentlich, ja, und es ist da nicht mal besonders dicht besiedelt oder so. Also das ist wirklich crazy. Und in Indien hat man jetzt eine neue Vorkehrung getroffen. Es gibt heute einen Wasserminister in der Region Delhi, Atishi Malena, was dann dazu führt, unter anderem sollen in mehreren Gegenden von Delhi einstweilen nur noch einmal täglich Wasser geliefert werden. Also da gibt es gar keine Wasserleitung, sondern da wird Frischwasser hingefahren. Was jetzt bedeutet, in einigen Regionen Indiens, die jetzt gerade 51, 52, 53 Grad erleben, gibt es für 15 bis 20 Minuten Wasser am Tag. Das ist die Realität. Da liest keiner Kant? Da will auch keiner wissen, was irgendwo mal irgendwann...
Da will auch keiner was jetzt abstraktes zum Thema Menschenrechte oder so hören.
Hier regiert einfach die Gegenwart, und zwar so, wie es sie vorher nicht gab. Weshalb man automatisch... Ja, wir müssen jetzt hier mal Begriffe entgrenzen und so weiter. Das fühlt jetzt gar nicht... Also hier muss man jetzt ernsthaft über Sachen nachdenken. Weshalb ich jetzt sage, wir brauchen jetzt mal neue Grundbegriffe und wir holen sie uns von Eckhard von Hörschausen. Der war im Table Media Podcast zu Gast. Und wir hören mal zwei Ausschnitte, die ich sehr interessant fand und die wir dann für uns mitnehmen können. Zum einen die Sollastalgie.
Gerade zum Beispiel dieses Thema Natur hat auch in Deutschland Riesenzustimmung. Wenn wir jetzt den Frühling haben, wenn wir merken, Mensch, früher waren da mehr Singvögel. Warum sind die nicht mehr da? Weil die Insekten weg sind. Warum sind die Insekten weg? Weil wir eine Landwirtschaft machen mit extrem viel Einsatz von Dünger und Pestiziden. Also wenn man den Leuten erklärt, dass sie einen hohen Preis zahlen für die Körperliche und, das ist mir auch neuerdings ein sehr großes Thema geworden, die seelische Gesundheit. Ich war hier auf dem Psychiater Kongress der GPPN auch dieses Jahr wieder als keynote speaker auch mit einer Arbeitsgruppe zu Solastalgie. Solastalgie ist das Wort dafür, dass der Trost, den die Natur uns eigentlich spendet, schwindet. Dass ich durch den Wald gehe und ich bin Berliner, ich bin mit meinem Vater hier durch den Grunewald. Und diese Lebendigkeit, die gibt es nicht mehr. Wenn Menschen sagen, Waldbaden ist gesund und vier von fünf Bäumen sind laut aktuellem Schadensbericht tot oder kaputt, dann spüren wir das. Dann wird aus einer Naherholung eine Nahtoderfahrung.
Also die Solastalgie. Man fühlt sich nicht mehr zu Hause und trauert darüber. Jetzt gibt es einige Comedians auf der Bühne. Ich habe den Namen nicht präsent, aber ich habe einen kleinen Mitschnitt auf YouTube gestellt, in dem noch mal dargestellt wird, all diese Long-Term-Missen-Ideen. Nicht als Long-Term-Missen, aber Elon Musk will irgendwie die Menschheit interstellar machen. Und Jeff Bezos ja auch. Nur überall auf der Welt, überall im Universum wäre es schlechter als auf der Erde. Also selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen, in Indien ist es richtig scheiße, 52,3 Grad. Was bedeutet, es ist ja nur ein paar Wochen im Jahr, aber innerhalb dieser Zeit sind drei Stunden draußen tödlich. Also du kannst einfach nicht vor die Tür gehen. So, und das ist trotzdem noch unter allen Gesichtspunkten die beste vorstellbare Welt ist immer noch hier im Vergleich zu Mars oder Venus. 500 Grad und die ganze Zeit explodiert da so irgendwelche Gase, die dich sofort verbrennen und du kannst da nichts bauen und hast überhaupt keine Materialien. Also auf der Erde ist es immer am besten, selbst unter diesen Gesichtspunkten gibt es keine weiteren Auswege. Und wir werden auch in Deutschland so eine Erlebnisse haben, dass Menschen einfach in ihren Wohnungen sitzen und nicht wissen, wo sie hingehen können.
Wenn sie nögen Platz haben in ihren Wohnungen.
Genau, wenn man einen Keller hat, könnte man auch in einen Keller gehen und sich davon so 5 Grad Minus versprechen, im unmittelbaren Erleben. Oder, und das ist ja das Bild, auf das ich so warte und das man auch mal kabarettistisch vorbereiten könnte, Rentner, die tagsüber einfach in ihrem Auto sitzen, die nicht irgendwo hinfahren oder so, sondern die einfach nur gucken, ob der Strom noch reicht, um die Klimaanlage zu betreiben. Weil das der einzige Ort ist, wo sie hin können, wo eine Klimaanlage ist. So, und das Bild muss man sich mal vor Augen führen einfach. So ein Straßenzug von geparkten Autos und in jedem zweiten sitzt einfach so ein älteres Ehepaar drin, weil es einfach nirgendwo anders hin kann. Und der Agent, der da dahinter steckt, der politische Akteur, mit dem ist nicht zu diskutieren. Wir können ihn, und das machen wir jetzt seit Jahren, einfach, gibt's eine Statistik kurz vorm Wetterbericht und so, wo nochmal erklärt wird, wie krass es jetzt ist, aber man kommt da einfach nicht raus. Und über die Medizin kann man ja diesen biologischen Grundbegriff, Brückenschlag, immer schön machen. Und deswegen hier nochmal Hirschhausen zum zweiten.
Und wenn die Klimakrise das Fieber von Mutter Erde ist, dann ist das Artensterben ihre Demenz. Demenz ist das krankhafte Vergessen von dem, was man schon mal gewusst hat. Jede Art enthält die Weisheit, die Innovation, die von Versuch und Irrtum, von Mutation, Selektion über Millionen Jahre Wissen, wie geht Leben auf diesem Planeten gesammelt hat. Und mit jeder Art, die weg ist und zwar irreversibel, für immer weg, fehlt auch dieses Wissen. Und wenn man dieses Netz sich vorstellt, jeder der Kinder hat, kennt dieses Phänomen, dass man so Klettertürme auf dem Spielplatz hat und man denkt, oh Gott, dreijährige klettern hoch, wie tief können die fallen? Ah, da ist noch eine andere Lage unten drunter. Und mit jedem Knotenpunkt, mit jeder Art, die weg ist, fehlt sozusagen eines dieser Sicherungssysteme und irgendwann fallen wir ins Bodenlose.
Also die Fallhöhe wird immer höher. Erderwärmung ist Fieber, Artensterben ist Demenz. Und noch haben wir dieses sich selbst regulierende System Natur, nur wenn sie zerstört ist, ist sie zerstört. Und auf dem Weg zur Zerstörung wird sie die Natur nicht weiter stören. Also wir sind die Einzigen, die das beobachten, dass es halt so ist. Du hast es ja auch immer wieder betont. Und damit ist aber auch echt nicht zu diskutieren. Also es gibt da keine Philosophie oder so.
Nee.
Und da werden auch alle, alle herrenidealistischen Konzepte sofort zusammenbrechen bei 52 Grad.
Und das vorbei.
Sagt niemand mehr in irgendeiner Weise, ich muss mal gucken, ob das auch mit einer universalistischen Begründung einhergeht. Es spielt keine Rolle mehr. Insofern ist da der pragmatische Ansatz angesagt. Wir sind gespannt, mit welchem Pragmatismus wir uns dann der großen Außenpolitik nähern mit Richard David Precht. Nochmal, wir lesen das Jahrhundert der Toleranz. Stefan hat schon einige Bücher angekündigt. Ich habe auch schon gesagt, ich werde mal alles auf den Kopf stellen mit Philipp Manow. Ich werde sagen, vielleicht haben wir gar keinen Demokratiedefizit. Vielleicht ist das auch eine eigenartige Ideologie mit der liberalen Demokratie. Müssen wir jetzt also am Ende böse Buben verteidigen aus Ungarn oder der Türkei? Wir werden sehen. Jedenfalls bin ich gespannt auf unsere Diskussion. Und man kann dieser Diskussion dann folgen, wenn man in den Salon kommt. Das ist also der Zusatz-Content zu diesem Podcast. Man kann diesen Podcast dann auch überall hören, wenn man ihn abonniert hat. Man muss nicht vor dem Laptop sitzen, sondern man kann den dann immer so hören wie alle anderen Folgen, regulären Folgen auch. Das ist möglich über Steady. Da geht man über neu20er.de drauf. Man kann auch über Spotify auf den Button klicken. Dann kommt man auch zu dem Steady-Abo. Sonst kann man es noch über Patreon oder Apple abschließen. Dann freue ich mich auf die nächste Woche.
Sehr gut. Bis dahin.
Bis dahin.
Und immer schön kühl bleiben.